I judge and jury I'm getting guilty so
lock me up for ke
oh oh
yeah lock me
[Music]
upy lock me
up
baby it's a lock down baby can drive me
crazy overing and love is do time you're
my attorney my judge and jury I'm
brething guilty Sal me
up you got to take to keep my Lo me
up keep
in
Lo
[Music]
hey pretty baby come and save me I got a
conv for you call me crazy but I may be
committing a crime of the first degree
I'm not pretending I mean what I'm
saying I'm coming in with My Hands Held
High got to face it I'm not going to
make it without your love and I got
nowhere to go don't you see what you
doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby
[Music]
hang
hello everybody and welcome to night two
of giant bombs E3 2017 coverage I'm Jeff
gersman wow we've got an action-packed
even scheduled for you for the next
thousand hour I don't know that we're
going to go until the sun comes up I
think one of these nights here but we're
starting the show with a show stopper
welcome back to uh our set here Phil
Spencer the head of Xbox how you doing
sir I'm doing well thanks for having me
yeah this it's great yeah uh so wow uh
last year you know talking about project
Scorpio and laying out the vision uh for
kind of the future of the Xbox ecosystem
I guess yeah and now here here we are a
year later and and you've got an actual
form factor and launch date and price
and all this stuff uh how's it been over
the last year kind of as you know
running this this ship as the watching
the reaction of of people kind of
getting used to this concept yeah it's a
good question you know we obviously
rolling in last year's E3 we knew the
box that we were going to go build
because we wouldn't announce it if we
didn't but we also knew we had some
engineering work to go do so there was
some question about whether we would
announc it on stage I think we talked
about that a little bit last year but we
also knew that we wanted to and
developers would start getting it
through the year so we felt okay let's
just put it out there so we're not kind
of in hide mode and it was we've seen
some good momentum we had obviously the
digital Foundry work where they were
able to get a console and come up and
visit us and talk about it seems smart
to get that out there rather than just
let them leak it eventually because it
seems like that's how a lot of this
stuff goes these days and also our show
here you know I I had Kareem out on
stage it was great having our one of our
head Engineers come out and talk about
but I didn't want to spend a lot of time
at E3 going through speeds and feeds and
all this stuff so having digital Foundry
kind of tear the box down and talk about
what they thought I thought was good and
it's been nice I've been using uh the
box at home for a couple months now as
my main console which gave us a lot of
confidence coming into E3 we've had
games up and running for a while
starting in about January uh so feeling
feeling good about the program still
have to ship right so we've given the
date November 7th uh the name the price
uh we'll talk more about pre-order
coming up but we obviously still have to
get done but it look looks good yeah and
and it's uh you know it's given people I
you know it's a very different market
now or or I guess the the console Cycles
feel weird now uh you have Sony out
there with the the pro uh you know you
have the Xbox One X you know coming and
do you feel like that this is kind of
just that this is the way forward and
now we'll see every four years or so
that that this this is kind of how we're
going to go or do you think that we'll
kind of reset and you'll go like okay
now we've got a whole new Xbox platform
uh starting from scratch not kind of hey
this backwards comp compatibility you
know Sony do the PlayStation 5 and yeah
we do it all over again or is it kind of
going to be like this like phones almost
you know it's probably not the answer I
should say but I don't know um you know
I'm watching and one of the things that
you mentioned the games industry is
different now and that's absolutely true
like if I look at the top games that
people are playing on Xbox Xbox one
today many of those games are 3 four
years old right and that didn't used to
be the case like when I was back I I
kind of bought a cartridge I plugged it
in my N64 I finished that game took that
cartridge out put the next cartridge in
so you you kind of had a natural recycle
of the content right which meant I think
that the generation step function that
we had with consoles uh felt more
natural but now I mean you saw it what
was it April when Black Ops 2 hit back
compat right and what it hit like top 10
on NPD sales and you can imagine on Xbox
Live the thing was massive yeah and
that's a game that's people been playing
for years GTA 5 is a beast on Xbox One
Minecraft I mean these so you get these
games that actually stretch out over
years which didn't used to be the case
and I think that does impact the
platform and the hardware that we build
for sure and that's something you know
we we tend to focus or you know I I
think the the traditional way to kind of
focus on game sales and a lot of the
stuff
we think about opening week the same way
the movie industry would do it's like
what's the what's the opening week take
you know where are they at with it uh
what's the first month and it really
just seems like or what are the
pre-order numbers even that's right it
seems like that stuff while not
unimportant is just mattering less and
less as time goes on do you do you see
what on the software side it's just
definitely like longer taale as we get
more into this kind of software as the
service and updates and this sort of
stuff it's it's even more impactful than
longer tail sometimes you see see things
start small and actually get bigger over
time I think Arc is a great example of
that player unknown great example of
that these games that come out and
actually get bigger as more people play
and the verality of just people watching
other people play or seeing their
friends play those things it impacts E3
even because E3 I mean you and I know
this because E3 was traditionally about
a bunch of gamees Publishers bringing
their games here so the retailers could
come to see what was going to be good so
they could put their pre-orders in so we
would then make enough cartridges and
discs for the fall so that when the
games hit you could actually they
weren't sold out right and that's where
pre-order came from and all this other
and now you walk the show floor and it's
as much about twitch and Facebook and
mixer and people and the influencers as
it is about the actual games you got a
booth for a game like law Breakers which
is a you know service-based online game
I think it it impacts everything that we
do I think it's a good thing but it does
mean that you have to kind of have your
head up and be reacting and and trying
to trying to predict where this business
is going definitely I mean you know
you've got people waiting in line in
your booth to play Minecraft yeah and
that's that's not a knock on Minecraft I
really enjoy Minecraft but at the same
time it's like this the game's out like
I know there's an update coming but like
if if there are games you're here to see
like Minecraft is out you're absolutely
right and I mean M M it it's ours so
it's weird when I talk about it too much
but uh it shipped in 2009 right and our
biggest month ever was December of this
last year and so it's another example of
something that gets bigger I think it's
good for the industry as a whole because
it means that game Publishers and
developers can have more predictable
Revenue over a longer period of time
which keeps them healthy so they invest
in new things and we see things like
Anthem and Destiny 2 and other big
things coming which is great one of the
things I worry about and I've talked
about a little bit are the kind of
single player story driven games cuz
it's hard when so much of the gameplay
that happens on a daily basis is on
these games that are long and growing
and service based and then you get a
smaller single player game and what's
how does it find its audience when so
many hours are taking up because people
aren't finishing the games that they are
playing exactly and you get these
comparisons that people have to make of
just like well it's $60 either way am I
going to get you know a game like to
that I'm gonna play for potentially 400
hours or something I'm 700 okay that's
that's I at some point had to do other
things you're smar than yeah uh or am I
going to get a you know 12-h hour
campaign that's right you know and and I
think that that's that's been
interesting to watch cuz I think back to
yeah when I was a kid I wanted games
that were going to last me a long time
because they were expensive I went and
bought whole the story but I went and
bought Strider on the Genesis for $80
brought it home finished it and I was
crushed I was like that was $80 spent on
that thing I remember when the closing
credits would come up on a game and it
made me sad like I didn't want to balers
gate I finished that game I'm like I
love this game no this they put out an
expansion what and they did
but then it now like people and it's
right that game designers have looked at
that mechanic and said hey how do we go
and just make a game around I mean
Destiny is kind of one of the division
like these games that actually are just
about perpetuating the gameplay which
like I said is I think a very healthy
thing uh but it does change the industry
it changes our Hardware road map it
changes compatibility it's one of the
reasons I like bringing the original
Xbox compatibility 360 compatibility
back it's because I want some of those
old games should also get played in this
time and even things like Game Pass for
us and I'm trying to think about how
maybe I don't want to go spend $60 on a
game that I think has a beginning and
middle and end that I can actually see I
hope it never gets to that but certain
people might have that mentality maybe
there's a different business model we
can put and I don't know if it's going
to work but we're going to try because I
want all kinds of games to be successful
I don't think we want to see the the
death of games that have a beginning and
middle and an end definitely do do you
think that Xbox game pass I mean so that
that is 100 games right now uh a yeah it
sounds like games will kind of rotate in
and out of that do you ever foresee in
in the the near future what do you think
a game would launch on Game Pass are you
kind of strictly looking at it as like
you know anything that's like an Xbox
One Piece of software maybe has to be
like you know it'll be nine months old
or something like that before no I want
to see I don't think it's for every game
with with launch game pass but uh I've
said this before I see what's happened
in television and I think we have some
great television being created right now
high quality good investment in the
content and it's because the business
model of subscription has allowed people
like Netflix HBO Amazon to invest in
some great television and Game Pass
games are structurally different than
television so I I don't know if it'll be
exactly the same but when we announced
Game Pass Shannon Loftus and I were
getting a ton of pings from external
developers that said hey maybe this is
the way that I can launch my episodic
game right maybe this is the way I can
launch M and it doesn't mean you
wouldn't also be able to just go buy the
thing if you wanted to uh I hope so like
I hope the model there is we share back
money right that comes through that
system so it it and if that can fund
those kind of games being developed uh
single player even episodic games uh
then I think it's a it's a good thing
and I'd love to see it on more platforms
it's something that I I've been hoping
that someone would figure out uh before
too long is how to do something that
that kind of resembles this like Netflix
for games idea and you know you always
it's something with everyone always says
like this is what Nintendo needs to do
instead of Virtual Console oneoff sale
like do a subscription thing and it
sounds like they might get into that and
then you know to see Xbox game pass come
along and be you know actually
downloading the games you know Sony's
had the streaming stuff and it's similar
it is uh and if it there's not PSN now I
thought was a something that was
Innovative for Sony to go and and do and
I I want to be share what we learn with
game pass because again as an industry I
don't want everything to turn into one
kind of game I think a diversity in the
kinds of Gam games that we can play is
just a good thing uh for the industry
yeah and it seems like we're we're maybe
at that point in I mean if you think
about it as the way that the console
Cycles went before like this is the
point where you really start seeing
those wider games you know the the more
broad approach to kind of hitting
everyone with different types of games
well we tried to do that on our stage
this year one of the games I was really
proud of on our stage was super lucky
tales and you know it's one of those
games that at least from a style happens
usually later in a console cycle turns
out it's a it's a real game a little bit
like ory like real game difficult game
uh good challenge but it's we had the 42
games you know go all the pr stuff but
uh the diversity of games that we were
able to get to show on our stage I do
think you're right is kind of part of
where we are in this console Generation
Um and I wanted to make sure we had you
know from Metro to Super thing luy
tailes to Fort I wanted to make sure
that that breadth of what this industry
is able to create shows up on the stage
yeah so super lucky stale follow up to a
VR game game yeah uh I it seemed sounded
like that there was some talk ahead of
the press conference that maybe VR
wouldn't be a focus and sure enough not
really mention and that's led to some
talk uh where do you kind of put your
commitment to VR right now now that it's
been out in the marketplace for a while
how are you feeling about it uh I'm
long-term bullish on we call it mixed
reality but like VR well we call it
mixed reality not for any kind of weird
naming reason I do think augmented ity
things like Pokémon go and and virtual
reality kind of an completely enclosed
immersive experience I do think there's
convergence in technology that should
happen in those worlds so it seems like
we'll eventually get clear glasses that
can black out that's exact that's
exactly so anyway long term I'm a big
believer in the category I think it's
incredibly immersive uh I think you can
deliver uh a feeling that whether it's
vertigo or you know a sense of of new
space and environment that is just
incredible and I I can't wait to see
that come to uh to mass Market games and
see what developers and creators are
able to do my view is in kind of in the
family room environment we're probably a
few years away from it being something
that will really work I think you know
the cords are kind of an issue um that
said I think the manufacturers that are
out there have it's great that people
that as an industry we investing whether
it's psvr whether it's Hollow lens
whether it's HTC Oculus I mean this is
what the games industry should be about
is investing in new technology our
investment is on the window side right
now we've kind of we built Scorpio we
said this last year the power of the box
is fine for for controlling a for having
a VR Mr Experience run on it it's really
that family room environment that we're
struggling a little bit with and we're
saying okay well let's stay more on on
the PC where we're seeing action and and
developer interest uh until we really
get the art form of what it means to
create great uh Mr experiences and then
it can go to more places I do think we
need to lose the chords at some point
yeah you know I think we're a few years
from that I've gotten pretty good at
stepping over him but but yeah
definitely you know you think about like
oh I'm completely immersed in this weird
space doing this other thing but somehow
there's still some part of my lizard
brain that knows that the cord is right
there and has to step over it and it it
breaks it a little bit well and in in a
family room environment there's just
more people something like there's so I
I want to make I and again it's not a
shot on what anybody else is doing I
love what every what we're all trying to
go do and actually the teams share a lot
of learning you know we've we've had the
Sony team up they've seen what we're
doing with Hollow lens we've we talked
to the valve guys all the time it's
because we're so early I don't think
this is a time for us to be competitive
in this space it's a time for us to
share our learnings and try to get
better uh because the market is years
away but we want to be ready for it and
we want to be kind of as an industry
state-of-the-art when it's actually here
so there was a a trademark for something
called direct reality not that long ago
is that when I look at that I think of
direct X as being the thing that helped
a lot of different graphics cards talk
to a lot different softwares direct
reality going to be an easy way for
people to make games for any VR headset
without having to worry about you're
totally right like when we focus on
Windows mixed reality which is the
version of Windows that we're think like
the API platforms actually not a version
of Windows just in Windows 10 but um and
then you start getting into more the
tech side of it whether it's direct
sound direct audio direct input all
under the umbrella of direct X um I
think it's important as the windows
platform company that we we don't start
getting people tied into well you bought
this hmd sorry it's not going to work
with these other things like when I buy
a great Monitor and I plug it in my PC
I'm not worried about that whether
Windows understands it and some games
play on it and some games don't I mean
these are all the when I said the kind
of multi-year Journey that we're all on
I think this is all part of that Windows
as a platform has to natively support
any hmd that you'd plug in and we've
been getting good feedback from the
Oculus team in valve about things that
we need to do in Windows 10 yeah it just
seems like that's where that market is
right now right I mean it's you know
there aren't a ton of headsets out there
and you know the fear is that if it
starts to fragment too much then you
know over the last few weeks here
leading up to the show I played a lot of
multiplayer VR games cool and they're
they're all a lot of fun and I kept
telling most of the devs like this is
great it's also probably the last time
I'll be able to find another person to
play this with because that's just where
it's at right now if you're not wck room
where it's free and and hot yeah it's
amazing uh then it's hard to find other
players yeah and I
worry a couple of years ago I think we
we had maybe an over exuberance around
VR which put more interest in it than
maybe the Tekken experiences could
deliver and I think that's a dangerous
spot for us as an industry because this
isn't to me this isn't something that's
going to
die this is something that will it's
it's not going to be 3D too and the
experience is way too immersive right
this is it is going to happen U but you
see it even in like where VCS and other
people are investing where it's like
everybody's got to be V VR VR and then
uh oh a couple people get their hands
burned and everybody runs away right and
I think we have to moderate the
temperature a bit around where we are
and not try to tell everybody this is
the year of VR yeah because I think then
when it doesn't happen it's like okay
then you get the biggest failure of of
e3 is VR and it's like it's neither one
of those things and uh we're somewhere
in the middle we're still learning this
will happen U so our focus is on the
Windows platform making sure that
head-mounted display manufacturers can
plug in we have four OEM shipping
actually good hmds at really affordable
prices as well I watched you guys when
you did your VR thing you were in I
think you were you had it on everybody
was kind of watching you and I like that
you guys get in use the experience and
tell people in and kind of real world
non-covered it language about what you
see and what you feel it's been it's
it's been effective for us uh and and in
in a way that like talking about VR on a
podcast uh isn't yeah you know when we
do that we write articles about VR and
I've heard this from other outlets the
interest just isn't there it's met with
a rage that is usually reserved for
mobile games yeah as like lame as that
can be uh and so we found some success
with just like Hey we're going to put
these headsets on and just
try cuz that's the thing people want to
they want to know like well and you guys
are genuine enough I think people know
that you're you're not going to over
Fanboy on one thing you're also not
going to be overly critical like you're
going to give your honest opinion about
how this thing feels how the experience
is working what you like and don't like
and I think people value that well we
try thank um so you know that's the
future but you up you go easy on me well
that's the future let's talk about the
past and making the past the present
again uh Xbox 360 on Xbox one has been
really cool to see in a way that even I
didn't anticipate uh thanks and now
you're you're doing it you're going to
bring original Xbox
games does that the official new term
now now that
Xbox language yeah that's the problem
honestly like the reason I I like the
reason this term I grabbed on to the
term was because when you say Xbox One
like what do you the original Xbox
people talk about the PlayStation one
that's right yeah and I mean their
naming lets you do that ours kind of
like 360 one like we're all over the
place so uh yeah so anyway the orig I'll
call it original Xbox the original Xbox
backward compatibility was something
that was important to me
360 uh I mean I I've been in the game
industry for quite a while I I said it
before I see this as an art form um
there are games not just on Xbox there
are games that we should all play to
understand just like there are books
that people should read from there are
movies we should go go watch Citizen
Kane if you haven't seen it right it's
great movie go listen to The White Album
right go so you kind of understand where
the art form comes from and it's I think
it's a shame that sometimes great games
get lost when consoles go away yeah uh I
also at the launch of Xbox one I was
pretty vocal on our leadership team
about wanting to support 360 back compat
because we were making this digital
story and and reality around of Xbox One
console and I always felt like it was a
little Hollow to tell people to buy into
the digital platform on Xbox one but not
respect the 360 games that they had
purchased from us especially after I
mean the original Xbox Xbox Live was
shut down and you know not that there
were a ton of digital purchases there
but it was a case of just like oh wait a
minute it led to a lot of consumers
going like was this just going to happen
again are they going to shut off the 360
someday which I would imagine not uh you
learned lessons on that sort of stuff
well and when you move it forward and
see use then of course and I live even
through like games for Windows Live
which was something that people so I I
want these games to be be played I think
they should be played I also love the
fact um that when somebody goes and
starts playing The Witcher I'll use The
Witcher 3 you can actually go back and
figure out where this franchise came
from right um because not every gamer is
an old person like me and and was around
when all those franchises come about I
even like Halo I think about the launch
of of Halo CE and we've got kids that
are now 20 years old and you know you
think okay that guy was like five when
this game launched yeah that's yeah
definitely like you know when I started
like reviewing games it was like 3dio it
was like the PlayStation was coming the
Saturn was coming and that sort of stuff
and then yeah doing this for at some
point you get people in there where like
their main frame of reference is like
yeah I grew up playing Halo I know what
are you even saying like what does that
even mean don't you know it all came
from Quakes everything come
on okay Blake stone is um yeah so that's
that's been uh really cool to see I
imagine that emulating the original Xbox
just because it was it was I'm trying to
remember what the it was like that nv1
like the graphics part was hard the
graphic part was a little harder frankly
we just have enough horsepower now for
the original Xbox games that we can kind
of we can kind of just Brute Force those
things are you brute force coming to
comp no Alan Hartman no Brute Force no
lizard man no what are you doing so so
Crimson sky is only game no I think we
also announced
was coming Bill Gates's favorite I
understand yeah we have a list of it
won't be as big as 360 I'll tell people
that like just the rights uh and it's
it's more difficult so we're now what
almost we're like 380 or something on
360 back compact games 380 games it
won't be that for for original Xbox so
this why we kind of announced it I'd say
lower key than we did with 360 back
compat but there are some games Crimson
was one that I really wanted to bring
back Jordan Weissman like great FAA like
I mean you know this is a game that that
I think people should play and there's a
list of other uh original Xbox games
that'll be coming back they play great
it's funny I mean when you not funny but
the back compat team has done such a
good job with the emulator even the 360
games many of many times actually almost
all the time now when they emulate a 360
game the Xbox One version actually runs
better than it did on the original hard
stable additional layer just kind of
smooth it out a little bit and we're
we're seeing the same thing with the
original Xbox game uh back comp Pat and
I i' love to be able to do that I think
it's it's both it's not true that
everybody plays every back compact game
but I think all of us have two or three
games in our past that were important to
us for our own reasons first game I
finished uh I played with my friend me I
play with voodo Vince with my daughters
so when you look at the program you kind
of pick a lot of games because I can't
predict what the game but they're
they're memorials for us as Gamers that
this was like root Force for some people
blinks for some crazy people and you
know it's uh so I'm proud of the program
and the work that the team has done yeah
I actually uh I have an Xbox an original
Xbox hooked up at home uh because my
wife really loves sudeki I know sudeki
and climax did that yeah and and so she
was just like I want to play sudeki
again that's a first- party game too
yeah so so if you could know uh so so
I've I was like okay well I'm going to
go out in the garage and go through all
these rub made tubs and okay let's PL
this out hook it all up and yeah the so
the idea of especially a machine like
that that
uh it's not easy to play those games any
other way there there are some older
consoles you can play in a wide variety
of ways on a PC for example that's right
um and the Xbox isn't really one of them
uh currently and and so not currently
it's it's yeah uh that's I I saw you out
there saying that you would like to
bring this stuff to PC as well I would I
I I want people to have to be able to
play these games certain people just the
console isn't something that they want
and they it's more difficult on PC like
there's no doubt the fixed Hardware spec
of a console when you're going from to
on the emulation side does make uh make
it easier but uh that emulation team
those those team is rock stars and uh
I'd love to be able to bring some of
those games over to PC I think'd be
fantastic yeah yeah that that would be
uh that would be really cool to see so
the PC plays an interesting role in all
of this you know kind as we you know get
ready to put the Xbox One X out and
you're getting ready to put it out there
yeah uh that it it kind of gets back to
that Xbox play Anywhere stuff of like
well now this stuff all lives in the
Windows store as well yeah and so you
have a lot of people that may have a PC
that is going to be more powerful than
the X yep um and certainly more powerful
than and a basine Xbox One S um and so
when you think about the is it kind of
meant to be this Middle Ground like who
who do you see as the ideal consumer for
the X cuz I I look at it and go like
well you know I have a a 4K TV right
here but the PC is also right here I
could just do it you could um but at
this point like I'm relatively starved
for 4K content so like I'm certainly
going to get a Scorpio you know well I
want to see what this thing looks like
and and hook it all up and and I want to
know um but at the same time I'm also I
I buy a lot of stuff at this point you
know so it's it's means yeah yeah
exactly sure yeah when it comes to video
games I make it happen uh I do what I
need to do uh and you know but but I
have that PC right there so I can right
now today play uh near automata at 4K
you know and play Doom at 4K and all
this sort of stuff and so when you think
about the Xbox overall is it are you
still thinking primarily about the boxes
themselves or is it really kind of
Shifting to more of an ecosystem and
ality for
you uh I mean I definitely think about
Xbox Live as the vibrancy of our
platform when I look at it it shows me
what people are playing and how many
people are playing and uh the kind of
how many people have friends and how
many people are in parties like all of
these things I look at as the real
health of our ecosystem I mean at if
somebody wants to play their 4K games
with a PC plugged into their television
I love that in fact you know we built
our controller with Bluetooth so that
you could we could you could go do that
I think that's and if that's the way you
play our games and you log in and
fantastic like I have no issue with that
right uh I mean our fundamental business
people won't care about this but like as
Microsoft is not about trying to get you
to buy one piece of Hardware like that's
that's not the business that we're in
we're a Services Company we're a
platform company we're a gaming company
uh and our gaming strategy uh fits right
into to what Microsoft's trying to do
now I love our Xbox One console we've
done two of them in two years now right
so we're all in and we're we're thinking
about the future the reason I I want us
to stay and keep doing consoles the way
we do is because one not everybody's
going to plug their PC into their
television I think the game it took me I
had a PC sitting there for years before
I got a 4K TV and never really thought
to was like I could do this but yeah I
mean and a lot of people don't have a PC
near their television different a lot of
laptops that integrated GPU they're not
going to go good play so if you look at
the price point of Xbox One X I feel
great about that price point relative to
uh a PC on 4K but PC that's capable of
doing 4K does a lot more than what a
console does so it's kind of a different
scenario this is probably also where
you're doing your email you're browsing
the like you're doing a ton of stuff on
4K email is amazing let me tell you it
is but you know PCS are a multi-function
device that do a lot more and uh than
what a game console does and I think
that's that's great I love obviously
it's Microsoft we love PCS and and and
growth in PCs and it's not true
everybody's going to put their PC next
to the television for Xbox One X when
you talked about 4K content one thing
that was important to me was making sure
we built a console that was capable we
can get into the true 4K checkerboard e
but build a console that could run
native 4K content not necessarily from a
marketing perspective the content
developers need to know that there's an
install base that's large enough so they
can go Target it right now on the PC
side the kind of install base of
graphics cards that are really capable
of running uh content at 4K I know this
we ship gears we ship Horizon like we're
in that business um it's there and
people do it a lot of the reason is
because PC has forward compatibility
like you know there's more graphics
cards to come so you put that into your
game so that two years from now it still
looks stateoftheart start up to ultra
and we'll be fine that's right that's
right uh but I wanted to make sure that
as this game console comes out it helps
build an install base so more developers
are targeting 4K uh as an output for
their game and almost all the third
parties are building a PC version and a
console version of their game right and
in fact when you listen to people like
Jesse at ARC or whatever talk about how
they bring their uh games over to to
Xbox One X they start with their PC
build in most cases bring it over most
of them are getting up in a couple days
at most um then they okay I think with
with Arc he's able to set it at kind of
his ultra settings he's got a little bit
of head room he's running at 60 and then
he'll start adding Gra techniques but he
started with his PC build and coming
over so I think it'll help you on the PC
side as well because you'll just get
more you you'll have more sockets for
those developers to build games for that
are thinking more about that idea of
just like hey let's let's start thinking
about this high-end stuff and and in
terms of who the Xbox One X is for
specifically uh it's it's a console so
it's for somebody who wants to play
games on a a video game console it's
somebody who wants the most powerful
console that's out there like the a Prem
premium console experience it's not for
everybody right just like the elite
controllers not for everybody not
everybody should go buy $150 controller
some people just get the controller you
have it's a great controller go play gam
so we're going to sell a lot of Xbox One
s's like and that'll be it'll sell we'll
sell more s's than X's I suspect next
year yeah U because the price Point's
important to a lot a lot of people it's
really getting closer and closer to
these like big Mass Market numbers where
you're just like okay like we can really
but there's some people that go out and
buy a Titan X as well and put it in
their PC and it's for a specific thing
and there's also people on the console
side that buy Elite controllers that
want that buy a PS4 Pro right that want
the best experience their console
ecosystem offers and I wanted to make
sure that the best we had to offer in
Xbox One consoles was the best thing
that anybody was building right now and
was capable of running games uh at a
native 4K not every game will um but we
wanted to give the tools and the
technology and the horsepower to do that
so the the resolution's not a a mandate
on down like every but is it internally
for for first party are you're like hey
let's make sure we're hitting 4K no I
I'm not a fan at all of mandating
creative or technical decisions for
Studios I just I don't think it leads to
the best the best games right uh I
wanted to give a platform that is
capable of running a native 4K game at
frame rate that's what we designed uh
certain developers will choose their own
frame rate other people said hey you
should mandate 60 like well some games
like that's as a platform hold when you
start mandating those kind of creative
decisions well we've got Uno coming out
you tell me Uno needs to be locked at 60
or you know what what you know it's not
just Uno there are great single player
or not even single player there are
great immersive scenes where you're
playing a game maybe it's not
competitive multiplayer or 60 or it's
just a game where everybody's going to
play competitive multiplayer 30 where
the developer wants to use the render
time to do things that take more time
than you can do in the cycle time for 60
frames per second so they go to 30 um
and you get some beautiful games that
run that way and you know as an as a
player base I'm one of I'm a player if
we get into this mode that we think we
should dictate to the developer
Community what we've deemed as good game
and it's based on a frame rate or a
resolution like that that's not the way
we watch movies we don't say hey movies
have to be 93 minutes long or they're
not good right you know but usually when
they're under 90 sometimes you're like
uh maybe I don't know but the hardware
itself I wanted to make sure could
support native 4K I mean that was that
was explicit from the beginning in the
design of the Xbox One X was uh a native
4K console that could hit frame rates
that developers wanted to hit some of
them will use will hit 60 some will hit
30 some will do checkerboarding and
their games will look amazing uh and
that that's the target for the platform
let the developers do the work that
they're going to do and uh I'm really
proud of the specs we have in the
console you know the nine gigs that are
available to Developers the GPU speed
the speed of the ram is turning out to
be a huge benefit the speed of the hard
drive a huge benefit um and and some of
this seems like it's coming from a place
of like hey you know there was
definitely no shortage of developer
feedback when it came to the original
Xbox one uh and I how do you feel that
this this update that the the bringing
the Xbox One X Out is it reactive to
some of the things you've heard is it
reactive to kind of the how the
competition has been setting things up
and how they've been doing things cuz is
as the name was getting announced is
when I kind of like started piecing
together this busted narrative in my
head was like well there were a lot of
people that were angry about 900p so
this is them going like
4K and then you know I understand that
people didn't necessarily like the term
xbone and now this one just abbreviates
to the word Xbox problems
solved uh don't see behind our plan I
was going to say is there just like some
chip on the shoulder of just like we're
fix all right we we heard you we heard
you here it is here it is um and and
delivering this box that is so much more
powerful than than what's been out there
it's kind of yes and no um to some
extent a lot of what I try to do with
Xbox and the team is reactive because
we're taking feedback right I'm pretty
active in the social communities around
gaming uh my my Twitter account Xbox
Live I'm there um I'm not trying to hide
behind things um and I get that feedback
and if I take that feedback and and turn
it into things that we do with the
program I guess that's reactive um but
it's reacting to what people are asking
for I will say with uh the Xbox One
X I do remember from the original
Xbox that there was the feeling around
the brand that this is a powerful
console and we do our brand research
even today around what Xbox means to
people power is a word that pops pretty
highly and and I wanted to make sure we
were kind of living up to the brand
promise of what people want from us
right uh when we were designing Xbox One
X I didn't know what the competition was
doing um I didn't know that there would
be a console shipping till later I
didn't know that there would be a
console shipping in uh when they when
they launched in in 16 um so there
wasn't a direct competitive thing on hey
I need to go do this um because there's
something else going that's honest I
didn't know um the S we kind of started
the S and the X around the same time we
knew we wanted to do uh a refresh of
Durango which is the code name for the
the original console and uh we wanted to
make a little bit smaller we had some
time now to to we wanted add HDR 4K
upscaling the UHD Drive um we also knew
price was going to be important so now
we're at 249 here in the US like we can
we want to get to as you said those Mass
market price points but that power thing
was sitting there I don't know if it was
a direct reaction to the launch of Xbox
one but I did feel it like I didn't like
um having a console where people felt
like I'm not playing the games that play
as well as they do on another platform
um so we set the target High um and I
knew the price would be different than S
right you yeah and uh and I knew it
wasn't going to be for everybody uh some
people will say hey I'm just fine
playing games on the S and uh and that
that's my experience that's what I want
to invest to play games on my television
and I'm totally fine with that as a
business running Xbox business I think
that's great uh but the X was something
that we wanted to we wanted to design
the best console we could use what we
had learned from PC as the windows uh
things like the vapor chamber and all
these things people tease me about um
but to build a piece of of Hardware that
could really hit the specs that g
today's game developers are asking us to
hit yeah and uh gosh yeah I I had
something I lost up there for a um my
[Laughter]
plan so
uh you talk about uh some of these older
games that are going to be getting these
4K updates um uh and that's think I said
over 30 on Gears Killer Instinct that
our first party there was the third like
Final Fantasy res yeah uh and is that
something is that is a lot of work have
to go into that stuff to kind of like
get these games ready or is it a case
where like oh if there's a PC version of
the game kind of just using because
obviously the gears is on the PC I would
imagine it was a design point for us a
design point for us were developers that
have 4K versions of their PC games that
they would be able to do the work
uh to get the 4K update on I'll call it
Scorpio just because at the time that's
what we were talking about um Scorpio uh
quickly so we designed really the
biggest star in all of Xbox One X to
date has actually been the development
kit and that's a really cool looking box
but even the way forgetting about the
way it looks the the focus with the
developer on we want to build the
absolute best development kit we've ever
built cuz all of this industry if you
can can enable developers to be
productive on your platform you're going
to get great games um you're going to
get great games that look great uh and
it's not just the hardware itself it's
what something we call the xdk or the
Xbox development kit all the tools that
we put in that so as part designing the
development kit and the xdk software we
said for a team that has a 4K PC version
of the game and I said this like two
years ago we were learning this through
doing our own PC first party games
shipping at 4K I said I want a team to
be able to bring their PC 4K version
over quickly and we did some things one
example pix pix is our now I'm really
out in left field so I apologies to
everybody but pix is our profiling tool
that we've had on Console forever I
brought it we brought it over to to
Windows so the windows people they could
start looking at their pix profile on
Windows knowing that they're probably
going to be hitting 4K there and we were
going to want to bring it back and
they'd have the same profiling tool it's
just a random example um but it was
really about how can these guys who all
have PC games running at at 4K come over
and like 30 we actually had to hold that
list back like that and that it is a
little bit hyperboy there but the the
list of games that people are going to
be able to play that are enhanced for
the Xbox one it's a great list um
there'll be more games to I was down at
343 the other week and saw some things
that were really good so uh I think
people are going to be excited and uh
mainly because the developers are are
doing the work and it's it's not that
challenging if they have a 4K version
cool do you feel that uh that some of
the uh the talk around E3 some of the uh
expectations going into something like
E3
are positive uh I asked this because you
know there was you know you got out
there you announced a ton of games uh
you announced uh 49 99 price point and
you had a lot of people you know myself
included to a certain extent uh that was
like well you know this isn't this
doesn't match Sony's price so what the
hell like that that's not is that what
you said well it's like well what they
even doing if if they're not going to
you know because you look at it as like
okay you know uh are they going to place
the the full bet is is kind of how I was
looking at it uh around the time of the
announcement I've been thinking about it
for the past couple of days and no I
totally understand turned on it because
I'm like wait a minute actually you know
uh they've probably got a responsible
business to run and selling consoles for
you know you you you know it's like I'm
sure it would be great if you could sell
an XBox for $70 I should give them away
yeah yeah just give them out right just
just take you want one I brought one
with me you want to be the market leader
just give them away come on Let's Do It
um but you know looking at it like
people go into E3 kind of looking for a
fight they they go into E3 looking to
watch watch the console manufacturers go
head-to-head with these press
conferences and this and that and fire
and brimstone and who's going to come
out the winner and I think that's led to
a lot of the discussion or or kind of
led a lot of the discussion around the
price of the X and do you feel that that
sort of stuff is maybe not great in the
long run for just video games and
General well yeah I mean on that point
specifically I've been hopefully
consistent I'm sure people will find
instances where I I haven't been um as
pure as I should be or something but uh
I'm first and foremost a fan of this
industry uh fundamentally believe that
and I'm lucky enough to land in a job
that gives me kind of 247 what I love my
hobby and uh I want to try to make
decisions for our platform that are good
for this industry it is it is a business
there
competition uh but in terms of like
crossplay in terms of back compat um in
terms of just you know allowing other
things onto our platform um I'm trying
to be uh a steward of the games industry
in my role as much Not Alone um to make
this a good place for people to play um
and for the creators to create the great
games that we all want to be playing now
and a decade into the future uh on the
price thing
specifically the fundamental decision on
price was was driven by the specs that
we wanted to go hit right right it it
wasn't like I said it wasn't a
competitive reaction to what I'll just
say the PS4 Pro and people tell me I
talk too much about Sony and but you
were kind of asking about it this way um
they delivered a great console at 3.99
last year um that's not the console I
wanted to build right that doesn't mean
they're wrong and I'm right I wanted to
build a console that had the
capabilities we've been talking about
before for the PC developers that and
the stuff we were seeing with our first
party that could run those games at
Native 4K if somebody wanted to go that
doesn't mean the Pro's wrong right and
we're a year later and we're a higher
spec more expensive box than that box
it's a different experience than what
they what they delivered and that
doesn't and I like what we delivered I
like what we have at the S level for
people who say I don't know what P's are
or or Tera flops or any of this or frame
rate FPS like I just want to go play
video game uh and I want make sure we
have a great price point there on the
other side I look at what the premium
experience that people want I see what
people are getting on PC and I want to
design have our team and work with them
to design a console and the Xbox One X
that could be the the best thing that we
could build this year at a console price
point and uh and as you said I can go
build a PC and I can blow that thing
away if I want to go invest to go do
that but on my television that's the
console that we wanted to go build and I
agree with you certain people look at it
and say well if I don't beat Sony like
so if I don't drive Sony into the ground
or something somehow I my job like a
weird and it's not a win lose like many
people like I'm sure yourself you have
multiple consoles I'm betting I have
true and our business can do just fine
with other people succeeding in fact
like you know we're shipping Minecraft
on the switch with Nintendo and it's
great and it's a partnership where it's
a win-win partnership between the two
companies so I read today that's just
you're going to just log into an Xbox
Live account on a switch for that right
it's kind of or connect to a Microsoft
account I guess no it's an Xbox Live
account I mean that's our gaming social
network um we can go we could go down
that path if you want to very just will
I be able to earn achievements in a
Nintendo switch game I don't know yet
like that's I'm I'm guessing no like uh
and this is a collaborative relationship
between Nintendo and I like they don't
have achievements on their platform I
don't know if they if they want us to
like I I'd love to be able to do it cuz
I've earned achievements in an iOS game
before and some came out like you know
you log in and it shows up on the same
profile and you're getting points
totally agree and Apple's been great
about the things that we want to do with
the platform um as has uh Google with
Android and we have a ton of users there
um and the relationship with Nintendo is
incredibly strong we obviously did them
Mario mashup pack into Nintendo into
Minecraft that doesn't happen that often
so that relationship has been strong we
use Xbox Live as the way to make sure we
know who our players are um controls
around parental controls and other
things that we put into our our our
platform are there so that people and as
you're buying things in Minecraft you
want to make sure you have them
available on the other platform so we
have to know who you are um and if you
have a realm that you've created on the
PC and you want to get to it on the
switch like we have to have an identity
system and we just use Xbox Live it's
you're still going to buy the game from
Nintendo you don't buy it from us
there's no nefarious you know it's it's
really just a way for us to unify the
Minecraft players and our social graph
on social network inside of cograph
inside of uh inside of Xbox's Xbox Live
um but going back to the other thing you
know the competitiveness I being proud
of what you own uh our FanFest is
amazing and know those people love Xbox
I come out on the stage and like people
are so so happy and proud to be part of
of the Xbox Community I love that I just
think as an industry when we start kind
of voting more on other people not
succeeding than us having a good time
and succeeding that just feels negative
to me and and and I don't try to do that
and I know people call me me you said
this about them and that about those
people I honestly have no dislike for
people in the games industry I'll never
vote for a game to fail regardless of
what platform it's on um I know
developers work incredibly hard to build
the games that they do and same thing
with the platforms I want to do the best
thing we can do with Xbox make sure the
best games possible are on Xbox and that
you have a great experience um and if
what we have isn't for you and you
decide to play on your PC or PlayStation
or on your iPhone great I'll do what I
can to make our experience great on
those platforms as well yeah just to
briefly back to the uh the the cross
compatibility stuff uh obviously Sony's
been out there saying that they they
don't necessarily see themselves being a
part of the uh of the Minecraft uh
family or the unified Minecraft family
obviously that the game does exist on
yeah on their platform and we love our
PlayStation customers in Minecraft uh
would you characterize those discussions
as still ongoing or I mean I know
they're out there kind of saying like
that they can't keep their users safe
from people that are not on their
platform and some other stuff you know
rocket League kind of got caught up in
in something similar uh as well uh is
that something where you you view this
the door is still open absolutely like
I'm I would love for players on all
platforms to be able to stay connected I
I will jump on another Grenade on this
one but
the the fact that somebody
would kind of make an assertion that
somehow
we're not keeping Minecraft players safe
I I found not only from a Microsoft
perspective from a game industry
perspective like I don't know why that
has to become the dialogue like that
doesn't seem healthy for for anyone and
I feel we can always do better with
everything that we do I feel great our
relationship with Minecraft from the
time we originally brought it over to
360 we've obviously owned it now for a
couple years and and where it's gone and
I just really found the whole discussion
around safety with our game and that
somehow we wouldn't take that as a top
priority and frankly through our
parental controls on XBox Live and
everything else that we've done shown
that that's incredibly important to us
as a platform that stuff exists and also
like you know we're we're talking about
Minecraft that's right like and frankly
and Nintendo like we're on like you know
the yeah you want to talk about people
that are like maybe overly protective in
spots like there you go uh you they'll
lock it down but the door is open I
don't mean to like shut the I I'd love
all Minecraft players to have the full
Minecraft experience um we take the the
safety of Xbox Live of our players
across all of our games um inside of
Minecraft uh obviously an incredibly
important part of that there's it's
incredibly important to our team and the
work that they do around imp parental
controls and frankly accessibility and
everything else uh that yeah it's we
would never put Minecraft in a place
where we we felt like it wasn't um we
weren't keeping our place play safe so
what's next for Xbox One X at this point
the pre-orders haven't started yet not
yet uh is it FCC related on that one
that was it um and and it's also the
reason we didn't have a complete list of
the worldwide markets that it will be
coming we're starting on November 7th we
say starting worldwide uh we'll do a
better job than we did at the launch of
Xbox One where I thought you know we
were a little spotty in terms of when it
hit uh the right markets um there's a
couple countries where the the kind of
the approvals take a little bit longer I
feel good uh are you still looking at
yields and like does it does it seem
like you know on day one that there's
going to be a lot of these available or
is it going to maybe a little little
limited does no it does uh
it's we I said I've been using mine at
home for a while now uh as some other
members of the team have so we feel good
about where the hardware is use the word
yield that's exactly the yield you know
you built X how many of X work right
starting from the chip all the way up uh
and but I feel good about what we should
have when we start we kind of of Mike
Nichols and I who runs marketing for
Xbox really think through those
scenarios before we stand on stage and
say something um it's going to be fun
you know we we need to finish a couple
things the platform still coming
together in terms of software and the
operating system for it we made a change
last week about increasing the amount of
ram that the developers get access to
this is kind of all the process you go
through uh but it's going to be fun
shipping is is always great it's
challenging we've got some crackdowns a
launch game a game I love from the uh
from 360 a a joke I maybe we should put
a Halo beta on the Crackdown disc this
time you know that was the thing though
like that was the like everyone bought
Crackdown CU they had the Halo beta and
then realized like oh wait Crackdown is
really good uh like it how many times I
got called zone of the Enders or
something right yeah yeah totally uh
that ended up working out pretty well it
did it did I remember though at first
there was a little bit of the throwaway
game and it was such a game you know
left trigger lock on right trigger shoot
it was uh and I I've been playing it
with a team it's on the floor playable
here um it feels and plays like a real
full Crackdown Crackdown 2 wasn't what
it should have been uh mainly CU we
didn't give the team the time to do what
they should have done but where they are
now is I might say they've had a lot of
time they on this one huh it's the same
producer on our side too Peter Connelly
was on the original Crackdown and we
wanted to make sure Peter was connected
to this one uh and getting Crackdown
three done obviously Dave Jones was
involved we have a couple teams involved
but getting the old team back together
so that the the stuff uh so it felt like
a real Crackdown Team game with as you
said it time that's cool well uh I'm
looking forward to seeing all this stuff
hitting and and watching people get
their hands on it and and and yeah I
mean what Hardware launches are exciting
they are it's cool so thanks so much for
stopping by Phil I want to say one thing
cuz uh you guys have been courteous
enough to have me on the last few years
and this is kind of it seems weird
because it's the middle of e3 but it's
kind of the back end of e3 for me I'll
be I'll be leaving tomorrow I have to go
do some other work but um I love the
show that you guys do here I think the
the tone you take with gaming um is real
you always ask great questions I feel
like we get enough time to sit down and
have a full discussion about topics and
it doesn't come kind of buzzword
headlines that get pulled out so one I
just want to say thanks for having me on
um over the last few years and also just
the show you guys do I think is
fantastic thanks I mean you know anytime
you're in San Francisco you want to come
by you know we can hang out for an hour
and you know do it do it off cycle
outside E3 that'd be great I'd love it
all right well we are going to be uh
back in a bit and uh everybody stay
tuned and we'll get another round of
guests in here and keep going as the
evening continues stay
tuned
I'm going to build a house Bo on the
bi it's going to be a mighty mighty
pretty side to see I'm going to make it
nice and pained red with a little
kitchen and a double bed I'm going to
build a house boat it's going to be a
Love Boat I'm going to build a house
boat for you and
me when we want to move we'll pull the
anchor up we're never going to have to
stay in just one spot we can let the
time pass floating through the tall
grass and when the time is right we'll
tie the
night I'm going to build a house Bo on
the
B it's going to be a mighty mighty
pretty side to see I'm going to make it
nice and pained red with a little
kitchen in a double bed I'm going to
build a house Co it's going to be a love
Co I'm going to build a house both for
you and
[Music]
[Applause]
me maybe we can float all the way to New
Orleans and listen to the sounds of the
Saints Go Marching in take it down to
life for yet all the places we ain't
been to yet yeah see the world and never
leave home
again I'm going to build a house Bo home
the
B it's going to be a mighty mighty
pretty side to see I'm going to make it
nice and plainy red with a little
kitchen and a double bed I'm going to
build a house boat it's going to be a
Love Boat I'm going to build a house
boat for you and
me I'm going to build a the house Bo on
the
B it's going to be a mighty mighty
pretty inside to see I'm going to make
it nice and pained red with a little
kitchen and a double bed I'm going to
build a house mod it's going to be a
love mod I'm going to build a house it's
going to be a love for you and me for
you and me yeah for you and
me just you and
[Music]
me
a
[Music]
know
n
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
la
[Music]
he
hey hey
hey
[Music]
hey hey
hey
hey hey hey
[Music]
hey he
hey
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
hello and welcome back to giantbomb.com
e327 coverage maybe you're watching us
here at giantbomb.com or maybe on
YouTube or mixer twitch or we on
Facebook where are I don't know are we
on caffeine.tv no I don't know that's
we're all over the place uh and welcome
back I am joined Now by many of the
folks that run giantbomb.com
hello pleasure hi we got Brad Shoemaker
we got Ben pack uh we got Alex Navaro
down there back line little Dan rer over
there hello little Dan rker that's what
they call me cuz you're far away you
look smaller oh it's perspective thing
I'm actually the same size I've always
been what yeah yeah yeah if I stood over
there I'd look normal but you're you're
taller than me which we've already
established that is true yes I'm that's
how Works wait he now Big Damn okay all
right Big Damn Riker back there and Lil
Vinnie
Hey lil Vinnie K hi little Vinnie how
you doing oh you want I'm sorry you want
Little Vinnie yeah no no I do not
actually wait before I get into more
trouble than I want HR is not watching
giant at night where we get loose
[Music]
hour two is where it gets a little too
real uh that was a good interview if you
if anybody missed it you had a fun time
with Phil Spencer yeah thanks yeah that
was uh it's always good getting getting
Phil in here and talking about stuff
he's he's very genuine about you know
what he wants to do with Xbox and where
it's where it's at in the business and
get cool shoes yeah cool shoes that's
you got to have shoes you know to be on
a press conference stage and all that
sort of stuff there you know these are
the the life you got to leave look The
Comfy
too speaking of Sho speaking of shoes
Vin car car uhhuh uhuh take it we'll
just take the one more three two Vinnie
Caravella yeah uh you played some
Detroit uh did or saw some Detroit I
guess speaking of Shu and a PlayStation
exclusive uh Detroit is a game where you
play as a robot okay you talked a little
bit about it you yelled uh a little bit
about it last night seems like it's it's
the David cage template yeah so it's
very it's very heavy ring so um like the
the code name of it very heavy extremely
it's pouring uh supery is that bad for
robots uh metal right they figured it
out I think they're water resistant not
waterproof like an iPhone like an iPhone
they removed their headphone jack and
it's really bad you just don't submerge
take the shower but not in the pool
exactly right uh so it's they showed off
in the thing I saw was uh exactly the
demo they showed off during the press
conference uh one of the press
conferences and it was the kind of go to
break out these other um robots Androids
from the showroom we're going to break
them out they went into a little bit
more depth on the are you going to do
this uh the uh
riding violent way or are you going to
do this the um kind of more pacifist way
and and what those choices mean M uh
there were kind of two things that were
I thought a little novel that weren't in
other uh games that are kind of
particular to the Android AI sense you
can like look at an object like a drone
flying above you and go into I think
what they
called preconstruction and
reconstruction I think that's what you
said so you can reconstruct the path of
the Drone virtually in the space right
so you'll see like oh the drone's going
to move around this space here um if I
can climb up on this building oh nope
I'm going to miss it and it kind of
shows your character virtually kind of
climbing up and be like oh I'd miss it
here and to me it kind of works in a
narrative it's an adventure game right
yeah so it works in a narrative sense of
like oh think in real life you know this
is my head Cannon but in real life A
robot's just running through these
things but visually we have to show this
and then also it kind of gives you a
little preview of what might happen if
you go down this path or is it kind of
like hey you got to peek down one of the
potential outcomes without s
uh yeah so you're kind of just like you
know and again very heavy rain style
you're looking around the environment
and have a little square and like oh
okay if I climb this I'll miss if I
climb this I'll miss oh if I climb this
I'll hit the Drone and that's what they
were calling the Reconstruction of this
path then You' go to a scaffolding you
have to climb and then you do the same
thing you push square on it and then
you're prec constructing what a path you
want to take to then climb up and jump
on this up and it's all a very it's a
visual thing and it's again this is an
adventure game right this not like an
action Run and Jump and shoot so you're
you're again you're just choosing paths
to go down uh so that was kind of novel
The other thing I thought was kind of
neat and this is just kind of an
evolution on you know when I say
Adventure game I'm kind of rolling up
what telltale's done and kind of modern
Adventure game stuff um you hit a
situation you have free control over
your character to run around and do
whatever within the set piece and then
it'll jump into cut scenes where it
steals control from you and the whole
thing looks great it was in the demo
they were showing it looked fantastic uh
probably one of the in the demo they
were showing probably one of the better
games I've ever seen with motion capture
and performance capture and all that
stuff uh so it looked great then it
would steal control from you and put you
in certain situations so you'd make a
choice and suddenly it would steal
control from you because the cops are
coming right you did a thing and then
the cops are coming and then give you
back control with like three options to
look around you got to look quickly
around because there's a timer that'll
start going very quickly of like do you
want to split do you want to hide do you
want to do this uh and you know in the
demo they were very much hitting that
all of these paths will then Branch
again like you've made this Choice which
will lead to this choice and I feel like
we've gotten this before with heavy rain
and this is why I kind of keep going
back to it uh you can lose control of
this character at any time this you can
dead end this story like with there are
three characters they were talking about
uh and I think that's they said that's
all of them they're all Androids and the
I could be getting some of the wrong but
they can dead you can lose this story
you can die so you have to think about a
very particular scene they said was cops
are coming do you want to just give up
on this mission to break these people
out uh and just Live Another Day oh or
you can maybe try and you don't know
what going to happen but it could be the
end of the story if you make the wrong
choice here and we'll move on to a
different video okay and but then it's
that it moves on it's not like a game
over uh you know like heavy rain I'm
trying to think back to how heavy rain
did it cuz they made that similar pitch
during that uh where hey this could be
the end of this character but you just
jump to a different character yeah like
a character would die and then you're
just that Arc is done but you're doing
the other character stuff so uh the
character they were showing was the
leader of he was a revolutionary and
he's he can touch other uh robots is he
Marcus yeah and he he could touch free
bread and you would be free and circle
is going to turn blue now so he would go
around the environment and there just be
guys sweeping up and it was a little
weird in kind of a you guys can probably
all imagine this in a very David cage
game kind of way
hey go to Jericho and then you know the
the guy would run off and you know it
was a little weird but it kind of worked
and I actually liked what I saw the
thing I didn't like was as you're as
you're done tearing this place up uh you
have your army of robots and you have to
decide whether you want to make send a
message to the humans right and you're
going have to do this by tagging
everything with your laser graffiti and
and like making laser Flags fall down uh
or you could just take a bat and start
bashing Windows right like a message the
humans will understand that's what one
of the characters says they only
understand violence right uh but as
you're doing this that's all that's all
I understand you're feeling a UI meter
comes up and they might I hope they get
rid of this that is either filling
towards violence this is on the red side
or on the blue side is paist yeah but
it's basic yes it's paive as a renegade
and it just was like don't we don't need
to see this UI in this meter like you're
kind of now for lack of a better turn
gamifying my revolution of like oh well
obviously I want to pin the meter on gy
your resolution with specially marked
bottles of Mountain Dew pre-or now I
mean to be fair that basically describes
water politics it's just a meter that
either goes toward pacifism or violence
now that's all it is don't you mean
Pepsi oh sorry yeah no that's yeah Pepsi
fireo draw Marcus asaria uh so the I I
was actually getting kind of mad
watching the demo as he's gaining points
on the violent path and then would do
something that would subtract points and
put him back on the other one being like
you're messing up like you're not going
to Peg the meter on this side right uh
so I wish they would just get rid of
that and kind of just infer from what
you're doing hey I'm smashing a window
this is real bad I'm flipping a car and
lighting a that's going to have
consequences regardless of if I'm like
suddenly like really apologetic or not
like I still did all that [__] right
exactly so it's like can you flip enough
cars and then put enough graffiti down
to kind of like then mellow it back out
and be like uh and the other I I think
my biggest worry with that game are
going to be some and this is just going
to be intrinsic to the style of game it
is just plot loopholes that are just
gonna you know you're going to have so
many branching paths and stories that
sure youan so like there was a scene
where he jumped down and a drone saw him
uh doing this activity like uh messing
with some wires and the Drone called the
cops and the cops came in like 5 Seconds
right and then he to avoid that he took
the Drone out right took smashed the
Drone she's like I hope it didn't have
time to call the cops he like we'll find
out soon then he grabs a truck and he
smashes it through a window and then
spent about 20 minutes flipping over
cars with no cops coming and it just
felt like it just felt like how did you
create this blackout scenario where like
no these cops who are around the corner
obviously from this drone are not like
you're flipping over cars and you have
this whole ride they like you hear
something right it sounds like a bunch
of cars getting flipped over the Drone
hasn't said anything okay well anything
then I forget it I guess right so it's
like you know just like very little
nitpicks in a game
that is kind of trading in immersion and
kind of like I'm going to bring you into
this story uh so on one hand it's like
ah you know I don't want a nitpick it's
you know still a very hard story to tell
with all these paths but on in the other
hand it's like this is your bread and
butter here is this very immersive story
that you're trying to tell it sounds
interesting if nothing else like is it
also sounds like another one of those in
a lot of ways right I mean there are
points when you're it's very heavy rain
it is it is very heavy rain uh there are
points where you have uh Hey I want to
put something in a bin or a or a or a
trash can and you got to shake the
controller down oh wow God drop it uh
there are there are points when you are
trying to open a door or something that
might be like you see his hand like
touch something and he has to dial code
you have to hold L2 L1
Square just this kind of claw yeah so
like all all of those elements that
one's fun the buttons at once I think
that's yeah do they use the touchpad for
anything does he use all of the
PlayStation controller card
you know I don't remember seeing a thing
where we
had yeah I don't remember a very gentle
brush like I'm trying to think of a game
recently that's actually used the
touchpad other than for anything other
than well let's bring up the map plunk
last one I can think it was Infamous
Second Sun and that had the stuff like
oh lift the thing up by swiping up but
if anyone's going to do it David cage is
going to do it oh yeah yeah there's
there's a probably a controller two to
fource waiting in there some uh I I I
like those games despite their flaws I
think they are are you know two concerns
I have one is is the game going to be
interesting is it going to stumble
across what it's trying to do game-wise
gameplay wise the other one is do you
have the chops to pull off this
political and charged Story I mean
that's no that's a big question yes like
you know let's just [__] put the nail
in that right now probably not so there
least they try it doesn't mean it's
going to be a bad game but it may not be
what you want it to be though I'm glad
I'm glad somebody's trying sure even if
they so so those are two concerns right
like uh and they're not there you can't
tease them apart because one might uh
influence the other right like oh is one
of these failing because of the gameplay
is the storytelling failing because of
the gameplay is the gaml or is the
storytelling drawing me out of the
gameplay right so I don't know like you
know swipe the touchpad to start a
revolution might not be my favorite
thing whereas you know
um you know and vice versa with the the
gameplay influence or the story
influence in the gamepl so I know cool
that's interesting either way yeah I'm
I'm actually pretty excited for it I was
excited for Heavy Rain excited for this
Brad you uh get around and see anything
how you feeling I see a lot of stuff
foremost I apologize that I sound
horrible this is disgusting and I we
love you Brad are at least feeling
slightly better that's there you go I've
seen you elbow bumping a lot of people
on the show that out of way excuse me I
know it's horrible that was a very good
I'm sorry I'm was trying so hard not to
cough while Phil was up here I'm just
going to go through the schedule here
Dan and I went and saw Uncharted Lost
Legacy this morning okay uh that looks
like more Uncharted okay I I felt the
exact same way I did when I was watching
that Call of Duty demo where like
everything looked really good and
wellmade and everything but I was just
thinking like I don't know if I need to
play this like I want to see the story
so I will play through it but the actual
moment to moment like getting behind
cover and shooting people with an
Uncharted game I didn't really want to
do that I felt that way through
Uncharted 4 I mean that's that's part of
what prevented me from playing Uncharted
4 was I I I didn't end up playing very
much of it because I I got into it and
got to the action I'm like you know this
is an incredibly well-made thing I just
don't really this looks incredibly well
made it is it is still that I feel like
with four it had been long enough since
three it was at least a few years that I
was like ah I could play another one of
those this I just played through all the
four last year loved it but I don't are
you ready to jump in that does it feel
totally different the biggest the
biggest I mean they're in India but the
the Hook is it's there's no nth of Drake
like the the hook is Uncharted without
Drake yeah uh they also said that it is
a full game they were saying this is a
like full length unch notc no it's 40s
$40 it's Standalone they said it's
shorter than four like kind of on par
with like the first three in terms of
length or amount 10 12 hour game
probably yeah I think we were looking at
this and going like is this going to be
like it's you know a standalone Side
Story is this going to be like a 4 Hour
thing a six hour thing they made it
sound and it ships with the entire
Uncharted 4 multiplay player Suite which
is cool if you didn't have that already
but yeah like the main thing is you're
playing as as Chloe the British Explorer
lady in na from four MH who's like a
total ass kicker like there's there's
that part at the beginning where they
they do the classic sneak up behind two
guys and and kloe's like all right I'll
get the one on the left and you go and
like halfway through and you get the one
on the right naen just like jumps over
there and like takes them both out like
it's that you know kind of buddy buddy
cop action movie type stuff there are
some cool uh Parts where you know you
islo running around and shooting people
while in the background you can see naen
just going around from person to person
like kicking their ass hand to hand
while you're swinging around shooting
them that seemed pretty cool does it
does it feel like again tonally like
does it feel like these were two
characters that were kind of foils for
Nathan's Goofy and buffoonery that are
now put together without that kind of I
feel that way about Khloe cuz kloe
didn't get fleshed out that much in two
I can't remember if she was in three but
uh naen they just when they showed her
in four I thought she was a really
interesting character and I want to see
more of her proba chlo's than the
playable characters because you know you
get to kind of experience a little more
that fleshes that character out right I
feel like they both seemed competent
whereas Nathan always seemed like I'm
going to get by on this with luck like
he's slipping on banana peels into the
treasure and they were always like
you're an idiot like what are you doing
does it how does that play out you know
he's the most capable idiot in the world
because everything he does is just so
over the top but he always does it with
like Perfection up he leaves a wake of
rubble behind him as well well there is
that they they seem less goofy in nature
but the whole like constantly being in
Peril thing that Nathan had they've got
that too like you know you're climbing
up a thing and then a giant like tank
APC thing crashes through the wall and
you go flying down like you know these
characters are getting [__] up in the
same way that like Nathan Drake
constantly was they're just not like all
Dopey about it if it's going to get
Supernatural like four didn't really
that's true yeah have
that the story it was kind of better for
it honestly yeah I think so yeah uh then
we saw Spider-Man after that it was the
same demo from the stage the other day
except without the or would have the
stuff that they cut from the middle of
that demo for time I feel like combat
which uh the environmental stuff like
all the L1 to like whip this thing
around and hit a guy I feel like we saw
more of that today there was a little
bit more of that yeah that combat seems
remains very Batman like yeah okay oh
you know they had the they had the UI
turn on I don't think they had the UI
turn on on the stage but you full on get
like finishers that are two face buttons
they did have the UI yeah cuz I remember
seeing in the bottom right like triangle
and circle
Batman that's how Batman it is that you
rack up five or six hits and then you
can do a finisher with two buttons I
mean of all the superheroes you can do
that with I feel like Spider-Man is
probably well suited for that I want to
say Spider-Man has had Batman combat in
a previous game but they they showed a
lot of swinging and that looks great but
he didn't he answered a lot of questions
about that thing like it's it's it's
Manhattan only but it's full Manhattan
they said like from the beginning of the
game like the whole island is open give
you full Manhattan that's right but like
they seem very uh intent on having a
world to swing around like from like
from right from the gigo I like what
they said about like hey we understand
that like the swinging around and how
that feels is critical to this game and
they brought up Spider-Man 2 a lot which
made me feel like they they got it
because that was the one that felt the
best to swing around I also asked about
sunset overdrive which I thought they
would never say anything about CU that
was Microsoft exclusive and this is a
Sony exclusive but they were like no we
like totally took all the like they said
they were actually thinking about
Spider-Man as they're making that game
oh in terms of the traversal stuff so
they like brought a bunch of that stuff
right over I guess that makes sense yeah
did they say anything promising say
anything about like the Miles Morales
Stuff Parker is Peter Parker uh Morales
is in in the well I guess it's him like
there a character that Stinger at the
end is like miles come on yeah and like
I guess I was informed by some people
from following that press conference
that I guess like in the current Marvel
Universe both Peter Parker and Miles
Morales are Spider-Man uh he this is not
based on any current comic series or
anything he said it's a standalone like
it's a Spider-Man universe in a bubble
okay uh so he he very lightly implied
that there might be Parts where he play
as Peter Parker like somebody asked and
he was just well we can't really talk
about that yet but I'll just say that
Peter Parker is a very important part of
Spider-Man and we understand that I want
to take photos yeah I want to take
photos yeah yeah like like showing The
Man Behind the Mask seems like a big
storytelling than for what if you could
just do it with your phone and use the
companion app what if you just do it
with your phone take regular pictures
but then you texted them to a number and
then the game popped up Tex J and J and
then the game popped up and said this is
a terrible phot
the glare is all bad this this console
has a share button right on it right you
know you don't need to take [__]
pictures of the
screen dick every time I do that someone
[__] goes you know it's got a share
button I'm like yeah my phone has a
zillion share buttons and it's nothing
but share button I type in a Twitter
password with a controller it's uh you
got the point of what I was trying to
get across pretty easily is easy stuff
yeah did did they miss any of those like
what look like QuickTime events uh no
but they somebody asked him about that
and he said there are fail States so you
can fail out of those big sequences I
like vicious like like Tomb Raider just
like Falls flat and the building blows
up or just impaled on a spike and like
hang out I heard somebody else mention
that they said they were trying to
relegate those only two like main story
yeah I would believe that critical that
makes sense Mission ask basically like
hey I saw a lot of like Quick Time Event
stuff and they basically said like yeah
you know for some of these big setpiece
moments and missions like we kind of
have to do that to make those moments
where you're catching the he he
referenced Trey AR and neversoft
repeatedly and like they seem very
intent on making like a Spider-Man game
in the tradition of those Spider-Man
games that's you know those games are
very well liked and this game you know
even it was it was hard to get a sense
sometimes during that press conference
like how much of this is a quick Time
Event and how much of it is video game
but like I regardless like it's a nice
looking thing yeah it looks incredible
and the combat doesn't seem like
straight up Batman because they they
mentioned that Spider-Man's not a
Bruiser he's more tricky acrobatic so
it's a lot of like we saw more that
environmental stuff remember in the
trailer or the demo you saw him like
grab that gerder or whatever and swing
it around tons of that stuff of like U
you know hit L1 to do something cool
with this thing or you can do the
stealth thing of you remember when he
shot the thing on the shipping container
and it kind of shot out and grabbed the
guy you can like stick one of those on a
guard that's patrolling around and then
if he happens to like walk by another
guard that will activate it and they'll
pull them together and smack them
together like it seems like there's some
fun stuff you can do did he drop anybody
off a building no one guy started flying
off and then he like hit L1 or something
and like grabbed him and because I guess
Spider-Man doesn't kill people so he you
think you think that was an automatic
thing like spider like the AI will just
do that a guy asked about that and he's
like oh yeah Marvel like no one would
allow you know Spider-Man can't be
murdering people oh that's just going to
be me trying to kick guys off building
yeah that's yeah definitely of course
well that sounds all right yeah it looks
really cool I came out of that I like
all the stuff they said more interested
than just after the press conference
stuff sure yeah uh then uh you and I
went to see Dave Lang's Extinction yeah
we did we saw we saw Dave Lang's
Extinction from Maximum games R Dave
Lang who has gone extinct yeah it's
unfortunate we lost him this year but uh
you know hey let's uh we'll have him in
here tomorrow night anyway uh yeah
that's uh it seems interesting it's a
third person you know the the third
person kind of action uh it actually has
some traversal stuff that reminded me of
some of the Spider-Man stuff a little
bit but it's more grappling hook based
you know you kind of get a little icon
on the environment like the corner of a
building or just the enemies themselves
like you know these kind of flying
creatures and stuff like that so you can
kind of zip around Dash in the air not
touch the ground and kind of Traverse
this world uh and it seems like the the
level they showed but also some of the
stuff they were saying about it almost
seems like it's it's a combat Arena yeah
or at least the the the part they were
showing was like hey uh there are
buildings at the center of this town
that cannot get [__] up these giant
ogres are going to come in and try to do
that make sure they don't uh and so you
have these fod enemies kind of around
and you can grapple onto them to get up
higher or just you know kill them and
you know you have put swords attacks and
stuff like that um but then these big
guys uh you kind of have to do some some
light Attack on Titan type stuff uh of
like they'll have armor on their like
legs and like wrists and stuff like that
so you can kind of get you know knock
the armor off if it's hard if it's like
higher level armor it might have buckles
on it that you have to break off uh
instead of just like wood armor which
you could just walk up and smash and
whatever and then once that's done you
can sever those limbs they grow back
very fast though so you kind of have
you're you're kind of immobilizing them
briefly of like oh I cut one foot off
and this guy's going to go down now I
need to get up on his head but if his
arms are active and they didn't actually
show a lot of the the the ogres kind of
like stopping you from doing stuff they
had a fully leveled up character at this
demo and they
wasting up so we didn't really get a
chance to see how the OG attack how they
fight back it seems go ahead is it
single player yeah yes but it it seems
very like score attack driven like it's
got leader boards it's going to a daily
challenge daily challenges Stu and so
that's why I say like you know it has
this kind of Arena thing to it where you
know if you watch that trailer at the
end of it they show all these ogres kind
of walking in so it seems like there's
almost like an endless mode in there
somewhere of like how long can you keep
the ogres at Bay um but you know some
good blood effects when you're severing
stuff like the and when you cut off the
head they're dead the the head falls off
and and then that whole thing goes away
just like real life just like real life
um but the bodies didn't really stick
around like the the limbs as you sever
them they would kind of fall off a
little bit start to and then they'd
Shimmer you know they'd kind of blink
out of existence uh and same with the
head and then eventually the body of the
thing so you didn't really get a sense
of just like Hey we're stacking up these
giant bodies you want the bodies to hit
the floor yeah I want to let the bodies
hit the floor yeah uh that's exactly
nothing wrong with that yeah um but yeah
I don't know it seems interesting um I
think that they've got some time to work
on it you know that's it's not a 2017
game right no it's not it's ear next
year so you know there's there's
something to it uh yeah for sure Ben you
uh yeah I saw some games uh I saw
Crackdown 3 yeah what do you think uh
pretty cool so it was uh you know uh
they had a demo out on the show floor uh
playable but this was kind of that but
more highly directed and they talked
more about the systems and stuff and it
made me realize how long it has been
since I've played a Crackdown game right
uh they started out by saying we wanted
to make Crackdown how you remembered it
um just like Mom used to make yeah right
some down home Crackdown yeah um so it
was it was a little portion of the city
and and basically so the the structure
it has the they called it the like
Touchback system or the the push back
system where kind of the more you
interact with the streets and the gangs
and stuff the more they interact with
you and uh so there's you know it's a
big city and there's a bunch of gangs
and a bunch of different uh groups that
are all intertwined and no story kind of
is just like go you know you have to
take out some big enemies that is the
Crackdown cck and so but they had kind
of almost Nemesis system thing where
there is the boss at the top but then he
has a certain number of lieutenants and
under them are a certain number of
captains and under them and then so you
kind of like learn about these
lieutenants or captains or whatever
through just you know if you defeat
certain guys they'll like you'll find
some audio log that might be the boss
talking to the lieutenant saying oh I
hate it when my Supply Depots get blown
up and so you're like I better
go saying that is it like the The
Riddler hint thing in Batman where you
could like look in Batman vision and
some of the guys would be green like oh
don't kill them he's got information
they didn't they didn't show like any of
the information gathering it was kind of
like um this is what we already know
about this you know this guy we're going
to take out it it was like the leader of
the police was one of the lieutenants
the leader like the bad leader yes nice
so Sting's there Stuart Copeland uh he's
like tantric just kind of there and
you're like oh I don't want to touch you
but so this game's about six hours
then like 10 oh all right yeah there's
an amazing payoff at the end yeah you're
going to want to stay around for that
climax I I like my game short you know
just bang them out 30 seconds that's
Crackdown three um no no it's cool so
you know they like uh the bad guys that
they were focusing on like controlled
the monil system and so once you killed
enough of the bad guys you kind of got
control of the monil system and then one
of the monals just got a big laser gun
on it from the agency and was going
around town just shooting all the bad
guys that it found okay yeah like uh
last night we had uh Clint the creative
director on it like he made it sound
like that you just go to this new island
and it's all crime yes it's a it's like
a million games on this huge volcanic
island uh they said it's 2.5 times the
size of Crackdown 2 both horizontally
and vertically and full crime um and
just just chalk full of crime with a big
old volcano in the middle that's which I
assume is also full of crime yeah a
crime volcano yeah all right if it's not
full of crime before then I'm going to
do my best to just like jump up and
throw as many people into the volcano as
possible you're going to start a
religion that's how you're going to got
to start somewhere we start here by
putting these people in this volcano and
start as zatu and whatever happen after
that hey I don't know Ben what about
visually cuz that was one thing from the
trailer that it looked pretty dated it
yeah it it looks a little uh so where it
looked really cool was like explosions
and particles and they had a singularity
gun that shot black holes and sucked
cars into it that then exploded into
other things and that all looks really
good it was really good frame rate um
ran very smoothly even with just every
like the guy was like I have
accidentally made too many explosions
here cuz like it was exploding over a
story lady talking and just like going
up bigger and bigger and bigger that
sounds good but like still running very
well um yeah I think you know we we saw
it at the Showcase they had a few days
ago and I took a look at it and there
were some things about it were like oh
the character doesn't really have a
shadow here like the parts of it look
plain and it was hard to parse whether
that was just like this is the art style
they're going for and it's got that kind
of comic Booky kind of cell shaded look
or is it hey they've got work to do it
seem like it was a little bit in between
yeah or or maybe not not quite finished
but I I I think I think it looks it
looks like a a decent modern video game
it looks like a slightly better Saints
Row looking kind of open world game Cool
were they demoing it single player yes
um yeah the multiplayer stuff is the
stuff that's like Cloud connected and
all destructible buildings and stuff and
they haven't really I mean they've got a
whole separate team working on that oh W
is that the Sumo digital team or Sumo
Sumo is doing the single player and
reagent uh which is the David Jones uh
team is is doing the multiplayer Dave
Jones is working yeah real time worlds
doesn't exist anymore they like oh
that's real time world like no it's it's
different it's different Squad guy
different Squad and then I guess uh
Terry Cruz accidentally broke embargo by
saying I am going to be in this video
game as a playable character so they
were like he's going to be in you can't
embargo Terry Cruz you can't do it you
can't embargo those biceps no that's it
would be foolish to even try uh did you
get around see anything else of note uh
I checked out some Ashen which looked
pretty cool um it's so it's Dark Souls
oh but where it's cool so cyberspace so
most of the present like three4 of the
presentation I was just watching this
game saying this is 100% dark souls you
know they're like large interconnected
world where dungeons kind of wind in
with each other mysterious MPCs who you
know you don't really get a lot from but
maybe if you present them with certain
items they will tell you some other
stuff sure um but where this game was
kind of unique was the multiplayer
system it kind of runs like Journey
where it's always searching for somebody
else and it plops them into your world
it's a maximum of one other person uh
you don't get their gamertag there's no
voice chat uh in fact dungeons don't
even open until you have two people they
said you can play offline and it'll
spawn an AI dude for you um but what's
cool is so like they previewed a dungeon
so the dungeon door opens up they go
through and they fight and fight and
fight and if you successfully clear a
level with an a with one of your uh
computer friends they will join your
town as an NPC and they said like they
will start doing different things like
they walked back and showed off like
this guy crafts potions and this other
guy will make armor so you can kind of
grow out your village they said you know
there's not leveling up or anything but
uh you know like there's a Talisman
system where you can kind of trade off
like I want to attack faster but take do
less damage or I want to you know do
more damage and take more damage thing
that'll do yeah yeah um Halo skulls or
something and and there's like you know
emotes you can like you know like wave
to each other and stuff like that but
beyond that no communication so that's
you have to but to grow your town you
have to play with a with an AI companion
either an AI or another human okay
another human that that like human model
will still come back to your town that
model will just hang out your player
then is like working but if they they're
just gone forever and you're trapped in
that dungeon by yourself which they said
it's very hard to clear them by yourself
so can another player come in at no once
you're once you're in you're in you're
in so you just quit the game at that
point or or you know you try and like
they they said like a lot of times some
one guy would die during the boss fight
and the other guy would just like
courageously carry on and so what
happens if like players are just like
waiting to get joined up and then just
like goodbye I'm going to quit yeah and
I feel like there might be some level of
trolling where it's like they said oh
you know you can kind of communicate
with each other through how you move and
where you go but I feel like there'll be
a fair amount of trolling of like hey
I'm going to lead you down this long
path and then just like and then this I
know this trap here and that'll be funny
for everyone or like an emote that is
like sorry my baby's crying I need to I
need to go it's just like a pull it out
the collar like got to go mom says I
need to turn the
system setting a controller down and
walking away and um they said they
haven't ruled out the idea of playing
like with the friends list but they
didn't want they want they were like we
want to explore the opportunity of just
playing this with strangers I think
that's that's a cool idea yeah sounds
cool uh Alex how about you today was day
uh mostly of driving uh I saw both Gran
Turismo and uh Forza and so I think more
so than just about any other uh genre of
game at the show here these are the most
buzzwordy games like you know gr tur is
leaning very hard on the HDR stuff uh
and Forza is very much about you know
the 4K and car games man yeah and and
they were yes no they are I I can
confirm uh they were both leaning on
those very hard uh for the gr Turismo
demo they had uh yuchi uh they had him
up there and he gave about a 20-minute
PowerPoint presentation about HDR and
all things it's doing about and the four
years they spent uh just completely
redoing all those car models making it
so that like they had way more deluxe
cars in there uh are does that mean that
there will be cars in that game that are
not Deluxe cars didn't sound it sounded
like they might just not have as many
overall cards as some of the other games
but they would all have like the full
detail stuff that was how it came across
anyway all right uh and after that you
know they just put us on one of those
stupid rigs with the the big chair and
whatever uh and had us all race do you
get the impression that would by calling
it gr turism a sport is there any kind
of specific focus on it that previous GT
games didn't have or is it just kind of
look like hey this is the next Grand
Turismo I mean the only cars they let us
drive in that were all sports models
like
rally Focus cars for the dirt tracks and
you know like full on like GT style
models for the they might have announced
that maybe I just following it yeah uh
but that said you know it plays well
like the the driving was really good I
mean it always feels good when you're on
one of those those giant rigs uh there's
a 10-second video going around that Dave
Lang uh creep shotted me while I was
driving so go looking for that if you
want right uh Forza you know Forza looks
great they they talked a lot about you
know the stuff they learned from from
Apex uh and the issues had on the PC the
last time around uh they are very
focused on on making that PC version as
good as the the Xbox version and Horizon
3 runs really good now there was a patch
recently that that really makes that
game run a lot better like it launched
Horizon 3 even you know Apex had its
issues but but Horizon did too it is it
is interesting that like when they were
talking about Horizon they don't talk
about Horizon as like a separate thing
like they talk about it very much is
like there is a lineage of Forza and
those two things are completely
intertwined there is no separation
between playground and turn 10 in terms
of like what that brand is yeah it just
seems like you know turn 10 definitely
touches the Horizon games in some ways
you know a lot of it's their Tech and
stuff like that but also yeah uh it's
interesting you know the the way we
think of a lot of like two team
franchises and stuff is very much their
game our game their game our game and
then yeah but for them it seems like
it's all just like kind of one
continuous lineage yeah the game looks
great you know uh they were talking up
some of the you know the features of
like you know the it has one drive
support so like if you have your music
on there like if you're just hanging out
in the garage or even when you're
driving like you'll hear your music like
playing on the speakers and the the
different tracks all those uh oh well I
guess one drive you get for free I was
going to say like Groove music
subscribers yeah I had that trial for
the mon that everyone had for a month
and I was like oh this is kind of neat I
don't want to go organize a playlist for
this game boy it should be nice if I
could just put a USB stick in this thing
huh anyway yeah I don't I have the
weirdest luck with Forza demos though
like every year that's like somehow I
just end up with like the most awkward
demo like last year uh there were some
Korean journalists in there and their
translator absolutely would not stop
talking during the middle of the demo
they were giving to the point where PR
had to like beg them to stop and this
year there was just a guy sitting next
to me and after like the driving section
of the demo he was like hey were you
really driving because you're your hand
movements weren't matching to the thing
like really aggressively and everyone
kind of looked each other like right
got exposed
theal you see them just being like yeah
I've been driving this whole [__] E3
dude I don't know what you're talking
about like replied about it but I I just
don't know why that game for all re I
just had the worst luck that's uh that's
a really strange thing they would fake I
mean of all the things you would fake
and I don't think he was faking really
don't I was watching him play too it did
not seem like it all right you getting a
scoop is tough
got to get your hands dirty you got to
dig deep man you got to dig deep these
days uh and the last thing Brad and I
saw was a state of De k 2 that gave
looks great yeah I watched state of you
like the first one a whole lot I did but
I except it was rough basically told the
developer like hey I tried to like your
first game a lot and I kind of couldn't
it I kind of bounced off of it at times
too he totally knew what I was talking
about sure they seem to be addressing a
lot of those complaints okay uh that
thing is an like continues to be an
amazingly complex simulation like the of
things you have to worry about sorry I
know I sound terrible it's fun actually
hear you yeah it's it's great stuff but
uh they the the amount of information
feedback you're getting now from why
your human settlement is going to [__]
constantly seems like it's going to help
a lot like it's not just like Fallout 4
like hey our settlement needs help come
back here want to do that yeah like he
acknowledged like the first time the
first game like like you would you know
your your people would be starving all
the time or they would be irritable and
refuse to fight or like you know it's a
management Sim and like would goong and
you didn't know why they just have like
straight up red and green text under
each thing now it's like it's like oh
you're getting plus 20 morale from this
lady from like the lady who's a gardener
but you're getting minus three from the
guy who snores like it's [__] like that
yeah it say it's like a thousand traits
now that they're pulling from a set of a
couple hundred the first one had for the
generate characters you level characters
up and like you invest a lot of time in
them but then when they die they're dead
forever right they're they're adding
multiplayer finally which is the thing
the first game didn't have uh you can
invite people into your game and you can
join other people's games but you also
there's a thing where people can set
their game to I don't know like just
join whenever like like there's like a
Lobby system you can join into you set
like a public option and then uh if
you're playing the game you can shoot a
flare if you're in trouble and you're
just like [__] I need help right now you
can shoot a flare and then the game will
go out and search for people who have
that flag set that they want to join
games and it'll match them into your
game immediately so they could just like
come in and help you out in a in a tough
situation and it sound like they'll get
specific rewards for they'll get rewards
you know if it's like in narrative like
I will see a flare go off in the
distance and I have to drive to it kind
of thing imagine if you knew your world
you know that
that they' have to fake a lot of stuff
for that yeah that' be neat though but
that game continues to be Savage as [__]
you know like your people can die and be
dead forever and also the map like just
like the first game like there's a
finite amount of resources out there and
that's it you know like like there's a
finite amount of like ammo and food and
all that stuff out in the world you
clear out of town like you're going to
have to start venturing further and
further out yeah so does that mean
there's an end game uh yeah there is a
story okay uh yeah you can beat the game
and it just sounds like a a bigger more
fleshed out version of the first one but
like that first game has so much
potential it just didn't quite get there
so like I'm super excited about but you
know I mean it obviously did so well for
them that like you know they they've
gotten a lot more leeway to kind of
build the thing they want to build out
of it now yeah it seems like this was
maybe the game that they wanted to
always make and maybe they'll get there
Dan how about you uh outside of the Sony
stuff I saw with Brad I saw agents at
Mayhem and it is very we play that last
year yeah it's very Saints Row as you
can probably tell from the trailers and
developer and everything um they told me
that they were trying to go more for
Action game first with some humor second
which Saint Row kind of just turned into
like naked gun at some point yeah um and
it's it was good it was better than I
expected it to be there was a lot of
customization stuff you could do you've
got the three agents at one time I don't
know if you guys had that swap between
them right yeah so like if one person's
powers are on cool down you can switch
to this other person and and fight with
them if one dies it's not all three of
them out fighting at the same time right
you teleport them in and out Bas yeah
yeah yeah and like everyone's got a
triple jump and a Dash like I thought it
was a nice way of scaling back what four
was Saints Row four because they went so
big on that superpower stuff that you're
just kind of flying around and stuff and
it's a superhero game at some point so
this kind of grounds it more even though
they're triple jumping stuff they're not
flying over skyscrapers but they're
still they're still very mobile yeah but
they also have a bunch of really weird
weapons and stuff this stuff called
Gremlin Tech and it's on a cool down so
like I can pop this one that if I shoot
you you turn into a little bouncing like
peep like a little rabbit thing and if
you hit Brad he turns into a peep and if
you hit like and so by I went into a
club at one point and popped it and by
the end it was all these like exploding
rabbits bouncing all over the place so
much so still goofy still goofy uh the
thing I didn't like as much was the
writing like Saints Row was never like
the most like clever intelligent comedy
it had a found its way it did and this
strikes me as like a new writer trying
to hit those marks but isn't as good at
it I'm pretty sure most of the people
that wrote three and four are gone from
volition at this point yeah I feel like
they they've had some turnover over
there and yeah it's just it seems like
it's kind of trying hard for that like
cursy like you know easy sex joke comedy
and it's just like nothing like
offensive or anything it was just kind
of like lame some of the writing but you
know I just saw a couple little Parts I
like when we played it like I I looked
at it went like oh well I'm swapping
between characters but clearly this is a
three-player co-op and they were like no
they didn't say anything about that it's
not and you're like
oh huh yeah that's a choice yeah yeah
that's that that was how I felt about
that gaml last year I was like that's a
choice like this doesn't seem like
terrible or anything but yeah I don't
know seems like a b game it might be it
might be a b game let's talk about this
for 45 minutes yeah let's stick no we're
no more talking one thing I do
appreciate is like you know STS the
third started doing this stuff where you
know you could just Sprint and press lb
or whatever like just dive into a car
and start driving whereas more realistic
open world games like GTA or something
you have to like stop the car or the
animation like open the door get the guy
out this goes even further like instead
of having to go to a cell phone to like
summon a car you just tap up on the
d-pad and a car just like comes blazing
around the corner your character just
does little sassy animation and then
flies in and then you're driving it's
just like that so you're just calling
your horse and it just rides up and just
get in and go sure you just
automatically get on and go all right so
it's it's definitely that tone of Saints
Row um but but yeah I it's the right
direction I think for it but but I just
the writing is a little not great from
what I saw we see that uh did not see
Johnny Gat but we heard about the is
that a pre-order bonus like that yeah
that's well but it was it played better
than I expected people really like
Johnny Gat as it turns out like that
always seemed like a really weird thing
for like people get hyped about like G
his back I'm like yeah okay show for
it's almost like this fast and furious
thing where it's like yeah these movies
and games are super stupid but they take
their characters super seriously and as
a result the fans kind of attach
themselves to that so
I don't know honestly that was more of a
Keith David guy MH yeah we all you know
I think everyone is also a Keith David
gu all right well uh thanks for all of
that
information uh and we'll check back in
with you tomorrow uh about some more
video games uh but right now we are
going to take it down and take a break
and get some guests on here and the show
will continue stay
tuned
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
keep giving the up we're going to do it
all keep giving the love we're going to
do it all the love the love the love
we're going to do it all the love we're
going to do it all the love we're going
to do it
all the going to do it
[Music]
all
going to do it all give it do it
all it do it
all give it the it all give it the love
give the love give it the love all give
it the love give it the love give it the
love going do it
[Music]
all
n
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
w
[Music]
good
a
[Music]
he
[Applause]
n
[Music]
w
oh
[Music]
donut
autut
[Music]
oh
h
[Music]
oh
what's up everybody well welcome back to
the
show
words no no we're we faded out in favor
yeah one more
time it's me it's Jeff gersman hi we're
back we've got another Couch full of
guests uh full of friends and contenders
and and all sorts of business over here
what's what's going on we got the number
one [__] contender in the place
to be Samoa Joe is
here right on the bomb yeah uh thanks so
much for coming uh Xavier Woods of
course returning also number one
Contender also number one contender in
the Wind Jammers world as
well Tag Team Championship you got a
double contendership TR try I don't have
to fight Brock Lesnar though yeah no
that's that's tough yeah I got to beat
him half to death to get what I want so
it's going to work out right it's about
time someone did yeah he deserves it uh
Drew scandin is here could been a
contender from uh from cloth map some
yeah you're a contender you're a cloth
map Contender I am yeah thanks Xavier
Woods
man we got team dancers back there you
know this a real [__] up reunion
episode I didn't expect it to go this
way no we got a lot of emails so yeah
you want to jump right to that sure okay
they've got questions we've got dancers
dancers dancers podcast Dan and Dan rer
here hi welcome hi thanks so much yeah I
want to ask these two guys Floyd
Mayweather Conor McGregor who's going to
win Floyd yeah running away well they're
not intimidated by the fact that I'm
Irish one bit oh
noat I don't see a drink in your hand so
you don't have your powers oh no never
mind the most Irish of drinks the
Mexican drink
is the pride of
Dublin is that Mexicans and Irish are
like the same thing like big Catholic
families
lots of drinking we all both love hor
going you know what I I'm liking this
analogy yeah uh you know no I'm I'm most
Irish I Floyd Mayweather definitely
that's 100% what if McGregor what if the
fight starts and McGregor just kicks him
in the [__] this is literally every
Irish te in the world and what they're
going to say for the next until the
fight what if are these boxing rules or
what if I was fighting him and I kicked
him right in the throat what if brings
down the tunder in his right hand and
puts it across his face and all of
Ireland raises up in a roar oh be I
didn't
know me on this actually now I'm like
wait a minute actually that work out are
you sure he's not Irish Joe yeah o he's
been fooling everybody all along I've
drinking Off Your Whiskey I'll play
that so uh you guys have been here I
mean obviously you know handling some
video game business hosting some some
shows representing out there uh how is
how has E3 been going did you get any
time to like walk around and see
anything or uh we walked around and saw
a little bit the the main thing that we
did today was uh play Call of Duty the
World War II was fantastic yeah it was
really really good that was sick we came
up with the new catch race for it yes
yeah boots on the ground again put the
jetpacks
down I got take that I got take the the
again out yeah boots on the ground put
the jetpacks down there we go all right
that's that's pretty good so technically
he came up with it so all we're asking
for 10% we're working putting that into
copyright and hopefully they'll use it
we're going to put them on those little
Gummy BRAC let everybody wears now yeah
now everyone's in the slap yeah yeah hot
[__] [__] right there and then doing
like a little bit of stage hosting as
well right um no not yet so uh tomorrow
uh we're on we're doing stuff with gam
spot um but for today like we did the
Call of Duty uh we went and played the
Dragon Ball fighting game which is it
looks I mean unreal was a hell of a game
and like it's like Guilty Gear and MVC
match together and it's just like we get
all these characters from Dragon Ball
Universe like the the trunks the free
those are the literally the only dragon
balls in
character Vegeta there's a Goku yeah are
you and Mr Dragon big anime fan uh yeah
I mean I mean I followed it and uh I
wouldn't say that I'm I'm I'm a really
in-depth anime fan but I've I watch
enough and I've experienced enough that
I have a good working knowledge of the
anime universe so Dragon Ball Z you know
I think everybody's kind of whether
you're an anime fan or not you soak in
somee for video games you're just like
no that's the Cell Games I know yeah the
cell yeah stuff happens yeah which which
is the best Saga which we talked about
yeah we were debating Frieza versus Cell
Saga like I don't know Frieza Saga never
really ends cuz it keeps coming back and
then he's gold and that just means he
didn't get right at the first time okay
Fair anyway yes yeah uh so then then
tomorrow doing a little bit of stage
show hosting is that the yeah I think I
think it's just interviews with games
gam spot um oh okay he's the guy who
took my job this is how it went there
yeah that's uh I told you I'm I'm
encroaching I'm coming in I'm coming
forcing my way into the games industry
going to be making documentaries about
rocket League next yeah hey I mean went
to the World Championships which was
awesome I actually remember when we met
at that SummerSlam and I told you that I
wanted to do stuff with games yeah yeah
I told you I want to like write articles
and stuff yeah see yep yep coming in
2012 I'm just following your footsteps
you you pave the way for BL the tra for
all these
[__] Daniel DWI is the original
man that's yeah definitely Drew scandin
back in the United States that's right
uh for like this fleeting moment here
yeah uh how's it been out there
traveling the world seeing what there is
to see and coming back to E3 for like
why would you why why are you here what
are you doing all one it's all one long
journey Jeff okay all right uh I
actually wasn't going to be here uh
because I I didn't think I would be able
to slot in I didn't want to like book E3
and then have to book my first trip
around that cuz like first trip you got
a nail right sh have I went to Los
Angeles yeah wouldn't travel Document
there a great burrito around the corner
here I drove this truck down here yeah
uh yeah I and then I realized that my uh
sister had put together this trip for
our family to come down and celebrate my
dad's birthday the weekend before E3 so
uh on Saturday night I went and saw
Chicago and the Doobie Brothers oh what
how good were the dues was Michael
McDonald with them no oh okay okay yeah
so it was it was just he really Come
Sail Away Michael McDonald's my jam yeah
I mean I I am more of a early Dobie
Brothers fan and early Chicago as well
although they played all the hits Jee I
mean I imagine at this point they're
really going to run through you know the
full catalog they're not going to go
like oh we only play the new stuff yeah
yeah Chicago there's four original dudes
still left and they're like three of
them are over 70 years old and they
played for like two and a half hours
that's like I imagine at that point you
got to like go to sleep after that [__]
like wake up do the show and then be
like all right we're done like the tour
is over let's go that's I mean in the
World of Sports entertainment and the
World of Wrestling you know the thought
of doing that sort of stuff at 70 seems
Preposterous but
meair I not to say there's not people
out there doing it but maybe it's a
little
Preposterous uh but that's uh yeah I
mean when you guys are on the road doing
this sort of stuff sort of like the
Dobie Brothers sort of like Chicago is
it definitely like pretty much just like
Chicago ex I was going to say Chicago is
definitely the yeah I mean we're playing
instruments they're playing instruments
brass yeah yeah uh is it a lot of you
know on the road just like okay what
like show's over we got it like I'm done
like I'm spent finished or is it like
the next part starts so depending on uh
whether you're flying up in the morning
you'll drive to the next town which
could be like you from like 3 to 4 hours
usually 3 to four hours lately 3 to 4
hours brutal so uh to the next town get
to your hotel like 2: or 3 in the
morning go to sleep try to wake up at
like 900 or 10 if you can get to getout
in has that gotten better since the
brand
split um we we I think we gained a day
yeah yeah but uh the schedule
essentially is still pretty much the
same so it's like uh you know instead of
two days a week we have three days a
week kind of middle of the week that we
have for us and then um but I mean other
than that it's like literally when we
get done with the show usually you're
right back in the car and if you have
something the next night you get on to
the next town it's just uh kind of kind
of out of habit nature of the Beast yeah
nature of the beast but you know hey
it's uh it's cool gig yeah can't can't
complain it's funny especially going to
travel everywhere like all over the
world as you're traveling as well so uh
it's it's such a jet set couch this is
guys are like just's compare
passports TSA pre-check yeah yeah clear
yeah GL yeah Global Entry the the cool
thing I know from my perspective is
being able to go to Arcade bars just
around the world I see you on Twitter
you're always is like where can I play
NBA Jam dude it's the best and people if
like if I don't know one in the area
people will tell me and I'll go and then
people will be there to play so it's and
it's not even
like anything crazy people just want to
come up and play video games right and
that to me is like that's the essence of
everything that we're all about we just
want to play games with people from
other places and see what kind of skills
they have and for me like you said it's
NBA Jam that is like the bar for me well
I mean you know next time there's a
pay-per-view in Petaluma California I've
got N Jam machine in my
garage come through and play yeah come
on through I'll show you how no actually
actually you probably whoop my [__]
ass what about Blitz blit NFL Blitz like
I
will I'm not great throw these and then
I've seen it yeah he's he's been the
he's never play against you but wit now
he's just [__] lying over
there Danny how's it going for you
obviously you know you're you're still
uh in the world of covering video games
uh doing your thing is it is so I mean
but how is E3 different for you cuz
obviously like you were doing hosting
gigs last year and going to this party
on the roof because that's fun I
know I left the suit at home yeah nice
you didn't have to wear the suit this
year this is good stuff so are you just
kind of like book like building material
for like the next set of documentaries
it's it's actually a really boring
answer we're actually just like doing
meetings for stuff for the rest of the
year so like no filming so we it's just
kind of like hey we would like to do
something on your game and like today we
locked down basically 4 months worth of
work with like upcoming documentar so I
mean people are in town and like the
thing about E3 as well is that you know
folks have announced their game finally
or they've said what date it's going to
be and then suddenly they're like okay
now do you want to come in and and you
know shoot something about the game uh
so yeah we've I basically booked the
next like three or four months worth of
stuff uh so I'm just chilling the [__]
out now yeah that's exciting yeah Shadow
E3 in full effect right yeah but but
it's weird like going past the Gamespot
stage and now being like like an alumni
like I still can't believe that I got to
work at Gamespot for four or five years
so the fact that I'm like walking past
it like that whole you know
ex-girlfriend thing where you're like
man we really didn't get along at the
end but but it wasn't so bad was it we
had some good time I could relate to
that part yeah the difference is I I
dumped them you got dumped yeah it's
worked out fine both of us wow um so
Wind Jammers not to you know just run
NBA Jam to Wind Jammers but that's you a
big proponent of frisbee pong frisbe
High action yeah like so Wind Jammers
and then obviously we got disc Jam too
which I think a lot of times when games
that are similar that come out we
automatically think that they're
competition for each other but I think
that these two games are actually going
to enhance one another because one's got
like the tennis aspect and one's got the
pong aspect but both of them it's it's
it's the same Sport and I think just
bringing more people to that style of
play and that type of game is going to
be unreal I figured I was going to
really hate dis Jam when I when I when
it first came out and I started looking
at it I'm just like it seems so slow
this is not Wind Jammers what am I even
doing this is a waste of my and I was
like oh actually wait this actually this
feels all right this feels a little
different but this is still pretty good
but obviously they just ran that beta
for uh Wind Jammers on PS4 like I I
think it just shut down while we were
here yeah on the 12th yeah I got like
one day in like I'm like I should
probably pack
but uh it works pretty well yeah that
was the the big concern like can you
play this over the internet and have it
work or is it going to be it's like
perfect yeah uh and I don't like saying
that I don't like saying that I I was
getting pretty low pings it felt good
like I felt like I was playing a proper
game of Jammers I think it's one of
those things because it's not uh a ton
of stuff going on right it's just two
characters moving and their phis be
going back and forth It's not like
grenades being thrown explosions in
like 12 hit combos in a fight you know
like you know maybe it is a little
different yeah yeah so I that definitely
helps it out I think playing people cuz
like when I play people in France like
you would know when you're play somebody
in France cuz like you just get messed
up yeah Wind Jammer France is where
that's where Wind Jammer Savages live
straight murderers it's so weird to say
like oh the French are destroy let me
tell you about it it's going to blow
your mind but no I mean I mean even uh
when when they came out to show it to us
you know I fancy myself like I'm all
right at Wind Jammers but you know I was
a little out of practice to be fair but
then I just got [__] worked like they
just came in and said here's the game
we're making [__] you and I was like oh
great I didn't win any of these that's a
we know you like this we're going to
destroy your dreams now yeah basically
that's how it went and I like well okay
that's you know maybe I'll get on the
internet and maybe I can get above wood
tier into something but uh do they have
tears like that they do wood silver gold
yeah and if I start getting matched with
people well how I mean how's the French
Wind Jammer scen you've seen it
firsthand a little bit um so I they flew
me to to Paris and it was incredible
like literally went for the day to film
and then flew back home to go wrestle
and do some more stuff but like we went
to the the the arcade area where they
were filming everything and literally
they just like ran through me everyone
there is like a Wind Jammer expert and
it wasn't even almost close yeah any
game but they taught me all these tricks
when I came back to the states to play
with my friends I was running house but
over there yeah pick up a few things but
that's that's a new show you should like
go to countries and just get work like
whatever game they're in to start
playing Starcraft in Korea but
like talk a gang of trash you know he
like I'm coming through Korea bring your
A game my guess if you got it Starcraft
2 you're going down slapping Kim CH had
a cat's hands be like what just real
real rough and ghetto and then just get
worked just leave with my head hung come
back to the station just burn everybody
yeah yeah I got I hold it down I hold it
down here at least I like that I like
that you want I I would love to watch do
that you
travel have you heard of patreon yes yes
okay we'll do that all right check out
there our new patreon for our new show
we're bringing up they just launched all
kinds of new tools uh yeah you can live
stream on that thing you can live stream
to members
only huh it's almost like a missing
piece of a
puzzle anyway like somebody over there
is not doing their job yeah who would
think of something so crazy yeah it's
live streaming why would you do it yeah
to members only that seems ridiculous
what no this show is for everybody this
is E3 we're here hanging out the
entirety of the internet focused upon us
I like that uh you know it's like the
people out there just just love games
like Dan you know you uh play Clash
Royale every single day right not I used
to I used to
and play it every other day now no it's
not on my phone anymore Xavier back me
up in that it's a good game I'll show
you my [__] I I think I tweeted the
[__] image of me deleting it there
look um it's it's awful that's like
tweeting a picture of you in line at a
methadone clinic like I'm good I'm good
like it's a really well-made game but
it's awful at the way they structure the
stuff like did you spend money on it no
okay I spent hundreds of dollars see
that's see Dan hundreds yeah like this
whole time hey I I just said in the
other room that like all these games are
literally app pyramid schemes yeah and
we all Buy in and and and you ruin
friendships by getting your friends
hooked into them and you end up spending
hundreds of dollars
in I spent $5 on Whiz Khalifa's weed
farm last week I'm not proud of it but
that's just how it went it was the right
offer I'm like oh 60 different new
strains huh that's really going to make
my weed farm look really
good I guess I'm an [__] here we go
well so Xavier I thought everyone
enjoyed Clash of Clans at least cuz
that's the one they seemed most militant
about the chat and everything but then I
talked to you just now about it and you
hate it too no I don't hate it I'm out
cuz I was spending too much time so it
was to the point where I was so hardcore
in it that it was like hurting my day
wait do you like the game though like
the playing of it I I think the game is
fun but I can't play a game like that
unless I'm completely devoted are these
games a problem in the locker room is it
is it like I wouldn't say a problem but
they get intense they used to be a
problem so so just to give a little bit
of insight so what happened to get us
into these games Cena started playing
Clash of Clans mhm this was maybe two
and a half years ago and then he was
like Hey I need people in my clan I was
like I tried this game and I didn't like
it it's because I didn't have a clan so
a bunch of us got in we got so serious
about it it's like 15 of us but then
what would happen is if you didn't do
well in war you were nervous to go to
work because you know you know Cena
would be disappointed in you yeah and
then it it turned from Cena being
disappointed to the whole clan being
disappointed in you so if you got like a
onear war on like a Sunday and you're
going to Raw on Monday you in the locker
room so were there any like any in ring
action that was maybe a little stiffer
than it should have been as a result of
a war it Taking Liberties was hey man
come on it was just you know you were
hanging your head in shame walking in
the locker room which is a weird
turnaround from the way wrestling used
to be it wasn't all video games it was
like we're we're living fast and we're
on airplanes and limousines woo but like
now it's like you got one star in the
war you dress in the hallway it's like
yeah there's that and like what like
like Big Show on a bus somewhere playing
Destiny that's dude he L Destiny yeah no
he hosted on a pan he did he he went off
of me cuz I was a Vanguard like lost his
mind that's hey you play Dy said yeah
man he's like what character I have one
like character I was like oh it's
Vanguard oh my God I would I expect more
from you like well that's oh just
discussed with me for like a week it
takes it seriously but that's the the
cool thing about uh kind of the way that
wrestling has turned since we've had
this gaming channel up up down down
subcribe if you haven't subscribed
already on Twitter and Instagram up up
down down without the O's um but uh just
being able to have a platform where guys
and girls that enjoy games can kind of
push that agenda and say like no just
because I'm on TV wrestling doesn't mean
I don't like this other stuff I think a
lot of fans see us on television they
say this is how they are this is who
they are this is what they are they put
us in a box you are wrestler a you dance
you have crazy hair you're 7 feet tall
and that's what you are so with up up
down down we're being able to come out
and say Big Show loves Destiny here's a
platform to cut a 15-minute promo about
it that I ask him one question he just
goes off and it's like and now we got
Joe at E3 and we're doing up up down
that stuff and people are coming into
this culture that we have of wrestling
and saying oh they play games too and
now we get to do stuff like this with
you guys and thank you for letting us
into your world so like it's it's cool
like that for us yeah it's been I you
know that's been one of the fascinating
things I think over I'm trying to think
like is it last 15 years or 10 years or
wrestling maybe it's it's even shorter
than that but like it really seems like
there's a lot of people in the wrestling
business that grew up really just like
loving the art of wrestling whereas
before it felt like uh like these almost
like 70s rockers in a lot of way where
they were just like just tough guys and
just like yeah I don't know I do it
whatever but now it feels like I maybe
it's just that's you know people talk
about it more openly different it's a
direct result of just the changing media
environment because I remember when I
was coming up in the wrestling business
um you know most people before my
generation only had access to one kind
of wrestling it was either WWE on you
know Saturday mornings and and Monday
evenings and that was pretty much the
gist of it but as I came up and you know
the internet came about you know then
you got you know Tape Traders and then
from Tape Traders spawn YouTube videos
and there became a a greater exposure to
very different styles of wrestling and
from Mexico to Japan to um you know
across the United States even smaller
companies ECW and uh as the kind of the
the country's media grew so did the
tastes in wrestling and especially when
you have younger guys coming up they
just experienced more different kinds of
styles and some people Incorporated it
some people you know they like the
straight on you know uh I guess American
style of wrestling and some people kind
of have a hybrid style and they take
from here and there and they they take
what they like and leave what they don't
so I think that's just a byproduct of
that if anything you know yeah just just
exposure to yeah you just it was it was
more accessible whereas like before um
you know if you wanted to see wrestling
from other countries you would have to
be a part of a tape trading list and you
had to have relationships with people
and it was a real difficult committed
process and as became more convenient
obviously uh you know you you had people
who were more preached of the art
because they had more exposure to it
yeah for me I had to you know like go
over to Alex's house and like look at
his big mask collection yeah and just
like all right man let's watch these
tapes uh and yeah no definitely like
that was like seeing some more of that
stuff and now just with the way that
streaming on the internet and all this
other stuff is has led to even further
exposure of just like now you have
people watching Live Events taking place
in other countries and other promotions
and all that stuff like it's just been
it's been awesome to see and and even
just the way it kind of seems to have
changed the way WWE thinks about all
this stuff WWE definitely thinks more
globally now yeah absolutely I mean we
Pro we're probably more Global than
we've ever been in the history of the
company I mean uh and it shows up in our
fan base cuz like now when we do
WrestleMania weekend which becomes like
this great pilgrimage for wrestling fans
around the world you know several other
companies run their events around the
same time same area uh we're obviously
we we WrestleMania we have NXT and all
this other stuff so as this all as this
is all going on you know we start to
meet people from countries you wouldn't
even think you know we would have
exposure from like Indonesia yeah you
know like we're going to New Orleans why
wrestl oh okay of course yeah and and
like it's it's as comical as it sounds I
mean this guy came me he's like y I'm a
big wrestling fan you know we 12 from
Zimbabwe I was like oh my God what like
you know like word yeah like we
channeled that on man yeah yeah yeah the
Channel's on like I know a dude yeah
yeah that's uh yeah that's that's pretty
awesome so it's like you know I think uh
we we've kind of uh especially now at
the network like we're embracing like
you know we have a more Global appeal
and we have fans kind of spread out
throughout the world we definitely tour
more
internationally you know it used to be
before you know we'd head over to Europe
we go twice a year but now there's like
random tour sometimes we go like four
times a year but it's like a it's like a
weekend tour to Germany right and then
go somewhere else but like we had a show
in Tokyo so we stopped in London to do a
show and then went to Tokyo to do two
shows and it's like what is happening
yeah like how we going to so many count
it right now where am I state so messed
up uh it's it's it's a it's a journey
yeah and then just I mean just even the
the program I you know like obviously
you know you both have time in NXT and
all this other stuff but also just like
seeing the stuff show up on the network
like now the the women's tournament
coming up or the the UK tournament and
some of this other stuff like just it's
been cool to see it branching out Beyond
like raw then Smackdown we're we're
building to the pay-per-view and just
like having it be like that Cadence like
having all this other stuff around the
edges really neat to to Joe's point
about uh just widening the widening
effect of different media sources um
being able to bridge gaming and
wrestling bringing more fans into
wrestling and more wrestling fans into
gaming is awesome cuz like you said with
the women's tournament and the UK
tournament it's like there are fans of
different kinds of wrestling that are
also fans of different kinds of games
that are still able to come together in
this synergistic like Unity so like
people always ask be like yeah
like people people usually ask like oh
you know uh why would you mix wrestling
and games it's like dude because it's
two communities that are one in the same
like people who are shunned for doing
certain things past like 13 years years
old oh you still watch wrestling like oh
well I grew up and it's like oh you
still play games I grew up it's like
dude like it's the same people and also
it's like hey comic book movies are the
biggest movies in the world what like
what are we even talking about and now
all the people that made fun of us are
the ones who are like oh that's really
cool like what do you know about it it's
like no no no no no no you don't get to
come into our world now no no no too
late yeah yeah you stay over there now
and also in the years since I got kind
of built and I can [__] you up exactly I
exactly I wanted to go to the routes
like people used to be mean to me in
school for like for being super into
comic books and stuff and now those same
people are on Facebook like hey we send
this figure for my kid and it's like I
sure will yeah yeah I will CU I'm a
bigger man that's what say literally and
figuratively
yeah Danny how's it been being out on
your own um it's been has it been a year
now it's been 10 months yeah since I
left Gamespot and started this thing um
it's been like creatively probably the
most exciting time of my life because
you know you've got car launch and you
can do whatever you want Oh totally the
blank slate and is like it's a little
frightening but also like it's very
fulfilling when as you start to build
that stuff out yeah and like the
reaction has been amazing like you know
starting up a YouTube channel that was
based on like not dealing with any
advertising and also like publishing one
video every like six weeks that's like
40 everyone loves on YouTube yeah long
videos on YouTube occasionally so to see
us like blast past 100,000 Subs which is
like we're not even like the numbers
don't really matter that much because
ultimately it's it's for the patrons but
to see like The Wider appeal and to see
people going like oh why weren't people
doing this before and it's like that's
what I was saying [__] four years ago
and here we are well it's sometimes if
you can't find a way you got to get out
there and do it on your own Drew you're
finding a way I am yeah uh yeah how was
euro
vision I can't believe he got to go to
Eurovision before the [__] Irish guy
he's more dedicated Drew has been
dedicated to euro vision the way You'
never were your vision was great it
was I mean I I think I took a little I
managed to sneak in a little camera um
and they I spent most of my time just
filming like the behind the scenes stuff
like Ries and the giant cameras on wires
and jibs and stuff and that thing moves
it is a well oiled machine yeah like
watching some of the live streams and
stuff it it's seems insane yeah like the
the the cuz each individual act has its
own crazy number with it its own crazy
you know presentation pyro and right
yeah and you get to see the the you know
the performers walk out uh like fix
their hair and like wave to the audience
before they like you know belt out their
ballad okay and so like that change is
really interesting like watching them
walk out and like okay all right now I'm
on yeah uh yeah that's exciting and
that's you can go to your vision live I
recommend it yeah that that sounds like
a good time Song competition it is okay
sorry dude I just saw this for the first
time in my life last time we in and uh
so it was like me and then a few other
guys were like sitting in the room like
you know it's it's later at night and
like there it's a replay obviously and
I'm watching my mind is blown like the
production that goes into this like oh
yeah yeah okay yeah that it's context
for me like yeah that's like the EUR
Vision Song competition is the most
amazing thing you'll ever see ever yeah
and like each one of these you know
competitors from different countries
coming out and singing these songs
that're just like some are all you know
they're all right
some it's amazing some of it's amazing
but some of those voices you're just
like oh
oh you should have won you made it but
the they're but they're manicured to a
level right when they walk out there
that is I I didn't think was they look
plastic like when they walk out there
there's something about the the pop
machine watching it churn out or or
watching it polish up people and put
them out in front of people like that uh
that I've always found super fascinating
and then seeing that through a lens of
like here's how they do it in this
country here's how they they think they
want to make these people look before
they send them out here and you're like
that's not well all right that works for
you I guess if it's fine for over there
you should watch like tapes of it from
like the '90s do you have video footage
of the people that just sit there and
wave the flags like in every like B-
roll shot their wrist must fall off at
the end of the night like I love Italy
woo no I was in the I was in the
Australian
contingent hey is that the guy that got
up there in Moon somebody this year yes
oh yeah what big old but why cuz it's
Australia man okay fair we showed them
yeah but like that that you know that
kind of image consultant thing or or
that kind of polishing up process like
what is it like kind of finding and
honing a character or or kind of finding
yourself and put and putting yourself
out there in the world of wrestling
because you you hear a lot of stories
about like oh someone came in and and
they got kind of a character kind of
foisted upon them uh I mean Samo Joe you
are still Samoa Joe yeah yeah you win
yeah you made it
through yeah this one managed to make it
through all the checks and balances uh
yeah no uh me it's just uh it's it's an
amped version of how I feel when I wake
up too early in the morning pretty much
yeah and then I obviously like the new
day has gone so far and done so much and
dressed up like every final Fant just
all this other stuff it's a weird thing
yeah you you found this weird amazing
thing that like you look at it and go
like this is what wrestling is now and
it's so cool that like this just gets to
happen
and everyone's [__] into it
everyone's amp yeah get the [__]
trombone let's go it's yeah it's I don't
know I tried to explain like my mom's
friend was like oh uh you know want to
come to one of the wrestling matches she
came and she's like so why do you guys
wear like unicorn horns and why do you
have a trombone it's like honestly I
can't tell you why I don't remember
anymore it's funny to me and so we
started doing it but um I know it took
me uh longer than it took Joe Joe's
Joe's had his personality for a minute
knew his his his deal and it took me a
while to kind of navigate the waters and
find it um consequences yeah went went
through some stuff sure did oh boy we
put him through some stuff too yeah he's
I've known him for a
while but uh it wasn't until I started
just being myself and saying like this
is who I am and throwing my own punches
saying like you know this is what I want
to do tonight and then going out and
doing it and it kind of like worked a
little bit and then no one said anything
as opposed to just going out and doing
what someone else was telling me to do
cuz uh I think whether it's like
wrestling or YouTube or in games like if
you're throwing punches that someone
else is telling you to punch to that
someone else is telling you to throw
like you're going to go down because
you're not using your gut instinct but
if you go down throwing your own punches
you'll be able to look yourself in the
mirror the next day you know what I mean
um so with New Day stuff uh I just knew
I wanted to be me finally rather than
trying to play a character it's like
what am I like I'm a nerd who loves
cosplay in video games so I will find a
way to incorporate that because I'm not
62 I'm not 300 lb uh what skills do I
have I can play Trombone and talk a lot
so let's do that and then it just it it
worked out I was there I was there in
the night when the trom trombone first
showed up was that a magical moment you
were like I I remember I remember I
walked down the hall and I saw him he
had in his hand and we just I just we
looked at each other for about 4 seconds
and I went this where we're at he go
where we're
at
we were just supposed to like we're
going to play a little song and then I
was supposed to hand it to the props guy
at the end of the ramp and then we'll do
the match but like I I with the song I
saw the guy and I was like you know what
I'm never in my life again GNA have a
chance to play Trombone on TV while my
friends wrestle and so I was like no no
no just go ahead and so I just playing
the trumbone through the match for no
reason and the camera guy during the
commercial break goes Vince is loving
this keep going and I was like all right
like okay back in the through the
curtain and Vince was looking at me he's
like this is it every night you stay
with that trombone I was like yes yeah
this is what I needed all those years of
putting my body through this hellacious
training and pain and bumps turns out I
just needed a
trombone Cool Joe we're going to get you
an accordion it's going to change your
life it's I hope so
man I'm I see it man Great Balls of Fire
yeah I'm going to get out there on on an
accordion yeah just play the song
goodness gracious
dang that's probably going to be the
most smoking version of down the
accordion is really meant
for
agreed so uh what's up next for for you
guys are you are you going to E3 at all
or you're done with business so you're
just like going to drink as you do Final
Fantasy 14 documentar is going up yeah
uh in the next couple of days so check
out youtube.com/ noclip video for that
three-parter um and then yeah working on
the next thing which I can't talk about
yet but involves flying to Europe uh and
it's one that is it's the Eurovision
song contest what you can't do
Eurovision well um let's take me with
you apart from that now I'm going to
Universal Studios and getting [__] up
all right that sounds all right yeah
Drew uh what What's Next uh for you
you've got some some more videos to hit
from this Eurovision trip or is that
kind of like you're you're finished with
that and now you're on to the next thing
no I mean I I shot a lot in Ukraine so I
I know how Drew scalin shoots so I know
you you got it brother uh yeah so I'm
I'm I'm you know chipping through um
video after video and I got another one
coming up uh should be this week cool um
from that and um yeah is that was that
youtube.com/ clothmap it is we need to
record an F1 podcast we also need to
record an F1 podcast all right and where
can people find out about your F1
podcast. no more no that's now you get
to own your own F1 podcast yeah yeah
yeah the money maker f1. cool1 f1. cool
yes all right and uh Xavier and Joe you
guys are uh on the show floor doing some
interview business doing a little E3
stuff is there anything you're hoping to
get around and and see while you're
there oh we saw a lot today yeah I want
to see more on this uh what's uh Detroit
yeah yeah V checked out Detroit yeah
dude very heavy rain he said yeah and I
love those kinds of games like uh Beyond
Two Souls like I play through like four
times yeah love it anything super story
driven I'm into so I want to check that
out hopefully see some more stuff on
Spider-Man and see what like exed and
Atlas have going on so mainly a good
General like just kind want to see
everything I I think we going to get in
and check out a little bit of Anthem too
we kind of wild by that yeah um you know
uh the the new Mordor game I think is we
walked by it like 20 million times CU we
were just doing other stuff and we never
like stop every time stop look you're
like okay for is big monster hunter on
the floor uh no they are not like people
play Monster H uh my understanding is
that they'd have like that footage again
if you would like to see it but but
they're not actually showing the game I
on giant bomb.com well it's it's on
giant bomb.com if you want see that foot
and then both of you you know you got
got big events coming up here uh I
believe is it Great Balls of Fire and
then money in the bank uh no money in
the bank's this Sunday okay and then
Great Balls of Fire is what the
following so money in the bank first and
then and then great actually no two two
weeks after yep and I will be uh
destroying Brock Lesnar for for the WWE
Universal Championship I can't I can't
wait to see you do it yeah I would I'm
very exhausted I'm going stomp him out
good
boys and then we can have us back on
he'll be WWE Champion and'll be
Smackdown live tag team champion belts I
got a replica belt I can bring in tough
too it'll be great pretty much the same
thing yeah
titles hold your pants up Bel holds your
pants up okay nothing holds my pants up
these things are too loose well thanks
everyone for coming by Dan from
giantbomb.com uh thanks for being here
as well can I say congrats to Dan yeah
oh couple weeks here right yeah uh yeah
yeah very ex goddamn Taco Bell Taco Bell
marriage that's of all the places you
would get married of course it would be
a goddamn Taco Bell yeah yeah expected
yeah I uh I drove past that Taco Bell
when I was in Las Vegas and fluida was
playing out of it so I was like
okay for a big wrestling fan like Dan of
course is going to be blasted out there
little my house for the family
the sound of sports
entertainment all right thanks you all
for being here we are going to take a
quick break and we'll be back with
another set of guests stay tuned stay
[Laughter]
tuned
[Music]
everybody
hey hey
hey hey he
hey hey hey hey what
hey
hey all the all
the
all the all
[Music]
the
night
find
I me this s
[Music]
go
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
n
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
oh
you
[Music]
yeah
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
Keep Me In
[Music]
hey pretty baby come and save me I got a
conv for you call me crazy it but I
maybe committing a crime of the first
degree I'm not pretending I mean what
I'm saying I'm coming in with My Hands
Held High got to face it I'm not going
to make it without your love and I got
nowhere to go don't you see what you
doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby please don't leave me hanging oh no
no no it's the lock down baby you dve me
crazy think escaping the love has got me
doing time you're my attorney my judge
and jury I'm bleeding guilty so lock me
up
[Music]
key lock me
upy lock me
up
you can't restrain me you can search me
I'll give it all up just to be with you
I'm so happy now you got me I surrender
all my love to you don't you see what
you doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby please don't leave me hang
no this a lock down baby you drive me
crazy over shaping your love has got me
doing time you're my attorney my judge
and jury I'm getting guilty so lock me
up oh yeah I said lock me
[Music]
up lock me up before with key
baby it's lock down baby get drive me
crazy scaming and love is got me doing
time you're my my judge in jury I'm
breing guilty so me up for with
please me you got to take away the keep
my
lock me
up keep me in the
[Music]
lock hey pretty baby come and save me I
got a conf for you call me crazy but I
maybe committing a crime of the first
degree I'm not pretending I mean what
I'm saying I'm coming in with My Hands
Held High got to face it I'm not going
to make it without your love and I got
nowhere to go don't you see what you're
doing to me I'm a loveing and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby please don't leave me hanging oh no
no no lock down baby you dve me crazy
think over scaping your love has got me
throughing time you're my attorney my
judge and jury I'm brething guilty so
lock me
[Music]
up hey I said lock me
up hey hey
lock me
[Music]
up you can't restrain me you can search
me I'll give it all up just to be with
you I'm so happy now you got me I'm I
Surrender on my love to you don't you
see what you're doing to me I'm love
love and I can't break free now I'm
begging with your baby please don't
leave me hanging up no a lock down baby
you dve me you crazy no escaping your
love is got me doing time you're my
turnning my judge and jury I'm getting
guilty so lock me
up
oh oh yeah I said lock me up going key
yeah
lock me up with
[Music]
key baby it's lock down baby can drive
me crazy pcing and love got do time
you're myy my judge and jury I'm
breathing
lock me up with the
key you got to take away the keep my
lock me
up Keep Me
In Me
[Music]
Up
hey pretty baby come and save me I got a
conf for you call me crazy but I maybe
committing a crime of the first degree
I'm not pretending I mean what I'm
saying I'm coming in with my hands held
out got to face it I'm not going to make
it without your love and I got know
where to go don't you see what you're
doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby please don't leave me hanging oh no
no lock down baby you drive me crazy a
over escaping your love has got me doing
time you're my attorney my judge and
jury I'm brething guilty so lock me
up oh me
he I said Lo me
[Music]
up you can't restrain me you can search
me I'll give it all up just to be with
you I'm so happy now you got me I
Surrender all my love to you don't you
see what you doing to me I'm in love and
I can't break free now I'm begging with
your baby please don't leave me hanging
no no it's a lock down baby you drive me
crazy B over escaping your love has got
me doing time you're my attorney my
judge inury I'm feeling guilty so lock
me up G oh oh oh yeah I said lock me up
ke lock me
[Music]
up baby it's a lock down baby can drive
me crazy think over scaping love is
Count doing time you're my attorney my
judge and jury I'm leing guilty Sal me
up
before you got to take away to keep
my me
up
[Music]
in
hey pretty baby come and save me I got
aish for you call me crazy but I maybe
committing a crime of the first degree
I'm not pretending I mean what I'm
seeing I'm coming in with my hands tell
I got to face it I'm not going to make
it without your love and I got nowhere
to go don't you see what you're doing to
me I'm in love and I can't break free
now I'm begging with your baby please
don't leave me hanging oh no lock down
baby you dve me crazy bab scaping your
love has got me throughing time you're
my attorney my judge and
I'm guilty so lock me
[Music]
up I said lock me
upy lock me
up you can't restrain me you can search
me I'll give it all up just to be with
you I'm so happy now you got me I
surrender all my love to you don't you
see what you doing to me I'm in love and
I can't break free now I'm begging with
your baby please don't leave me hanging
no a lock down baby dve me crazy over
shaping your love has got me doing time
you're my eternity my judge inury I'm
getting guilty so lock me
up
oh oh
yeah lock me up
key lock me
[Music]
up W baby it's a lock down baby can
drive me crazy Ain no scaming the love
is got me doing time you're my attorney
my judge in jury I'm brething guilty so
me up for
with you got to take away the keep my Lo
me
up
[Music]
in
hey pretty baby come and save me I got a
conf for you call me crazy but I maybe
committing a crime of the first degree
I'm not pretending I mean what I'm
saying I'm coming in with My Hands Held
High got to face it I'm not going to
make it without your love and I got
nowhere to go don't you see what you
doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby please don't leave me hanging oh no
no lock down baby you dve me crazy big
over shaping the love has got me doing
time you're my attorney my judge and
jury I'm brething guilty lock me
[Music]
up I lock me
up lock me
[Music]
up
you can't restrain me you can search me
I'll give it all up just to be with you
I'm so happy now you got me I'm a
surrender all my love to you don't you
see what you doing to me I'm in love and
I can't break free now I'm begging with
your baby please don't leave me hanging
no no this a lock down baby get dve me
crazy shaping your love has got me doing
time you're my eternity my judge and
jury I'm guilty so lock me up ke
oh oh yeah said lock me
up lock me
[Music]
up
oh baby it's lot down baby you drive me
crazy aing I love is Count do time your
my my judge and jury I'm breing guilty
so me up
fore me you got to take with the keep
my
up
Keep Me
In
[Music]
Me hey pretty baby come and save me I
got aish for you
call me crazy but I maybe committing a
crime of the first degree I'm not prend
it I mean what I'm saying I'm coming in
with My Hands Held High got to face it
I'm not going to make it without your
love and I got nowhere to go don't you
see what you're doing to me I'm in love
and I can't break free now I'm begging
with your baby please don't leave me
hanging oh no no no the lock down baby
you dve me crazy think over shaping the
love has got me doing time you're my
attorney my judge and jury I'm bleeding
guilty so lock me
[Music]
upy me
upy
hey what's up everybody it's Jeff
gersman we're back here with
giantbomb.com continuing coverage of e3
2017 day two is in the books night two
we're in the middle of it so let's get
right down to it we've got some more
guests here joining us from Oddworld
inhabitants we've got Lauren Lanning how
how you doing sir I'm doing great Jeff
thanks for having me back on great to
see you and Tim Willet of VI software
welcome yes thank you thank you yeah
awesome uh so it's been uh a crazy
couple of years for it I mean you got
Quake Champions coming out here I guess
what's the is is it in more of an open
Beta now or is it still kind of a closed
thing uh yeah I mean we're we're still
in beta uh but you just go to quake.
comom hit the little give me a key and
you can start playing okay you'll
definitely get a key it's not like a
waves thing it's okay yeah yeah we we we
keep it in so we can you know reset
stats we need to and scale rankings and
we can keep adding things without people
getting all upset but anyone can go on
even you Lauren yes we can all play
Quake Champions it's true I'm an
obnoxious reviewer that's why I never do
it well yeah no it's you have to be a
certain brand of what's the word [__]
that's what I am that's how I get I just
don't want everyone to know that's what
I okay fair enough uh Quake Champions is
uh in some ways a lot like the games of
ID's past in some ways very different
you know the the structure of uh you
know this uh class system and and all
this sort of stuff yeah I mean you know
I don't like to use the word class okay
champ Champion yeah at its heart it's
still pure Quake you know and since I've
made all the Quakes I know Quake heart
that's right you would know I would know
and uh uh it is it is true to to to what
the franchise is yeah and it's uh it's
been interesting playing it kind of
around some of these waves through
through the waves of of betas and and
seeing it kind of take shape uh with
kind of the different passive abilities
and active abilities uh was it
challenging bringing that stuff to
something like I think a lot of people
think about quake as a very pure thing
this is another layer when we when we
announced the game and we said there
would be champions in it with abilities
people freaked out they're like oh my
God you're ruining my Quake uh but um uh
but you know now that people have been
playing it that's that's gone and
because people can see that it it really
does not change the way you play the
game I mean it's still very skill-based
still the classic Arena shooter uh but
the Champions they just their abilities
and their passive abilities they add a
lot of depth like today we had some of
the best Quake players in the world
playing the game at Big ESL booth and uh
you saw a lot of strategy a lot of death
that you don't you would not normally
get in Quake game sure yeah I'm just you
know from picking the different
Champions and cuz it's a different
starting stats and stuff like that too
right yeah yeah you have speed and you
have you know health and armor and stuff
yeah does it do you think of it in terms
of uh team composition mattering you
know people think about something like
OverWatch uh as being like this very you
know like oh you got to put your crew
together just right uh is Quake
Champions do you see it the same way uh
yeah yeah like today we saw with the pro
teams you know really try the guys uh
picking Champions that fit with with
their team you know you one fast guy one
tanker um and um uh yeah yeah you saw
that Dynamic cool cool so there is no
one formula which is really nice that
there this hasn't happened but there
isn't just one formula these guys yes
yes yes thank God that hasn't happened
so that means we've done something well
and we we've we've balanced it correctly
cool Lauren how have things been going
man it's like it's another year you're
back here with us we've we've talked
about everything from VR to AR and back
again we but uh What uh what brings you
to the show this year you can you're
showing stuff behind stuff behind closed
doors sneaking the thing around going
like hey we got this thing yeah we're
not not necessarily making fam happy
with that but um but you know you get
out there too early and then they
slaughter you for this reason or that so
we're just delaying the slaughter you
know but we know it's coming yeah uh and
and how's that been going is it's been
going actually pretty great it's like
hunting for a publisher kind of meetings
or you're like looking no we we we
bypass that world but we are looking for
for a partner for physical distribution
cuz we want to get a disc out this time
even though we're self-published uh but
you know I think that'll go well I think
we got something fairly special but talk
is cheap you know so it needs to be
great and um uh you know it's it I try
to see a lot of things in the show so
show is so busy this year you can't see
anything right body odor factor is high
it's really high not as bad as Gamescom
it's not as bad as
Gamescom but it's high you know for La
it's unusually high the Uber drivers are
talking about it yeah no well today was
definitely probably I think the the
warmest day of the week too so I'm sure
that really helped so we've been you
know it's it's a it's a it's a weird
balance today because I mean you're
right on the crust right you got beta
out there and but uh the the
announcement time to to release time has
to be shorter because people have a
shorter attention span really right so
if you're a year out don't start talking
about too much yet so we do things to
engage the qu audience but we have
haven't been doing things to really
launch outward yet and that's coming and
I think we got you know a lot of bullets
in the belt that people aren't expecting
hopefully we'll see and then they'll
shoot us down to humbling size in no
time I'm sure well you know but at least
at least it will happen in a short
window from announc release instead of
stretching the murder out over three
yeah yeah so it's nicer it's a more
condensed post-traumatic stress error
yeah that's F and we'll we'll we'll take
that yeah and and I guess you know with
with the way Doom was announced and and
shown and shown again and stuff like
that it's definitely seemed like it gave
people a whole lot of time to come up
with a lot of things to say about Doom
yes yes yes keep it small like like
Wolfenstein 2 The New
Colossus you know we we announced it
this week and it comes out this year and
yes keep it short keep it short keep
Bethesda has gone into short focused hit
them hard nothing without six months if
it's not in six months you don't hear
about it from be and and the surprise
there is that you don't know who's going
to emerge as competition in your release
window because everyone's holding back
longer well now yeah it's well now it's
uh Wolfenstein Assassin's Creed and
Mario all on the same day that's that's
that's what we end up I I believe all
three of them are it's 1027 right and
you're like what what are they doing
like we we released the original game
back in 978 Odyssey and then final F
Fantasy 7 a week later right so our
sales are like Yay no you know like how
do you deal with that you know you don't
so you cover unless you're like going to
be nimble enough to just move stuff
around and and try to play that game but
that doesn't yeah but you know it's
funny I divert for a second because you
got into gaming because you were a big
Doom fan right that was that was your
history right so check this out I don't
know if you know the story so I was in
visual effects at the time when Doom
came out and doom someone someone
created a uh a mod that ran on Unix mhm
and then all the I was in visual effects
and film at the time in Los Angeles and
everyone who was in film was running on
Unix workstations but at the time they
were like $880,000 a pie
right so no no consum but someone made a
doom mod so now ilm Pixar Rhythm and
Hughes all everyone's playing Doom I
mean totally addicted yeah right like
totally addicted so work is grinding to
a halt right and this was one of the
things that convinced me that I need to
get into games so here these guys are
working on like Academy award-winning
movies and they're deciding not to work
on them to just play Doom and ATM and at
Pixar they started saying if we catch
you playing Doom damn it you're you're
fired that's funny and people got fired
cuz they couldn't stop is all you had to
hear was oh someone's in there and
they're still fighting they're kicking
your ass you know once you hear one
person doing it you're like yeah but to
see that phenomena right to see what
could happen from a modded thing that
was on land networks and we're doing
this and no one had it before and you
can you had the impression of 3D in this
yes it was it was a factor that drove me
towards games because I saw that even
the visual effects guys couldn't help
themselves you know they were risking
their job to continue playing I mean you
know I think I may have told the story
before but you know I have a similar
story with Wolfenstein when when wolf 3D
came out it was I was uh I was kind of
loosely going to company you know I was
kind of getting into this line of work
you know I was still in high school and
uh and we were going to see uh it was a
VR company because you know they like
kind of virtuality dactyl nightmare era
of VR yeah and um three frame three
frames per second VR but oh those
frames and we were seeing a company uh
somewhere in s Francisco that had a tank
game in VR and there were it was you
know and I was 16 17 years old so like
that was like the coolest [__] I had
ever seen uh and so you know they're
putting us in this cockpit we're putting
on this headset and going like well the
frame you know like this is probably the
most amazing thing ever it was before
you knew with the bad frame rates were
bad frame rates and played that for a
while and you know we're hanging out
chatting and a guy walks up and goes to
one of the other the guy we're talking
to with the company goes hey have you
seen this Wolfenstein thing that just
came out and like what is this and and
walks over there goes you need to check
this [__] out you need to come over and
look at this and these guys that are
working on just the most advanced future
Tech of the era and us who are just you
know are like hovering around this
computer looking at Wolfenstein 3D for
the first I'm just like oh my [__]
god well gaming has been the tip of
Technology it's been you know it's it's
it's always driven you know the huge
Hardware you know push I mean it'll it's
pushing VR VR will eventually there will
be something so something you know like
some app but it was gaming that pushed
it right of course yeah uh do you ever
see well I guess like now uh Doom is
coming to VR what is what is that all
about it looked like a very different
experience than Doom I'm glad you
pointing yes that is that is good to
note uh yes you you are not the Doom
Marine you are a different character but
you're in that Universe um you're in
that setting and um you really it's a
complete experience uh but it is
engineered differently because it is VR
I mean if you played Doom in VR you
would probably throw up yeah but it's
it's a little bit different but but it's
awesome though do do you think that you
know I guess like it depends on how the
tech develops but do you have in the
back of your mind you're just like this
is the like there's the VR game that you
wish that you could make if people just
wouldn't get sick or you know I think
about like Doom I think about Quake you
know there's just something about this
idea of just like what if we were just
rocket jumping yes yes the people have
asked us oh you should you should do
Quake champ and VR it's like that' be
crazy but spectating mode spectating
would be awesome you can sit there and
you can watch those guys go back and
forth at your pace yes at your pace uh
so yeah I mean we we I still think I
mean vr's awesome we we still have a
ways to go we have to lose the cord the
cord is killing VR yeah yes I was saying
earlier like i' I've developed a skill
to step over the cord but it's a weird
you shouldn't have to develop the skill
to step over the course yes and and if I
if I had the the VR headset on and my
wife came home some night and she caught
me with this thing going the night would
not be what I would plan so it's still
there's still a whole bunch of weirdness
going on that we need to get over yeah
especially depending on what you were
watching that's true yeah yeah yes for
sure uh and that's that's kind of the
thing I I think for for me with VR in a
lot of cases the thing I've come to
realize uh I got married about a year
ago and so that you know that changed a
lot of things about how I'm living my
life and porn PornHub is not getting
nearly enough Vlog hours anymore
uh and so VR became very different at
that point because now it's like okay
well you know when I put this on I have
to go all the way away and it's not just
conversations with my wife it's Twitter
on my phone it's whatever I got going on
my second PC monitor whatever I got you
know I've got four screens in the room
I'm in it's information overload but
that's just how I've come to take in the
world and this is a problem and VR shuts
it all off in a way that sometimes even
VR is not enough it's like no I need I
need more so in an increasingly social
World VR is very antisocial weirdly
enough right yeah and it's and it's a
prohibiting Factor like like I would
have expected it to take off faster I
mean we can say you know Sony's
outselling units gear is outselling
units um also say like the tech is
incredibly impressive you know like some
really neat amazing stuff but you're
isolating yourself away and it's not
safe right cuz we got all kinds of
things coming with uh all the back the
blowback of VR right the kid who's mad
at his older brother so now he's sticks
sharp object in the room while the
brother's in VR that's coming it'll be
on YouTube soon I assure you right the
kid on the gear on the subway and he's
getting pick bucketed and everyone
that's funny right that's that has to
have happened by now statistically K the
kid who gets in the car after 6 hours of
playing VR and then gets in a car
accident and kills the family that's
coming too right the neural growth
changes that happen because you're in VR
that's coming too because it's real
right so imagine for in the first time
in human evolution your experience ing a
completely alternative reality except
your motor skills have not been turned
off right we dream we run we do all
these things but our body stay still
mostly right unless you have dream ISS
unless you have sleeping issues right uh
or various types of you know
neurological problems but for the first
time you're not disconnected so it
inevitably is going to change a neural
pathway growth you know we don't know
what that means right but inevitably
it's going to happen because your
experiential uh experien is now
dislocated in a way that for millions of
years never have before so there's all
kinds of these these factors that are
going to weigh in YouTube is going to
document a lot of it whereas before we
didn't have it right right and uh it's
going to be really interesting and um my
personal bet is that uh AR if AR takes
off sooner then it's over right right
yeah because because AR can be mobile
and social meaning meaning everything
else in my life can stay engaged but now
I can start engaging alter of reality
laid on top of my reality but if I have
to dislocate from reality then it's a
very disengaging experience for anyone
else in the household right and parents
are already pissed off enough that they
see the kids on a on a PlayStation long
enough suddenly they're watching kids
going like later you know now they're
really gone right yeah well you know and
I think you know that's again I think I
think you know as that Tech develops
like of course AR makes the most sense
cuz even in cases where you need VR you
can just black out the glasses and you
know make it traditional traditional
tradition traditional VR yeah uh and and
probably get the best of both out of
that stuff yeah but you know what you've
seen this 20 years these Trends remember
and this is you know yeah for sure yes
we'll we'll see how it really kind of
shakes up I look at it and think like
you know like the thing that changed for
me is like I'm a an extreme believer in
the technology I look at it and go like
it works you know in in a way that like
uh you know it didn't work in the 90s
that's right thanks does yeah and
screwed that pay to the order of right
um that that that Tech is too impressive
to I when it's well yeah it's pretty
mindblowing yeah right uh even when it's
done poorly it's still kind of
mindblowing uh but the thing I found is
that I'm just spending way less time
doing it because the software hasn't
gotten better fast enough in a lot of
cases or it's just or that kind of
antisocial aspect of it yeah yeah and we
and we still have the uh you know the
install base isn't there so that the
funding is really going for the real AAA
level stuff we see a couple indicators
of it we see some amazing demos uh you
know we see some valid games that are
valid experiences uh but if the install
base isn't there who's really going to
fund that content that's reaching the
levels of the AAA that we normal
consoles it's still expensive to make
games exactly yeah it doesn't get
cheaper to make Gam because it needs to
run at 120 frames per second in Stereo
it's cheaper for th people right of
course yeah exactly so at ID it must be
what like well I what's it like having
these ID properties the classic ID
properties still not not only around but
like very much in Vogue and relevant and
you know we're talking about Doom we're
talking about Wolfenstein we're talking
about Quake where's Commander Keane what
are we
doing I haven't drank enough tonight all
right to let
all right um we have some people back
there laughing um but uh yes it is we
are truly blessed that uh um you know
because all the games have that spirit
and you know we've done lots of things
different throughout the years but we
maintain the spirit and uh um it was it
was very evident with doom it had that
classic Doom Spirit but there's lots of
modern things that were put on top of it
Champions same way you know feels like
the game you played 20 years ago but
it's new you know Wolfenstein has tapped
into that emotion that has always been
in in the franchise uh so really we
maintained the spirit of the titles
that's key yeah that's something that I
just you know I I think when when Doom
got announced even having seen
Wolfenstein you know kind of come and go
over the years and become popular and
kind of Fade Out and you know it was
very hard to believe as
a big fan of Doom and Doom 2 like they
bring back Doom I just don't see in a
Call of Duty war world what does Doom
even mean man Doom could be awesome and
and it turns out right I was talking to
dino D lenes yeah who produced the movie
right and he asked me why do you think
it didn't go so well the movie yeah Oh I
thought the movie is great it had a
character named after
me I have one rule if there's a
character named after me it's an awesome
movie so is that is that the is that the
one awesome movie that is the one
awesome movie okay sorry sorry go ahead
that deserves five stars right on the
phone we're going to get another he
was and I was like you got an awesome
property but you cared too much what the
gamers think sure right yeah like how
often do you listen to a movie audience
about how would you shape your script
yeah no never no the audience doesn't
want a script that they wrote they want
a great movie right and and here's the
thing about Gamers I'm just like
probably going to get shot for this but
it wouldn't be the first time so you got
a great property do them and I'm looking
at it I'm like this is Hell opens up on
Mark man let's go back to Babylon and
let's like trace the roots let's get
into the ancient history let's get into
the black magic of all this let's get
into the goetic this and that right uh
and and you could really get into deep
stuff and and he had asked me this you
know it was right when it released and I
was like you cared what the gamers think
man of course gamers are going to give
you their opinion that's what Gamers do
right go on the net they they pay some
of them to do it it's weird yeah it's
brutal right but you
listened right here's what they really
cared about after all all the [__] that
they're talking what they really cared
about give us a great movie on a
property we loved now you're the one who
makes movie why did you listen to game
that the gamers on how you should make
the script sure right yeah because if
you delivered a great great movie and I
think the content is there cuz I'm I'm
like a doom fan from way back Quake is a
different story because every time I log
in these little pricks shoot me every
[__] time that'd be a different very
different movie feel old play BL qu mov
yeah I log in bang I'm dead again and
again and again it's your fault to yeah
I think that's but like that's probably
what happened with Resident Evil movies
right is because they've they're on a
ter I mean they're going to reboot them
as soon as they're done making you know
they made the last I yeah yeah but you
know those movies don't actually have
that much direct ties to the games long
and they they work the most successful
game franchise dur movies right uh and
you know beautiful starlets help oh well
for sure yeah no I mean you could have
got someone like like that to be fair I
think the rock was in The Rock The Rock
was in do he's a beautiful star yeah
yeah of course I mean you know and he's
very nice oh nicer than he needed to be
I bet yes yes yes he's really nicer than
he needs to be yeah he's good guy that's
awesome so with uh with Quake Champions
like what's it been like kind of
returning to Quake I feel like with with
doom there was that essence of just like
okay let's distill this thing down to
the essence but modernize all around but
like with quake it's multiplayer so
there's still a lot of like people have
those expectations about this and that
and this Fe this that's the thing so
it's it's a quake game so it uh the
greatest thing about it is that it's a
quake game the thing that works against
it is it's a quake game because there
are people that love Quake one Quake two
Quake three Quake four and they all have
something different in them so when
Champions came out people would be like
I don't like the speed of the rocket
launcher I don't like air control I
don't like this make it like Quake four
make it like Quake three make it like
Quake two so there's that uh but I think
we we've kind of balanced it out which
which which with the Champions it's
helped cuz we have some Champions I feel
like quick World some Champions feel it
Quake three some so that has helped but
um and the Cosmetics so you can unlock
proper rocket launcher skin yes and and
today one of the uh one of the pro
players from Team Liquid played with the
Quake one uh you know rocket launcher
and the Quake 2 Lightning gun and stuff
so that was cool um but uh but yeah that
is that has been a challenge M to get
everyone's ideas of Quake because people
have these memories of Quake I was in
college and I played Quake for the first
time I my me and my dad used to play
Quake together so they take these
memories of and they project them onto
what they're playing and if it doesn't
match that memory then they're like you
ruined Quake for me of course you know
so it's it's it's been fun I could say
that you know it's been a bit a bit of a
challenge but because it has yes there's
been that yeah yeah that's uh yeah I I
imagine I mean you know if anything
that's that's got to be again that
blessing of the C how how willing are
you to step beyond that expectation and
take the risks uh well we had a
Champions yeah clear yes it was um I
mean plus I we've done this long enough
to know that if you make a game that you
love there's a good chance that other
people will make it too right right yes
and how much but but I mean this like a
legitimate question question today right
so we're more and more shaped because we
do have rapid user feedback right but
then we tend to hear the most vocal the
most right right and then that can
really tilt yes tilt uh not necessarily
in the best place that everyone else is
going to like the game because the
loudest voices tend to be you know rise
rise to the noisiest level uh and I
think
that's you you said it which is build a
great game that we love and so you go
you Quake oh you killed Quake for me cuz
it's not like Quake four well that was
[__] Quake 4 yes right we gave you
that game we didn't ruin Quake four
we're evolving we're evolving the
franchise right and if you can take that
into that next realm but it's but it's
like you know you're going to suffer
some backlash you know you're going to
do it but you got to because the people
that love it are pling right the people
that don't love it are like I don't love
it right s
right yeah exactly yeah absolutely I
mean that's the I went back and forth
cuz I you know I still have like quck
live and
and and still play a fair amount of that
and I'm terrible at it now as it turns
out but that's okay I still enjoy myself
and and so it's been interesting
seeing you know kind of Quake live as
kind of this continuation of of the
Quake 3 Legacy and then getting into
that quick Champions uh bait and going
like oh this is they've made some
changes okay all right but it still has
the basic feel and then over the course
of you know week to week as it's been
shaped kind of seeing and going like
this is a good yes great looking Arena
shooter so in our production in in our
path the first Milestone was make it
feel like Quake so you know we just got
it in as fast you know got got
everything working got some outside
people to come in play it does it feel
like Quake uh yes okay good then we're
done with that then we started to focus
on the other so wa you started all over
on Tech yeah yeah yeah yeah you you
didn't evolve existing mechanics started
this is ID we like we start over all the
time it's ridiculous
you know I mean Heck if we made Doom 3
with Quake 3 Tech been done in a year
yeah right yeah yes new deck yeah and
yeah I mean that eyeball looks really
good so when it turns out when you start
over with new stuff and you get the yeah
you get I mean we're going to be better
we we have a good production pipeline
now that lets us be more it you know
itate on it and and how do you find the
right level of content for something
like this when it comes to like choosing
like hey how many champions we going to
put in this thing or like how many Maps
you going to launch with not I'm like
going like how many Maps you going to
launch with but how do you determine as
much as we get done by the time sure all
right yeah how did you measure that you
measure that in terms of you know it's a
poundage ratio yeah yeah 40 go hours to
play hours how are you figuring that out
Pur live you know I mean we uh you know
we we have some stats on what people
play and how long they play and uh and
Quake playing Quake Champions or any
Quake game is can be physically
draining so we know that most people
really only spend about 30 minutes a day
playing yes they most people can't
really handle more than that you know
the hardcore people play all day long
yeah but uh you know so you take your
average kind of put people in the the
the pool you draw a curve you kind of
figure this is what we need to make you
know so there's more math behind it
originally we just made stuff you know
like like people like the quad damage is
the greatest thing ever we just made
that up we put more Satan in this whole
ship it just work extra Satan go there's
like there's you know this map that I
made 15 years ago someone someone just
today said it was so genius that you you
did not place a rail gun in that map and
I was like that's cuz I forgot I forgot
that's that's true genius man that's you
know so we were just throwing stuff
against the wall now we're a little more
scientific and stuff that we make but do
you worry that the science sometimes
ruin I mean you talk about feedback and
knowing when to listen but you ever
either of you ever get worried that the
science is going to ruin it I know like
we're pretty lame on science yeah for us
like we've access to all kinds of
numbers and stats and time spent and
engagement and all this stuff and I'm
just like when when when you have uh you
know tournament play when you have Arena
play I think you know you're you're
tracking analytic Behavior at a much
tighter level you know when you have the
type of experiences that we've been
building you know historically which is
you know more into the category of
single player you know story is action
adventure game uh you're going a lot
more with your gut you could probably be
more scientific we just said like where
did they yell loudest what they like the
most you know when were the death
threats and we can measure that get a
better idea of like what we should do
what we shouldn't do would you ever even
want more data out of that I know like
something like like Mass Effect you can
you can opt in to like send them a lot
of data about how you played all stuff
we're totally welcoming that data you
know how much we process is another
story you know but uh uh and there's a
part of it where um you know what
personally as a designer I tend to think
more like a film director which is not
necessarily a smart thing to say on this
show but uh I tend to think that way so
I tend to think if we have some ideas
that can blaz some new territory that
can make it exciting we should take some
chances on it yeah and uh and It's
tricky because if we talk about it early
then there's all kinds of potential
blowback uh you promised this and it
wasn't in the game it's like so I've
just learned just shut the [__] up you
know until we're there and we really
have the goods and then we can tease at
it in certain abstract ways yeah uh but
if we start getting specific it's you
almost can't win you know so you might
excite people but you're going to be
disappointing someone else at the same
time right and and you're just turning
them into like all of a sudden now
they're like well now I want it now yeah
like well that's not that was never the
and part of it we we pursue our own gut
with it like this is where it should go
this is where we feel it should go based
on our experience with an IP that we've
been living with for 20 years right it's
like here goes the hair but uh and in
that
uh you really have to be able to afford
uh an element of the creative process
where you can sort of fail fail faster
right how how much is that get imp pass
like no it's a great idea man I'm going
to make it happen we're like let's
figure out if it's a good idea fast so
we can kill it quick if it sucks but if
it's great you know we'll expand on it
and uh through that process we learn a
lot um but in our type of game we're not
getting the same type of feedback I mean
we're we're we're heading towards live
there'll be some surprises on that I
think uh coming soon but without
spilling the beans cuz he's going to
kill me but
uh yeah I'm not Kidd and
uh so a lot of it is like gut you know
if you go back to film making right
right The Gamers know what they want to
a large degree but they want to be
surprised right and so you got to
deliver that surprise filmmakers have to
think different they need to always
surprise you know unless you unless
you're Michael Bay and you know who your
15-year-old male audience is just make
more surprised these things blew up good
yeah blow them up bigger yeah and
uh it reminds me of so many things but
uh so a lot of it is that gut and you're
trying to balance that with some
semblances of Science and I but I think
if you do that too much then we're in a
landscape that we largely see today
which is Big Brands uh derivative uh
product that um they're they're
measuring I mean huge financial GR right
so I don't ding anyone for being
cautious on huge Financial Risk but so
then you got to measure more succinctly
are we delivering what they want and how
much can we you know is it 90% what they
want 10% surprise is that the right
ratio and all of that's a risk but when
you're in a Big Brand like if you built
gr uh Grand tourismo whatever the latest
number right and you don't do an
outstanding 10 out of 10 job you suck
because you have so much data of knowing
what they want of knowing where you
could go of knowing what should be added
but if you're in like an abstract world
you're in alternative universes people
are looking at you to develop that in
ways that are going to be compelling to
them right and if they were going to
write the script they're not that
interested in you anymore yeah so
there's a and I think there's a lot of
risk with that and you have to trust the
creative process and that's a that's a
whole another you know sort of uh can of
schizophrenia totally I think that's I
mean that's why uh I think Wolfenstein
ended up being like one of if not the
standout of the show for me because you
look at that and you know I think back
to what Wolfenstein has been but also I
think about you know even just the the
first Wolfenstein game in this in this
chain for machine games and seeing that
trailer you're like they did some crazy
stuff those machine game guys are crazy
they went out there in like a good way
yeah but even something they pitched so
like a while back they they came and
they they pitched the story to me and uh
they said there's there's something in
that's kind of like really out there and
just so they started going and they
would get to something i' be like oh is
that it they're like oh no no that's not
it
and they would go on and it's explain is
that it is that the crazy thing they're
like no and they're like this is I'm
like holy cow so those guys have just
gone I mean it's awesome yeah it's it's
been great to see just because of of how
strong just that to be play more crazy
than you even know yeah no that's uh
crazy that's very exciting uh to hear uh
cuz yeah we had Yen on last night and
talked him for a while insane isn't he
awesome he's like the best guy ever and
I just think back to for me it was just
like the lineage from uh back in kind of
the star bre days for stuff like Ric and
stuff like that and what they've what
teams like that have done for first
person games yes and and the way you see
that in Wolfenstein uh and you see this
kind of like old concept of Wolfenstein
merged with that kind of style and it
just yes machine game guys like in in
the beginning they'd be like hey can we
get your opinion on something like no
you're good just you're good go yeah you
don't need my opinion make awesome yeah
awesome well uh I think we're going to
let you guys go quake so anyone can go
to quake. comom sign right now if you
can click a button you can play the game
all right I uh well I'm already in the
game so I was going to say I'll use my
clicking fingers but what's your what's
your uh what's your game uh monster dunk
I've moner dun not played look me up
probably terrible monster dunk probably
terrible terrible and Lauren uh so you
know you can follow we're running ARG on
what's coming so we're we're slowly
tricking it out and it's uh it's
depressing how fast the audience crowd
Solutions yeah uh that's always eye
opening but you know Oddworld OD r on
Facebook Facebook yeah soul storm is the
new game is coming we we should be out
uh well I can't say CU they'll kill me
we should be out someday I guess someday
not too too distant future all right I
guess those announcements will come soon
all right well thank you both for coming
through thanks for having us awesome and
uh we will take another break and we'll
be back with some more guests in the
very near future stay
tuned
who's
that
[Music]
w
that
who's
[Applause]
[Music]
that
[Applause]
[Music]
a
down
[Music]
n
what
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that's
[Music]
a
e
[Music]
b b a b a b b b a a b a a
b
[Music]
B
[Applause]
[Music]
w
spe
[Music]
[Applause]
woo
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
w
are you sure hey hey hey I got
[Music]
home
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
barue everybody CH for the body body
[Music]
hey
lock me
[Music]
up lock me
up you can't restrain me you can search
me I'll give it all up just to be with
you you I'm so happy now you got me I'm
a surrender all my love to you don't you
see what you doing to me I'm in love and
I can't break free now I'm begging with
your baby please don't leave me hanging
no no this lock down baby you drive me
crazy was King your love has got me
doing time you're my attorney my judge
and jury I'm feeling guilty so lock me
up for with ke
oh oh yeah I said lock me up
key lock me
[Music]
up bab it's a lock down baby you drive
me
crazy scaming the love is got do time
you're my turnning my judge in jury I'm
breathing guilty so me up
for me you got to take away to keep my
Lo me
up keep
[Music]
me
hey pretty baby come and save me I got
aish for you call me crazy but I maybe
committing a crime of the first degree
I'm not pretending I mean what I'm
saying I'm coming in with My Hands Held
High got to face it I'm not going to
make it without your love and I got
nowhere to go don't you see what you're
doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby please don't leave me hanging off
the Flor lock down baby you drive me
crazy B was shaping the love has got me
throughing time you're my attorney my
judge and jury I'm beding guilty so lock
me
[Music]
up I lock me
up lock me
up you can't restrain me you can search
me I'll give it all up just to be with
you I'm so happy now you got me I
surrender all my love to you don't you
see what you doing to me I'm in love and
I can't break free now I'm begging with
your baby please don't leave me hanging
up no lock down baby drive me crazy
was Shing your love has got me doing
time you're my attorney my judge and
jury I'm feeling guilty lock me up
and
oh oh yeah I said lock me up and with
key lock me up with
[Music]
key
we're back and we're under the bright
lights of the internet I'm Jeff gersman
welcome back to Giant pom.com coverage
of e327 we've got another Cavalcade of
stars here tonight starting with down on
the end there we got Ramy is Ramy vamer
down there Ramy vamer my last name yeah
I picture like if you were if you were
to just start going by Ramy vamer and
just wear like a leisure suit or
something like that Ramy flamb beer yeah
I'm Ramy flamb beer what's going on wait
but then if I get married is it then
also Adriel flamb beer is that how that
works I I think yeah I mean I don't
think she's happy with I think she would
get to choose that it's not going to
work it could be like a hyph
adri wall vber
yeah that's and then she technically
owns some part of the I forget how it
works you know what let's just not do
that okay all right we got uh Brendan
green uh from I guess is it blue note
technically Blue Hole sorry blue note
yeah uh of player unknown Fame yes I
suppose game uh yeah yeah and welcome
thank you thanks for coming and we've
got Dave cracker from Spike Chun soft uh
well technically it's uh crer but it's
it's a very good Icebreaker all right
I'll let you keep it thank you Dave crer
for coming three out of three man yeah
noce pow he's a professional yeah that's
what I do around here it's just just set
people set him up I knock him down is
that how that works we got Alex and Dan
in the back hello hello how's it going
back there great that's nice the lights
aren't quite as bright back here yeah so
independent game development you guys
are all doing it in some form or or
another uh Ramy uh you uh have shipped a
lot of games on consoles and what I just
want to know what you do you think of
the press conferences this year because
it seems like they've waxed and waned
when it comes to showing personally
thought Sony was well in terms of
independent games there was n us like
there's nothing to complain about
because they had nothing so it's hard to
complain there just nothing to talk
about fair enough I thought it was
rather I thought like they had cool
stuff and the first party stuff looks
amazing but it's also all looks to be
like 2018 stuff and it seemed kind of
flat I like Microsoft had like good ups
and downs had a bit of a flow to it like
it was nice having Phil just on stage
all the time because you know light goes
on it's Phil Spencer you know Phil
Spencer Phil Spencer is going to tell
you that there's stof flops and that's
great yeah and then uh I thought the
Nintendo Direct thing was done pretty
well I hate when they do that thing
where they're like you want you want
some news Nintendo's making a Pokemon
game had you thought about that wait a
minute Nintendo's gonna hang on
Nintendo's not making a Pokemon game
true story true story and I kind of
hated that but I thought the rest of
their show was pretty good so it's it's
kind of a it feels like a very like
transitional year E3 kind of like things
are changing around the industry and we
just don't know where they're going at
the moment so right going to be a wait
to see year I guess yeah and and Brendan
you got to head out on out there and
yeah talk about bringing Battlegrounds
uh to console yeah I know that was
nerve-wracking yeah was it a lot of
rehearsals was it like multiple days
four days like I've been here since last
Wednesday okay did four days rehearsals
and everything was planned to a tea but
it was great like with the other
speakers backstage kind of like cheering
each other as we're going out and then
you come back in it's like yeah you did
it no mistakes yeah it's like did the
script change at all or is it one of
like are people like going know we I had
like a script I was meant to read but
then like changed a lot of it and I came
in the first rehearsal and just said
that and everyone was like that's not
the script like have you changed the
script why why are you reading that uh
so and then we just hammered it down but
then on the last night I just had a
sense of relief on stage and just said
it it worked awesome and and and
bringing and bringing Battlegrounds to
to Xbox Xbox one uh
and then I guess like the game had
already kind of been announced or you
said like Hey we're going to bring it to
consoles yeah we were working on Console
not working but looking into seeing how
we could get it to work on console and
because we use Onre it's it's quite easy
to pour things across so we have a
Spanish team um I like whenever somebody
in the industry says quite easy because
you know there's just like 100
developers like smashing their face into
a keyboard for just unreal you just push
the button here director loves me he
thinks I'm a great guy because I just go
oh can we do this
yes yeah yeah pretty much yeah but hey
awesome and and uh Dave you're with
Spike chunsoft uh yes we actually don't
have a US presence really so we're not
presenting at the show uh we're just
kind of writing in the coat tales and
you know everybody who's anybody's in
town right now so it's just kind of nice
to come out and you know get FaceTime
with people that we never get to you
know communicate with yeah so is it a
lot of uh just kind of setting up a lot
of meetings just kind of like looking
for new business or is it kind of like
getting out here and talking up fire pro
wrestling world or oh uh you said the
magic
word yeah that's uh well yeah yeah man
that's uh it's it's kind of cool that
firepro is coming back and and coming to
PC right that's the yes yeah I mean I
think it's the perfect platform for it
uh the biggest hurdle with firepro is
that it's like the greatest wrestling
simulation that nobody's heard of so
every time I've have tried to play it
like I've I've yet to have my true
firepro moment because every time I've
purchased a fire Pro game turns out I
don't understand any Japanese at all so
trying to wrap your mind around the
systems of that game and even just
navigating the menus to go like I want
to make my character and do this or you
know edit these moves and this sort of
stuff uh I'm too stupid to do that well
so it's been exciting to you know see
this would be coming out in English
again right yeah yeah yeah um actually
I'll I'm the defacto localization
producer on it because we wanted to save
money we could uh spend in other
places enough yeah I'm our social media
manager
sometimes that seems to be it's you know
it's it's beyond many hats it's just
like what needs to get done today right
Prett much right IND the life right
there right yeah and I you're off
updating uh Ridiculous Fishing for 64 B
that was a fun iPhone that was a fun
surprise like apple said Hey listen
we're going to update our o Os from
32bit to 64bit and on September 1st your
32-bit apps will stop working but in the
meanwhile will destroy everybody's
experience with your game so that they
will email you
continuously until you just can't see a
single single email email anymore about
64 bit and then 3 weeks ago they just
pulled it from the search like any
32-bit app is now long and no warnings
no so it was just like I woke up and
it's like you can't buy your game
anymore that's was a fun fun way to wake
up and that's when you as an indie you
just go like well I guess this is my hat
today like right yeah just updating
let's see how horrible xcode is nowadays
and then you just kind to cry and you
just load it in and push the xort
64 it's done we also we also added tilt
controls to the Xbox two clicks and now
you can just tilt your Xbox and
Ridiculous Fishing Flawless you have to
tilt the whole Xbox that's originally it
was the DV but I dropped my DV I think
you know at some point you know it's
it's important uh to think about Fitness
when it comes to video games it's easy
to sit ridic
time so yeah ridiculous Fitness uh pick
up your Xbox edition throw it grab the
shotgun and just yeah Xbox hunt it's the
whole thing and then you can buy an Xbox
One X yeah four T some time they'll make
that thing okay all right we'll see if
we can set that up um so Alex and Dan
and I I think most of us have really
come under the spell of Battlegrounds
really yeah I'm sorry it hunts me it's
great it's not the sort of game I
normally think of myself getting into
either it it was something that you know
like we'd seen some of the you know the
the Arma stuff and and you know King of
the kill and and you know there other
games out there in in the field it just
none of them ever really clicked and
this one did in a way that it got it
hooks in deep yeah no it's it's I'm just
happy it it's stable one but I mean it's
I mean for me it's always been just give
the player choice you know what I mean
that it's like let just give them a
playground with lots of weapons like
games like just cause three M or just
cause two multiplayer stuff like that
where it's just chaos you know and but
it's fun and it's the same with
Battlegrounds is like it's not as like
fast-paced as say king of the kill mhm
whereas you have time to do some fun
stuff you know you have time to do a
back flip if you want to you know and
and this kind of stuff and that's what
you know the design was it was to like
yeah it's still a battle royale but
there's still time to have fun right
yeah or time to just kind of hide on the
second story of a building yeah
walk up there and just yeah the people
you're people people hate you I won
whatever that's I don't care I don't
care let them hate me that's right there
is no right way to play the game I get
people oh no they're not playing it the
right way and it's like if you win
that's the right way to play oh you been
reading your
comments they say a lot about the right
way to play comments on videos there no
there's no right way to play but that
was the wrong way to play I can I'll
vouch for that we were definitely
playing the wrong way there was one
where I had my gun trained on a person
and then for whatever reason just didn't
shoot I don't really know why it's just
like hey are we going to engage these we
going to shoot these guys no are they
shooting us am I dead now okay well
that's a good time I saw this amazing
video of some guy who was trying to
shoot through a window with I think a
shotgun he tried to shoot and the he
thought the bullet didn't go through so
he was just like cursing at the game
like this this is broken this is and
then as as he was doing that obviously
he got sniped from outside through the
window and it's just the Meltdown of
that was the funniest thing I've seen in
so I got a nice picture of a guy who
sent me a picture of the corner of his
screen which was broken because he threw
something at it after like dying silly
like that's yeah I how does it feel to
be responsible for breaking people's
psyches pretty great no no it's I don't
know what we've done but we've done
something right and yeah it's been
tremendous to see it really just taking
off like this uh and circle yeah circle
circle oh yeah no no it's just forces
action yeah it's good it's just taken
all this stuff of of games that I've
liked over the last like four or five
years and kind of just put them into it
my game I mean I've never I've never put
just CS together with player unknown but
now that I'm thinking about it it's like
just gos with a circle that gets smaller
yeah right that's yeah when you say like
the four or five games that inspired you
like what would those be oh like Delta
Force black HW down um America's Army 2
and three
um yeah oh no I paid the [__] out of
that game holy [__] like uh but um
and yeah Day Z just the Day Z mod and
the whole modding scene that was kind of
it like they they were kind of what
really made me want to make a game like
this uh just from like perade death
that's this kind of stuff that uh and
modding he mding yeah uh so fire pro
wrestling world uh what's the is is it
really just kind of going back to the
the roots of fire Pro and kind of just
is is the thing here hey we're putting
on the PC is there a lot more too CU I
it sounded like that there would be
maybe some kind of deeper mod support
there right well it's it's kind of
Tenacious to call it an early access
game because even though we're launching
An Early Access it'll you know burst
into the world essentially fully formed
okay because the the base system is
going to be uh the previous iteration
for the PS2 fire pro wrestling returns
okay we're basically taking the same
system and uh the whole code has been
Rewritten from scratch and we're moving
it over onto PCS and the question then
is like where do we go from there and
that's kind of what we want to do in
Early Access is get a lot of fan
feedback because I know people have been
brewing crazy ideas over the last 10
years since the previous installment
like we want this that and the other
thing like you want these kinds of moves
you want these kinds of
modes and the director himself is a huge
fan of the game so I've been picking up
all this info from like the forums and
you know uh over on the steam pages and
I give him the director and he's like
yes yes yes yes I want all these things
too but it all comes down to where do we
want to put our development dollars to
get the biggest bang right so and and so
I I guess it sounds like that that that
kind of PS2 stuff as it as it moves over
like it is in a state where it would be
reasonable to iterate on it in
meaningful ways then oh yeah definitely
we have we have a very strong base to
build on and I mean I think just it
being online yeah uh not technically for
the first time because the Dreamcast
version also had like you could download
and upload
Uh custom wrestlers and things like that
and moves but you know now having like
Steam Workshop it's just going to be uh
totally Bonkers once the community gets
their hands on it oh definitely I mean
you know that's that's been maybe the
only bright spot about some of the WWE
wrestling games over the years has been
just the created content and the user
created stuff and seeing like not only
people creating wrestlers that aren't in
the game but you know their own
creations and just like the well my
personal favorite was always the story
Creator they did for those games that
was just like this ridiculous mess of
nonsense just terrible scripting oh yeah
I mean but you but you could type in
your own text so you could tell whatever
so I was just writing stories that had
no wrestling in them and it was just
everyone hanging out backstage at a
sports arena just talking like referees
having coffee together right did you
ever have to fight actually or is it
just conversations no just conversations
and then someone gets hit by a limo My
Dinner with Andre the Giant yeah
basically yeah that's how it goes yeah
it's really funny because fly beer
ourselves we have never made a game with
Mod support because our games are like
very small and tight but with nuclear
thron something strange happened in that
a fan took the
game basically like reverse engineered
the
code yeah and then rewrote the game with
Mod Sport and then emailed us and said
hey is it okay if I release this as a
Batcher for the original game that's aw
so suddenly we had mport yeah and now
people are making incredible stuff like
new characters like that's great new
weapons new new levels new worlds we're
just like I don't think we deserve this
but I'm very happy it exists so so did
you pull any of that kind of just
support structure into like the main
branch of the game we're working with
him now like he he kind of joined the
community back when the game was in
early axis and he's always kind of been
around but yeah no there there's
something like as a game developer
knowing how our code looks you kind of
go like oh God but then knowing what
code looks like after it's been compiled
and then reverse engineered you go
double oh God and then knowing that
somebody made sense out of that and then
added functionality to the game
including online multiplayer which we
don't support like ourselves I like mod
support we were just like what is this
person like how yeah so we emailed we
emailed him and kind of like hired him
to work on yeah like hey how about we
just send you the source code and see
really do we can do this easier we could
skip the first six months of this
process wow yeah mod is like it's a
really fun thing to just watch oh yeah
yeah which yeah I mean for LIF drous is
it's kind of like what are what do you
want to like change the colors or
something but I modified Lo rowers to
make it easier uh because you could
change a lot of the damage values and
stuff like that pretty easily in in
there so that's true just like you know
I just want to see I want to unlock all
this stuff I genuinely believe l r might
not actually be like a video game video
game it's like a feeling game like you
play it and then you're like okay I feel
better about myself and then you just
kind of does that make it an emotional
game yeah it's like basically gone home
but with airplanes yeah yeah no that's
exctly yeah I would think of it as gone
home as more of like a Luft Rouser clone
in a sense but U but yeah I guess you
you could approach it yeah Steve gner
went home so it's safe to say that
exactly he left town so whatever man
that dude yeah god um so I mean how
different I mean I imagine it's been
dramatically different coming at
Battlegrounds as opposed to modding an
existing game does it feel very like
extremely liberating to go like okay
whatever we come up with that we can
afford or is it more like it was really
tough the first like few months because
when I was making mods for the first
part I pretty much did everything myself
from like the artwork to to writing code
very very very bad code you think your
code's bad [__] oh no we we meet you
don't worry no no there's there's lines
in like our GitHub where there's like we
have a new coder looking after the Armor
3 mod and it's like you know feel free
to rewrite this is old B original
Battlegrounds code Berry messy and just
yeah my my code was bad but coming from
that and then going into position of a
creative director
really I literally have I literally have
messages comments in our code that it's
like don't forget to take out the trash
that we just never removed because it
was there that's just cute I just like
yeah it
wasn't but yeah no so um what was I
talking
about coding and kind of you know being
creative director yeah so like coming as
a credit director then being like the
Visionary in the company like and not
having to implement stuff and me
micromanaging team teams internally
trying to go well I should do this and I
should do that and that was tough to
kind of stand back and go and now I
trust them and now it's just let them do
their things and they're great I mean
and you've got like a pretty decent
Cadence uh for updates uh going through
Early Access like our boss's agile
system so he adapted agile to his own
making and it's really good like weekly
and monthly updates and it works well
yeah uh and with the popularity of the
game I imagine each one of those updates
does it kind of become a nailbiter where
on one hand you're like oh we're fixing
this thing we know we need to fix but
also we're introducing this thing and
now the car is kind of in motion and
you're starting to change things oh yeah
no no we like we we had that with when
we did looting update and when you
looted from the inventory you wouldn't
play an animation and we put it in and
there was a bug in it that would play
the full animation every time you car
and people hated that and we got uproar
and we have to change back uh but now
we're being very careful about what we
Chang cuz the core game kind of works
you know we just want to polish it off a
little bit but yeah but we have the test
server that we roll out stuff to and
hope nothing breaks um in 24 hours but
you know we have a great QA team like we
have six people on our QA team that do
nothing but like play the game
constantly and just look for things so
you by the time we release it to the
public then it's it's relatively stable
do you have like a a batch of things
that you look at and think oh we should
definitely fix this but actually the
game is better because it's kind of like
I ran myself over with my own car that
seems like something that would be very
hard to do but I managed a way to do it
uh and it was like okay well I got out
of the car and kind of skipped the
animate like something the models moved
in a certain way and then I ran myself
down and I was like that's the best
that's one of the best things that's
happened to me in my entire time with
the game there's lots of stuff we don't
want to like the you know the ragd doll
sometimes is a little crazy yeah but I
like that you know but you know it's
it's mainly like our focus is optimizing
performance and and getting the servers
up the spec you know at the moment yeah
we'll add new stuff that's that's but
you know that's what the focus is really
you know the it's kind of feature
complete and I was just polishing off
stuff cool physx oh my god physx um just
yeah we're going to see tress effects
for hair you know we're going to go and
let's just keep implementing all this
stuff so did weekly updates do you also
have the thing where you look at
features that are going to take more
than two or three updates SE just like
how are we going to oh yeah we have that
with vating so like our vating system
it's prototyped and it works and it's
Dynamic but you know it was written in
maybe a week and it's still being worked
on you know and it's like I and we're
like it's not coming out in the June
update maybe July um it just yeah when
you announced the vaulting thing I think
you said something like if you stand in
front of in front of something you will
Vault over it and I heard you will Vault
over it and I just yeah I thought it was
like you have to if you're in stand of
something in front of something that you
can Vault over you will automatically
Vault over it and I was just like that's
an amazing video game I want to play
please set that as a
switch at time link would just jump if
you walk to the edge of something it's
just that you know it's
it's the Ocarina time of murder games
yeah yeah no
no I am I wrong no but I mean why not
make it easier to kill people sure yeah
that's that's half fun uh Early Access
and you know Japanese game development
isn't something that often go hand inand
when you think about it it seems like
this is
maybe I you don't really think of a lot
of Japanese developers getting into
programs like this has it been
interesting and exciting to kind of like
say hey we're going to get out there and
do this yeah well the most difficult
part about uh trying to do fire PR or
Early Access is explaining to the devs
and to the managers like and producers
what exactly Early Access is how it's
supposed to work how you're supposed to
you know talk to the community and get
feedback uh one thing I've noticed a lot
about uh in the west especially recently
it's there's a very close distance
between the development community and
the actual players of the game you know
everyone's on Twitter and you're talking
back and forth but in Japan there's kind
of like this you know there's there's a
few creators that are really getting in
there but for the most part just kind of
like this like professional distance so
uh the fact that you know spike jof is
willing to let me be there and you know
be inter intermediary between the deves
and the community I think is really cool
in a Forward Thinking sort of way I mean
it kind of speaks to the nature of the
game too cuz like you know sort of what
made it popular in the west even when
they weren't releasing here was kind of
like the hardcore community of people
that wanted to trade you know their
badly copyright violating wrestlers and
and what have you uh so it it feels like
the right to me at least it feels like
kind of like the right format for that
yeah yeah definitely it I mean it does
but then again corporations don't always
make those choice so it's super cool to
hear that in this case they are that's
just amazing yeah like breaking those
walls down feels like over an overdue
kind of thing and definitely you know I
think you know over the last year or two
it's been really fascinating to see just
kind of more Japanese developers
approaching the PC in general uh you
know and even just Sega starting to Port
more of it stuff or you know some of
these Platinum Games Vanquish finally
coming over and Stu yeah right my God I
I that's like 1/4 of the reason I have
my Xbox 360 still hooked up all right
well one down what's what what else
needs to get ported before Split Second
you just oh yeah okay well that that
already exists on PC yeah but I want
like I want an updated version um I
don't have to do Alan Wake anymore
binary domain which I adored mhm and uh
I really like Alpha Protocol even though
it's kind of broken but like it's Matt
Rory worked on Matt
Rory love it a lot it's I have I have a
fondness for games like that where you
can tell that there was a dream in a
vision yeah and it didn't quite it never
because that's what a dream and a vision
is it's why I love Peter Molly new and
kind of why like David Cage's work is
like you look at the games you're like
this was a long shot and it was never
going to happen but my God am I glad
that there's somebody taking those shots
right because it pushes the industry in
a certain direction and that's that's
incredible yeah even you know I think in
that game what was it you kind of just
you Speck into pistols and stealth and
you're just pretty much Invincible for
the entire game right yeah the number of
bosses I beat just going like y yeah uh
but I guess that's you know part of the
fun when you've got realistic weapons is
is that dramatic moment of just wiping
someone out and sending them back to the
lobby yeah looks way too happy saying
that I know right it's like that's
honestly it's yeah I know it's like it's
kind of CRA I I keep going back to the
one game I won because we've been
streaming it and I've been playing like
[__] every time um but yeah I I won I
got 12 kills and I and I've never done
that well ever again I may never do that
well again
um but that one win has been enough to
keep me going in pursuit of that type of
performance again yeah yeah no it's it's
certainly addictive Pursuit it's yeah
it's a good feeling when you win and
it's been such a heavy game uh for
streaming uh obviously and uh you know
you've been doing some things here with
streamers and kind of custom servers and
stuff like that what's it been like kind
of supporting that Community it's been
great we have poopy Queen our community
manager best name on the Internet um
yeah right and she like she's just being
a legend with with community and she set
up the partner program and you know it's
proving really well it's not just twitch
streamers it's just people who love
Battle Royale and support like the game
basically in whatever form and and we
try to give something back in the form
of custom servers which is our our sort
of start into modding you know they can
kind of change stuff and we'll
eventually add it that you can take out
the Battle Royale game mod completely
and have a custom server that you could
do whatever you want on this kind but
we're getting there and it sounds like
zombies are coming to the game this is
something that was tested in custom
servers this was like we we we saw the
game like uh there was Korean streamers
this zombie mode of four of them with
weapons and everyone else was just using
Mal and just ended up being crazy fun so
when we were in the Czech Republic our
executive producer told her animator
let's get some zombie animations so we
can put them in right and we both agreed
it was like Fast zombies like World War
Z 28 Days Later that kind of like you
see the zombies you run the [__] away
you know it's not like I can take these
on and so the video you saw was made by
myself and the lead animator in about 3
days um and you know we have no plan for
it yet we're not investing a huge amount
of uh time into it because you know we
want to opiz got higher priority stuff
yeah performance and servers my God the
servers um but you know it's it's
something we want to do we want to do
you know 90 players playing as zombies
versus 10 players playing with weapons
and and that's do you design like
obviously with the with how much
streaming there is the the you know
normally you make a game you're very
aware of the loop between like a player
and a game there's like input from the
player and then output from the game but
you're designing like two circles right
because the game is also outputting to
the audience the audience is inputting
to the player like is have you had like
a lot of strange challenges figuring out
how to again like we haven't really like
it we know it's a massive spectator
sport like we know like on Twitch like
people watch it all the time but we
don't design it for that you know it's
like it for us it's I think it's it's
just the nature of the game game it's
again you say it's the circle you know
it's it's it's the nature of a battle
royale that especially in our version
it's a bit slower so there's time for a
streamer to chat to community so there's
that interaction but then even though
maybe 80% of matches are a bit boring
you know there's those 20% that are just
amazing right that's what people coming
back it's a drama right the drama of
your streamer getting that far and like
the circle getting it's like a good game
of soccer basically you know it's like
just that chance of something amazing to
happen and it's it's a game that lends
itself so we were talking about it with
folks from Microsoft on yesterday we
were talking about the game and just
like how it really lends itself so well
to stories from the players like
everyone wants to talk about their run I
will talk about these 12 kills I got
with this shotgun for at least another
two months okay yeah yeah but the at
least and like just it seems like
everyone kind of has their story of just
like oh we were in the motorcycle we
jumped and did this and you know either
they were capturing it or streaming it
but maybe they're just like hey you know
this thing I did last night was the
crazy [__] because it was nonlinear and
you just you chose what you wanted to do
and and you created Your Own Story right
and it's the same with Battlegrounds is
like you decide how intense your round's
going to be where you want to drop and
you decide how you want to play it you
know if you want to go crazy you do go
crazy or if you want to camp the whole
thing do and it gives you a different
experience every time and I think that's
why it's popular at the moment it's just
yeah do you have a recommended style
that you like for for new players or
anything like get the [__] away from
everyone else uh just like get away from
everyone else get out of the plane and
just get get far away and just creep
your way in get armor get weapons
jumping immediately a good idea
immediately yes probably but I don't
know like just choose somewhere that you
can maybe see a car or okay get spot it
from the air and get away because I I'll
tell you like as we've streamed this
game a handful of times we get a lot of
tips like people are like they're doing
it wrong they're spending too long
getting gear they're wasting their time
getting gear they're there this is bad
time no no no they're doing it all wrong
there's no right way to play if you win
are you good
no people always ask Developers for tips
and I always have to go like listen I'm
horrible at my game but I at least
assume that you watched a lot of people
play and maybe cleaned some stuff every
day like I Bic have twitch running
constantly they're better than me so I
just they are yes what I should do is
Dodge these 4.6 million bullets and I
roll to this weapon and then insta kill
everything on the screen yeah that's a
great tip but I can't do it it doesn't
doesn't help me yeah yeah and then do a
thousand suplexes of different styles
well they actually are over a thousand
moves but there's maybe only so many
suplexes okay well more well I mean yeah
it's like let us know where you want us
to put our money in is this is it like
the Chris Jericho kind of thousand man
of a thousand holds thousand one hold th
no was thousand three holds there's a
lot of arm bars there was a th4 cuz
minko was a th that's right yeah so it
was armar yeah a lot of arm bars a lot
of arm bars as it turns out so maybe
maybe putting some more armar no I mean
it almost feels like you have 1,4 moves
at your disposal cuz I don't know if
you've ever gone down the edit wrestler
rabbit hole but i' I've started to and
and it's it's a lot man it's a lot uh
somewhere between the move list and like
the AI programming right it was the
always the AI programming that I got to
and I was like oh man this is it's
amazing that this is here and I don't
know that I can fully devote myself to
this for your game yeah yeah uh but yeah
it just it it always went so deep and it
was fascinating to see like you know
here's this like 2D wrestling game in
the era of like you know as as games are
becoming more and more polygonal and
going further and further uh even back
when when I first discovered the series
and anyone who knew anything about
anything was always like yeah you know
it's great that the graphics are better
and yeah I know this one has a Scott
Steiner in it or whatever but hey you
need to be playing this cuz this is this
is the real wrestling game here uh it it
must be I imagine that that kind of just
either gives you a leg up or is
terrifying to be able to say like hey
this has this like established fan base
that is like extremely hungry for this
thing to come back it's been a while oh
yeah well I mean the fact that the
community was there waiting for it was
definitely a huge push in able to
getting the scheme approved uh director
he's a guy named mamoto he's been trying
to get a new fire Pro made for like the
past 10 years right and every time he
brings it to the board they're like no
uh-uh maybe next time but because of now
like we had we've been publishing on uh
PC steam recently and we've had a great
success there so they figured they'd
give him a chance cool but uh yeah I
mean it's been really interesting seeing
people's reactions to the games because
like the old school fans are like oh yes
like firepro is back awesome but then
people are seeing the the series for the
first time it's like what is this you
know like this this looks like you're
playing with like action figures or
something yeah so I imagine like yeah
educating new fans as to like where this
thing comes from and and why it's
important all this sort of stuff I guess
that that'll be part of the the
challenge of getting out I ripped off
H1Z1 that's what I did I'm just trying
to imagine how exciting it must be for
for what was his name maimoto yeah how
exciting it would be for after 10 years
to finally get that green light that
must feel so good oh man he's he all
smiles all day a that's super good he's
not even feeling the crunch oh that's
awesome that's awesome so when are we
going to hear more about vam I mean the
book came out uh all this other stuff I
know uh you know side projects are
happening and other stuff so fber is a
bit in maintenance mode we' focusing on
getting our all stuff4 bit stuff yeah
it's basically that you know flamb was a
roller coaster for me in JW and and in
many ways we were just never quite ready
for how big it got so we've been sort of
we never grew we never like we we're
just the two guys who started the thing
so we've been looking at the stuff we've
made and just kind of fixing some stuff
and that's mostly my job like tww is
sort of the the creative part of the
company I just kind of do the
implementation and everything around it
um so we basically said like you know
what we're going to split off for a
little while JW you go make a side
project I'll go fix our stuff and then
eventually you know when we're ready
we'll get back together and we'll start
a new project and we've been talking
about new stuff so there's definitely
new games coming cool I just have no
idea what they are like they're just
prototypes you know you play something
you go like how about like a b game
with guns on your like whatever sure why
not because like we have gun settings
whether it's a fish or not do you do you
feel that like there's going to be a
shift uh in in vamer out because I think
about vamer you think about screen shake
you think about this sort of stuff is
the screen Shake era over or are we
entering the double screen Shake era
well we've we've since since nuclear R
we Implement a slider where you can set
the screen shake to zero or 200% we
don't we want people to have like the
choice in the realest screen Shake just
to stalk in Microsoft terms it's like
the truest screen shake you witnessed
the most powerful screen the this we
want Nuclear Throne in 320 by 240 on
your screen on a 4K screen and if the
screen shakes it just shakes all over
the 4K screen HD screen Shake 4K screen
Shake we but no so JW on the site has
been working on a game called minute
which is with evolver digital and it
just looks adorable it's with his uh
with his partner and two others uh and
it's just it's incredible to see you
know him working on that side thing
while
I'm with apple yeah uh so we'll have new
stuff coming up and it's I'm actually
like quite excited to get back to it and
I think for our new games are going to
be a bit smaller nuclear thr almost like
three and a half years I don't know how
long you work on a project but 3 and a
half years for me is is too much I need
something to like I need something to be
like very excited about so our next game
is going to be very exciting for me all
right I hope great otherwise I'll just
I'll just cry yeah uh what was the I
guess like at some point the player
unknown name you're you know got out
there in a way that like like now
you're like sidm or American M no I'm
notown no you are now there's no right
there there's no there's no turning back
from this yeah it was like you know
putting my name on the game like it was
either going to be great or it was going
to be [__] it turned out to be great so
yay yeah and so uh obviously you know
servers and uh you know that type of of
maintenance is kind of in the near- term
uh and then stuff like 3D replays got
coming which like you'll be able to play
the the match back in the engine and use
cinematic cameras and DEP of field and
all kinds of stuff is that something
where it's like it'll be a match that
you were in or you thinking like oh
we're going to build like the DOTA
replay type thing of like go watch any
game that's ever happened we we were
going to be storing the data for all the
games so why not you know that you can
just go back and watch anyone's game you
know right so yeah know I'm excited
about that it's because it gives content
creators really interesting ways to do
stuff especially if you have slow motion
and stuff like that right yeah yeah if
you've got all that data I got to know
mhm what weapon has killed the most
we're still crunching that actually I
asked our data science guys for this but
there's so much D that they were like
yeah I can't answer you this week um
maybe maybe next week like we're going
to let this query Run for the next
couple of weeks and yeah see how it goes
and yeah but yeah it's it's insane
insane amounts of data do you know how
many hours have been played many a good
number yeah yeah no many many an unknown
number yeah player unknown number and
and uh so what's the plan for console is
it kind of get out of Early Access on PC
this year and then Implement on Xbox or
well no we we hope to come out on Xbox
later part of this year as well I mean
where we want to try to you know launch
Early Access and or get about Early
Access come back and console R about the
same time that's that's the plan
internally and it's good because like
our console team is a team called in
Tito from um Spain they the mutable
which is like the character
customization system there an AP
reloaded I think as well a few others
but uh they're doing the console version
so like our main team that's working on
the PC version don't have to you know
change because like I get lots of lovely
feedback via the Internet um they
they're wonderful people thank you um
but no they're terrible
Jesus I was just about to say I don't
know how you manag to say that without
like breaking someone oh no I mean I
enjoy my trolls with coffee in the
morning you know it's just good work
yeah yeah but I mean
yeah so uh with that in mind I guess
like so Early Access you know and then
do you foresee the game being done or
what changes when the game out access
what actually changes CU I assume the
stable platform stable with modding
support will come after we'll have two
new maps we're hoping maybe when we come
out of Early Access the new maps will be
ready but new maps take a lot of time
especially big maps and yeah they're
both they're the new the new ones are
both 8 by8 as well so like they're going
to take time um but you know that's we
have planed going forward for like we
want this to run for 5 years you know
that it's not just a a a year or two
years we intend on building a really
good platform here and that's going to
take some time but and then uh firep
wrestling world is not yet launched on
Early Access right correct and is is it
is there a launch date for it yet or is
it still kind of coming together I wish
I could tell you guys but the uh the pr
team back home would crucify me so but
but I mean that tells me you do have a
date in mind right okay okay so but we
actually we're having uh another uh Fan
event uh next Wednesday in Japan where
we'll be releasing or giving uh
announcing the release date fantastic so
probably you know us time sometime on
uh it' be Tuesday then all right yeah
because we're in the future oh right yes
I know that as well like we have the
future time yeah great it's always fun
to fly back here from there because you
get to eat breakfast twice so great yeah
I had that once where the first time I
had to fly that I had a meeting at like
the 11th at like 8:00 a.m. and I flew
out at 11th on at 11:00 a.m. and I was
like I have no idea how this works but
I'm very excited that I can make this
meeting yeah we'll see how it goes you
gain a day on the way here and then on
the way back you just lose a day yeah
like leave Monday or Wednesday I lose
days all the time it's fine yeah well
thank you all for coming through uh it's
a pleasure to talk to you about this
stuff this uh it's all really exciting I
get fire Pro and of course Battlegrounds
and and I just more flam next vamer game
blamer next I will make sure that
whatever it is you will be able to get
12 kills in it
great okay just once though yeah just
once and then I can talk about it for
months to come the game deletes itself
from your hardrive the one moment of
Glory I had you can never take that away
from me all right thanks we'll be back
we got one more segment to go so hang in
there we'll be back
shortly
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
know
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey hey
hey
he hey
[Music]
hey
hey hey hey
[Music]
heyy
hey he
he
[Music]
hey
down
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
a
n
[Music]
got me do time you're my attorney my
judge and jury I'm guilty lock me
[Music]
up hey hey
I said lock me up
key lock me
[Music]
up you can't restrain me you can search
me I'll give it all up just to be with
you I'm so happy now you got me I
surrender all my love to you
don't you see what you doing to me I'm
in love and I can't break free now I'm
begging with your baby please don't
leave me hanging no a lock down baby you
drive me crazy B shaping your love has
got me doing time you're my attorney my
judge and jury I'm eting guilty so lock
me
up
oh oh yeah I said lock me up
ke lock me
[Music]
up baby it's lock down baby you drive me
crazy he scaming the love is got me
doing time you're my turnning my judge
in jury I'm breathing guilty so lock me
up for with
pleas you got to take away to keep
my me
up
[Music]
in
hey pretty baby come and save me I got a
conv for you call me crazy but I maybe
committing a crime of the first degree
I'm not pretending I mean what I'm
seeing I'm coming in with My Hands Held
High got to face it I'm not going to
make it without your love and I got
nowhere to go don't you see what you
doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with your
baby please don't leave me hanging oh no
no no the lock down baby you drive me
crazy think over escaping your love has
got me throughing time you're my
attorney my judge and jury I'm bleeding
gu lock me
[Music]
up I said lock me
up lock me
[Music]
up you can't restrain me you can search
me I'll give it all up just to be with
you
I'm so happy now you got me I surrender
all my love to you don't you see what
you doing to me I'm in love and I can't
break free now I'm begging with you baby
please don't leave me hanging no a lock
down baby you drive me crazy can't nocap
your love is Count me doing time you're
my attorney my judge and jury feel
guilty so lock me
up
oh oh
yeah lock me
[Music]
up lock me
up baby KN down baby you drive me crazy
he over scaping and love is got do time
your my turnning my judge and jury I'm
breathing guilty so me
up me you got to take with keep
my me
up Keep Me
[Music]
In
pretty baby come and save me I got a
conv for you call me crazy but I maybe
committing a crime of the first degree
I'm not end it I mean what I'm saying
I'm coming in with My Hands Held High
got to face it I'm not going to make it
without your love and I got nowhere to
go don't you see what you're doing to me
I'm in love and I can't break free now
I'm begging with your baby please don't
leave me hanging oh no long lock down
baby you dve me crazy think over scaping
your love has got me doing time you're
my attorney my judge and jury I'm Bing
guilty so lock me up
[Music]
key I lo me up
key lock me
[Music]
up
C
hello and welcome back to giantbomb.com
coverage of e3 2017 this is the second
night of the show and we are at our
final segment of the
night so let's see how this goes then
we've got a full crew I don't think we
could fit any more than this we did not
prepare for more than six uh this is the
number of microphones we brought we
brought seven mics that's it that's we
if more people showed up tell them to F
themselves Heather Alexander is here
from Kaku welcome hi how's it going back
there it's okay I am about to collapse
yeah that's okay that sounds about right
that seem seems about right uh Patrick
KET professional collapser
uh the second time she dragged this week
Phil Spencer Jeff gersman that's Z
Davis never not good yeah
hi welcome it's good to see you you too
yeah uh Austin Walker is here from uh
average bomb.com average bomb yeah
listen slightly above average bomb no no
someone registered average bomb.com last
after last night's show and directed it
to way points one of our many we also
have new dod. city yeah poop. Mo mhm
yeah we got cultural Marxism Club they
all of the URL these all sound like
Mastadon instances to me yeah basically
we are the Mastadon of video game
website and I mean that both the social
media Network and like the metal band so
yeah that that's a pretty good place for
people who know about Metal start of the
special no it's actually one of the more
Alex Naro it was he's the one who made
[__] noise he's laughing a little too
hard yes have you played rock
band Chris PL is here are you the fge
now one of those S I don't know I've
been mostly doing VCR reviews smart yeah
that's real money I'm telling you yeah
uh what's what's the latest on auto
tracking still good still I mean it's
gotten
better and like so I was at C I didn't
go to CS I was there I didn't go I'll be
honest I don't even know what they do at
that show [__] lying about VCRs to me
Justin maoy down there hi how you doing
I own fartpatrol.com
that's a pretty good one that's not bad
I also um own teen google.com which is
not I keep waiting for them to come
calling with that checkbook cuz they're
going to get one of these days they're
going to be like hey wait a minute this
is where they're going to buy Snapchat
and they just wanted to redirect also
when when Heavy Rain was big I bought
press X to Jason and that is not pretty
you remed that since then no just stayed
in the archives what if you just now
double down on that and just say like
press X to robot or press X to Detroit
that's a whole URL have that kind of
money to around I've got an offer code
for you you can get this uh URL for a
discount Griffin M hello hi to me yeah
Banas seat yeah the banana thing really
took off huh yeah how's that been going
it's been going it's been going good um
isn't it coconuts now yeah I was going
to say need a whole coconut are you
doubling down coconut business it's
escalating quickly a looking at your
agent over here Nick is this a coconut
thing
happening great give a thumbs up thank
you yeah I typically avoid food that has
its own like sort of fruit hair and
that's kind of what a coconut brings to
the table but like a banana has fruit
hairs but it's on the inside of the peel
and you did that I did do that I think
by trans property like really this
coconut thing got to happen yeah my
brand right now [__]
sucks one more year of stuff and stuff
in your mouth for
money it's the
internet so how's the show been going
for like uh you you wayo kids first one
as a group lot of people here I had a
man confront me ask for my phone number
today to like stop me from getting it
was a whole thing to date you no they
want to kiss you was a pastor to get
into the that doesn't make it anymore
was it the bad guy from Evil Within too
yeah actually that are Far Cry 5 one or
the other a lot of bad pastors out there
asking about why did a pastor ask you
for your phone number though for real he
thought I was an Esports he asked me
someone thought you were an orts or so
someone so it's first time and people
are from the fans are around and they're
like hey can I get a photo and I'm like
awesome sure and this dude had a camera
and he was like I'll take that photo for
you and just he kept that photo that was
a photo for him and then he was like so
what are you professional amateur I was
like I'm I'd write for a living I guess
and sounds professional he was like how
many followers do you have and it just
went down from there it was bad did he
want to like make a little money like
what was he he just like I'm trying I'm
trying to Hitch my wagon to somebody
like a real proper influencer you look
like you got the juice he said he was at
making this is not a joke a New
Hampshire based amateur Esports League
hey Live Free or Die [__] [__]
godamn right represent shout out to all
of you but is the league called live e
or die definitely and then Sports and
parenthesis somewhere in that sentence
fig so that would been my E3 so far all
right yeah that sounds good Patrick you
what a weird E3 just this is your I me I
actually feel H so yeah so I've been
going
1997 skipped one year two years ago I
was uh yeah 14 it was in Atlanta back
then the first one where they showed
halflife one your stylent in English uh
I went my I went with my father because
and I had a pink underage media badge
because well that was back then where
you could work for Best Buy or it was
not GameStop it was bages software Etc
and wasun fun was around if you had a
past up and they sold video games you
could just get in just happy people to
show up
to you have to be 17 now right there's
no so they still had the sign in front
that said you have to be 17 yeah but it
turns out you get a pink badge
interesting that's always been there
because you get like you know kids that
are on TV shows that show up to this
thing St Spielberg's kid you don't need
to be S exactly yeah right he's like
34 an example I have St like Wikipedia
kid page in front of me I'm sorry I know
kids is a different URL
completely have
that Heather there's a real opportunity
here for you to get this URL game so
this is your first this my first E3 you
know when Goku wants to fight people and
he goes into that room where time is
like 12 times [__] slower yeah it's
the I think it's the room we have across
the oh my gosh that is me right now like
just constantly like you're spending the
whole episode charging up oh tomorrow
I'm going to kick all sorts of ass but
right now like I sit down so diso no no
on you I'm done I'm done he's right I'm
so disappointed that metaphor connected
to what we were talking about cuz I hope
we were just about
toar just take a wild turn yeah uh
Justin I feel like you have not been to
E3 since the
70s like it's been about three years
I've been covering it from New York cuz
um is does by covering it from New York
do you mean watching the same videos
that everybody else going s hey big news
that's what everybody's doing now uh
yeah become largely vestigal to our
organization they haven't wised up yet
so I'm just kind of the grand old man
more of a symbol at this point really
pop uh yeah kind of the pop pop of
of I haven't been here for a few years
and uh I wanted to see if it was how I
remembered it was and it was definitely
it was like that how I thought it was a
waking
nightmare yo but there's a lot of people
here and you will wait 45 minutes for a
fish taco from a truck
for 45 minutes know that taco play
stopped taking cards today while I was
like four steps away from getting food
oh wow that's garbage is there like a
law that all of the food carts in that
kind of open area have to have an
offensive name like the middle Feast
there's one with like like an anime girl
just like chilling it's just like
what that it's like I don't know it's
kind like babe Al there like here's your
comfort food it's like I'm not sure if
that's exactly why people are going to
that food truck anime food looks good I
was talking Ben pack about this and he
was like anime food look delicious looks
look at it and I looked at it w Kake I I
have and that food looks [__]
incredible and that looks like a very
relaxing way to just like I'm going to
have this beer and to eat this and then
I got my office lady job that place has
a that place has a little counter out in
front of the window where they hand you
the food and I swear to God they had
like three baskets of like the types of
food that you could order out there that
they it wasn't like plastic it was like
the real food that they set out there
and then put up a sign that said for
display only which I think but it was
the food it's the boldest strategy to
advertised food I've maybe ever seen
because how long does that food keep in
that hot California Sun like how long
does that look appetizing at all well
maybe it just is like you know it's like
Nature's heat lamp finally uh honesty
and advertising that's what I'm out here
for no nowhere else in E3 I saw Beyond
Good and Evil 2 today and what is that
is it a website where you can sign up
for updates or is there what demo how do
you feel about no man
Sky uh I don't wait have you have no one
here actually heard about I saw the same
demo it's a thing okay I know it I'm
actually like vaguely interested I'll
let you see it and come to your own
conclusions yeah uh well no I like Okay
so let's hear about it so it's an action
adventure RPG I guess sort of there's
photos in it do I take pictures of pigs
you can take pictures lots of and you
can show those pictur supposedly show
those pictures to other pigs and they'll
be like oh yeah I know that place that
place has good beard an engine that at
some point may be able to take
photographs of pigs yeah it also it also
simulates the entire [__] universe
and that worked out really well last
time but not so you can go around the
whole universe they basically like it's
like two solar systems three solar
systems something like that what's the
[__] point well so I saw this demo
with uh with Marty from IGN and at one
point he was like do y'all just hate
yourselves like why the [__] are you
doing this they're like this is the only
way this is the best way to make this
game this is the way that we've never
done before Le it's like shh we're
[Laughter]
not we're siphoning money off of this to
make wild just everybody [__] play
their office is like the most beautiful
office in the world you you open the
door and it's just like Beauty
surrounding you and whenever you talk
with them you wonder why the games are
chip they're like what did you do today
well Michelle he ate
cheese so funny this is a real no that's
a real quote that they gave me that's
not fake it's like your your your day
was it like you had a nice cheese meal
and then you sat outside and it was
another gorgeous day and like yeah it's
like well great no games will ever be
published they described the room that
they did the demo did they do this for
you they're like we designed this room
to look like we slept in lot in why CU
that's where they do their best thinking
the comfortable cozy Barracks the thing
the thing with these creative types is
that you never know what's going to lead
you from point A to point B so Michelle
T eats like a whole wheel of cheese and
everybody has like a really good laugh
at it but that that leads him to the
decision to throw away that everybody
throw away everything that folks loved
about Bianca even want this [__] Wild
open open world Universe game that's not
going to happen I mean we'll never laugh
again but what if it does if it does
what if it does though and we all get a
wheel cheese explain the scam that this
cat is running he shows a trailer for
his game everyone's like hell yes here
it is he waits years 15 years later they
show another trailer and every's like
yeah it's happening like do you not re
like it just happened the best part is
last year they showed a trailer for a
totally different game andbody was like
wild doesn't even exist anymore what
about that other game he's
like yo y all see that Raymond origins
was that just like is he just like
pulling that on Sony now he's just like
I got a good thing going with Ubisoft
but what if we did it again like okay
we're going to have this animals
fighting jug game over here we're just
going to make the trailer don't worry
about stop giving them cheese no The Jug
need cheese it's the whole thing pig men
with magnets yeah how that [__] work
I [__] I don't know you take a
pictures of them and then you showed the
magnets to other pigs and they go I know
where those magnets are they make that
rabit
noise [__] they got it Nintendo's like
get me that why do you have such a good
rabbit impression yeah how long did you
work on your rabbit's impression uh
every day I just think about those
little guys and I just laugh till I
[__] a lot back here they're cut UPS
I'll say that about it's hard to see it
because it's not HD but you're actually
just shoting out of your pants right
yeah no we got one more day on this
couch and someone's going to be real
bummed out uh only in the 4K yeah only
true 4K hiding someone's going to have
to sit there and well well we'll get a
steam clean we I know a guy 60 frames
per second yeah uh I that's look we have
to Bean this out to the internet in the
highest quality possible because
otherwise like what are we even doing
you know if I'm sending like 320 by 240
what is that this CBS only the
Fest I've never heard a lawyer pick up a
phone so
fast Jeff I saw commercial for Hawaii 5
where they were fighting a giant robot
what's going on over
there well that's not a joke none of
that was a joke I just like like next
week on Hawaii 5 they're shooting a
robot there's a really amazing program
to the company where if you're there
long enough like instead of like saying
like hey you get to go on sabatical
they're like you can ride a season of
any TV show you
want I chose y David cage got together I
was just like David cage what's up with
this and he said I don't need the robots
you will get to free them free the robot
and I'm like that's boring we want the
cops to bust the robots cuz they're
crimes uh it's just like you know so
Jeff your script is very good maybe we
remove every other
word I feel pretty strong about no no no
Jeff Trust me and then we'll double them
up so so we get a bunch of people saying
we'll follow you and then we'll have the
lead character saying follow
me if we didn't all just agree does he a
plan yes very good yes print it Michelle
cheese man people from other countries
are really taking a beating on this
section it's about time am I right 2017
America's killing it right now so we're
on the open up oh nailing it so has it
been I like like seriously like like has
the show been a lot of appointments and
getting around and seeing stuff or has
it been pretty light for everybody like
are you have like a Heather you have
like a full schedule Oh I am going
everywhere I had this is all a a ton of
first for me where it's like first
translated interviews so I'm just in a
room of like you don't know who to look
at or
you it's well it's also the best cuz
they are very they're very passionate
people but it's also like who do I look
at what do I do oh this is a good
question do they understand what I'm
saying I am terrified but it's also been
very very exciting and I I'm fortunate
to be here but also holy [__] get me out
of here it's there's definitely like a
fire hose effect to it especially like
with you know there are a lot more
people here like last year there ton of
people on that floor yeah last year last
year we were doing stuff like making
phone calls from the show floor and
recording podcasts directly on the show
floor worked last year all kinds of
weird stuff that you've never been able
to do at E3 before I just shove people
aside and go I'm from Kotaku and that
goes everybody's like oh yeah cool we're
cool with them oh yeah you guys are the
best let's go
[__] gam I don't think I don't think
the extra I don't think the extra people
would be an issue except the way that if
you haven't been to E3 before the way
that the show floor is laid out is that
like the big like Sony and Nintendo and
Microsoft and like EA nuis soft and
Activision all demand that they be in
the very center of the show floor right
in front of the [__] front door and
everybody else like those booths aren't
as crowded but everybody just swarms to
Nintendo and Sony like I think it's not
a problem of like there being too many
people here it's just that everybody
walks in and walks 20 feet to the
Nintendo and Sony like cluster [__] and
then stops and it's like you have to
just Buffalo your way through them to
get anywhere it's also a poor convention
for fans
right
serious them like it's it's it's it's
not designed that way and maybe it'll
pivot that way but like I walk around
it's like when I was done with meetings
it's like all right I'll just walk
around for an hour like what would it be
like if I was just here and enjoying
things like there's just not much for
you to do Max has figured that out and
they're trying to Pivot you know eight
years too late and maybe they'll figure
it out and maybe it'll it'll get they
have to I they'll definitely it has to
become essentially a pack that like
adopts a thing like a Gamescom which is
like hours or like you know press hours
ahead of time but but it's just it's a
it's a novelty for fans that have paid
but that novelty will wear off fast I
think because there just not enough for
it's not a good fan and so uh gibis did
an interview they there were they they
interviewed a few people they walked
around and said like so what do you
think of the E3 and they actually got a
couple and we I think we ran into a
couple people that were the same deal
that were like it was the same response
you would get at something like packs
where people were like I waited in line
for like 4 hours and it was awesome we
totally hung out and and it's like some
people were just more than happy to do
that just to get a glimpse of 6 hour
lines for Assassin's Creed Origins that
people were like yeah playable or like
theater playable playable I think I hope
I pray for hour I'm pretty sure they
have that like 45 minute demo if you
were waiting like line for that stuff
yeah and I feel like though like I mean
they're not getting the real press
experience which is like what if I told
you you could come here on like Saturday
and then Sunday night watch an entire
gameplay demo and then like Tuesday and
Wednesday go behind closed doors and
watch that exact same gameplay demo
while the publicist watches you now you
talk yeah it's pretty good cuz that was
my entire day I don't wait 45 minutes
for my parents if they're lost in a city
somewhere you kidding me like to play
Assassin's Creed no like you are on your
own that would be an amazing plot for
the next Assassin's Creed by the way
parents are playing Assassin's Creed oh
is that the new uh the new metaler
parents are blended into a crowd and
they're just like walking near them just
going and so worth it because you going
to play as that bird that just
like my parents scream
W that it doesn't even go up and down
it's just perfectly still it's a very
good bird it's what it does it's good
Birds Austin it's good Birds what if we
uh fired kinch a hall back up and filled
with vendor we had earlier that's
already happened it's called South Hall
now and do you not go to the gamer store
I didn't stop by the gamer store this
year it's right no they no they're like
three now oh really it's it's a
challenging but yeah you know like
clearly yeah the show would probably
need to change just to be a better a
better time for the people that paying
this money and they were not very
upfront about what people got so
Coliseum thing happened
later inated into the show yeah you got
people that thought that uh that they
would get into the press conferences
they I can't wait to see Microsoft
like weird because especially with like
Bethesda and Sony you pretty much had
the same experience as everybody I mean
if you right like if how do about
trailers yeah right do you want to watch
a video cuz we're watching a video yeah
but some of you guys see like bodies
hanging upside down ring
will they jump off and get me yeah they
will not maybe I mean who could say
that's 4D yeah no so we we watched all
those press conferences here with the
air conditioning on and it was pretty
great did smell good oh yeah it was
awesome we we just kind of hung out in
here we talked and watched on the
internet and I had some
water and it was it an influencer
pointed bright lights at me and Patrick
for like an hour oh my god did he
influence you about anything she influ
sorry well we don't know if it was her
fault really was the two guys in front
of it probably was there's two guys in
suits like where where uh Griffin and
and plant are might have been them we
could have been them that close and it
was just like someone was just keeping
them lit to film their re their live
reactions the whole and not just like a
little light like one of those lights
like a big ass light I had to hide
behind his head and Austin just gave the
death stare and then she [__] walked
away it's a lot of wild stuff like I was
at the Sony presser and I was like I'm
going to be all super professional and
then there's like an influencer fellow
who I'm pretty sure was some type of
Luchador oh I saw yes no he was he was
like we are here and we are ready and
I'm just like I'm just trying to get
like my Wi-Fi working I really need to
start sending stuff to the home team
he's like I am pumped I will break you
into a thousand tiny pieces and then
[__] those pieces out yeah that's I mean
E3 that's where I'm headed with honestly
like like give us in one more year I'm
going to be up here pooping my pants and
that's how you that's how you get the
the hits I don't want to just throw
influence under under the bus I no no no
I will name names oh in gadget brought a
video team and I was trying to play that
Wolfenstein and like you are me and I am
in gadget this is a nice guy from in
gadget I'm not going to say his name but
the video guy had like one of those
lights which is not meant for one person
like literally like so inget dude and
Chris how do both of you feel about this
game it's like a 30 minute demo he's
like just just talk about what's
happening so I'm trying to play this
like game about I you know like na
and he like he's like what do you think
about this and he's like playing the
game he's like Nazi killed me
again got killed by a Nazi again and aot
the light is blinding me my eye is
switching my contact is dried up so I'm
changing my contact like directly into
the camera the in gadget video the whole
time thinking like somebody's going to
turn this into a damn gift and it's
going to be me who's the new the new
[__] the new Star Wars
kid crusty crusty contact that's when
the money comes in and suddenly you're
the end Gadget guy right you graduate up
the chain finally AOL
yeah drowning and
money that's where the good game
coverage lives I'm
told if it's not there it's
Z these days anything good
happen Hunter there's a monster hunter
yeah there's a monster hunter hunt all
the monsters monsters absolutely would
you say 10
yeah no I'll do much more than 10
there's at least like 12 okay that is
that is no joke that's the most exciting
uh announcement of e3 for me abely the
the here's here's what I've been trying
to reconcile all week I I'm I'm I love
E3 I genuinely do like I still get
really excited to to to like it's still
so novel to me and it's like this basic
primordial primordial thing of like oh
this isn't out yet and I can play it
[__] yeah but I have this very I I I
have this spider sense now of just like
beond G evil to is a good uh point of
Justin saying like oh it's another
cinematic trailer and the tech demo that
they have is like kind of half a tech
demo and I see that and they say like oh
that's [__] Nintendo Direct we're
making a Pokemon game on switch surprise
[__] of course you're making a
Nintendo yeah like of course I don't
know like I feel like Nintendo is just
the type of company where that might be
sort of a surprise because they might
just [__] this up forever you're like I
don't know maybe it's just like another
10 years of the 3DS somehow this is also
the same company that recently said
these NES are selling Great Stop quit so
like I hate money the the Metroid Pine 4
reveal it didn't do anything for me
because it's a [__] logo like I need
it to be tangible because it's happened
a billion times now where you see it and
then it's gone so like I'm I guess I'm
jaded about that stuff um and but at the
same time like the Bethesda press
conference I get it it's all games that
come out this year and that's cool and
it's concrete but there wasn't anything
very exciting I feel like that's kind of
across the board how it was lot of
sequels and so as as as like as like uh
jaded as I am about like oh well that's
never going to [__] come out or
that's not going to come out for like
four years that's all you got is the
cinematic trailer just a logo reveal
whatever I still want some of that for
me monster hunter world is the only one
where it's like here's a cool reveal for
a new game and here's what it looks like
being played and it looks [__] great
that's like I think the only one of
those that happened this entire year why
do you think you've been you've been in
the game for a long time like why do you
I feel like usually at this point the
the reaction that I've seen broadly
speaking is a little bit tepid to all
the pressers this year and the
announcements and stuff why do you feel
like at this point we're normally mid
console cycle assuming that's what where
we're at is when things are like
cranking and and and uh this would
normally be like a huge year at another
E3 why is it a little more pullback I
think everyone is in a weird spot where
they're trying to find that balance
between what's the right time to
announce a game uh versus shipping it
and that one into the Spectrum being
Sony last year was like shimu 3 help us
make it bye for exactly also we're not
making it so run away from the
kickstarter quick counter argument they
like breath of the wild Persona 5 yaku's
a
zero E3 ain't doing it but like we're
getting game we are midcycle
right and so I think that you have a lot
of companies that are are trying to find
that middle ground and wins the right
time to announce a game and that
changing because of the way the internet
covers games and the way that streaming
has become such a big deal and like all
that stuff is just getting ripped apart
and reformed in in new ways uh as
Publishers find new ways to cut people
like you out of the announcement process
and all this other stuff like yo we can
just do it
ourselves say I think a part of it too
is like there are people now out there
who are making their own stuff
independent from content creators like
Nintendo or whoever who are making more
interesting stuff am I interested in
Metroid on the 3DS yes but also
am2 I can't even say am2r came out and
that's a better version already I'm
looking at a better version of of remake
of Metroid 2 and like am I going to get
excited about some sort of oh great oh
you got the guys who did the bad castle
that was the moment where you're like
super doing a new sweet oh wait oh no uh
yeah that that's that is kind of a weird
one but for me it was uh I think a
couple of things that happened I I think
I'm finally completely broken on the
like and this has been happening for a
while but I think this year maybe the
last of it maybe got kind of pushed out
of me is the like who won E3 like it
doesn't [__] matter like Microsoft is
not out there setting the message
clearly with the way they're pricing the
console and all other stuff it's not
about can we Crush Sony can we can you
know and Sony for their part is just
like yeah we sold a lot of these things
we're just going to show you some
trailers got YouTube playlist to hit
play on yeah yeah yeah and you know at
least Nintendo is just you know
literally pushing play on a video
instead of Sony pushing play on eight of
them or whatever individual videos G to
go oh [__] he's actually they got a
whole thing he's got like a turntable
for trailers and he just goes got uh and
then the next trailer starts it's very
exciting uh so I think like everyone has
games that look fine or solid you know
there's stuff that I go like oh I would
like to play that when that comes out I
would like to play that but also it's a
ton of known quantities and sequels and
stuff where you you look at it and go
like I've been doing this for a while I
know exactly what that game probably is
hopefully it has some twists can about a
specific game though what's here the
Shadow of the Colossus HD Jesus Christ
like they did it on PS3 right they they
on PS3 yeah they did the HD PS think
it's also on
PS4 I thought they brought a person of
that over I'm aware so they had to
remake it enti from the round up i' I
felt like they must have thought that
was a home run and then like it came out
and people were like like what well I
think everyone sit there is this a new I
was really excited about my my I peaked
so fast and then literally what broke me
out of it was I saw the [__] sword
Colossus that's the first one you fight
and I was like oh I know exactly how to
do
him over like done everybody in the room
was like yeah this is perfect though
because I've never finished [__] and I
was like why have you never finished it
and like oh yeah oh yeah well think
about this old man there's a bunch of
people who never played that game in the
first place and the PS4 is selling
really well no one bought a PS3 it's not
entirely true the PS3 was even people
that bought a PS3 if they didn't buy a
PS2 why would they buy an HD collection
of games from the PS2 so like actually
properly remaking that game is
essentially a new game you heard what so
many thinks about what old games look
like so they have to up to do always
they're out there saying this stuff
looks like garbage F that we're paying
these people to remake it so we can sell
[__] [__] jumping
flash [__] blasto [__] blasto all right
now you're talking about um yeah how how
I think the one of the weirdest calls
was putting um that undertale
announcement in the pre-show that would
have been Absol they could have
engendered so much good it violated a
real law where it said the word Vita in
it so they were like all right nope
about that isn't it coming to PS4 as
well yeah PS and but also VA could whis
confence but they were like oh V that
sounds like some pre-show that's the
only V game yeah got [__] Orchestra
to play that music that would and I I
think that yeah there's a lot of stuff
like that where everyone is trying to
figure out what their press conferences
need to be or their briefings you know
whatever we want to call them now uh
because you had briefings Media conf
stuff like that in the pre-show Nintendo
announcing games immediately after it
announced some games uh what of Sony's
coolest games we would and play it
earlier today yeah this hidden agend
game made by superm has made until dawn
had no interest in making an until dawn
2 so they they're making uh a really
boring looking U military game Bravo
Team
Bravo Ghost Squad Bravo but they're made
this game called hind Jenna which is
apparently part of this Sony Europe
initiative called uh play linkink don't
shut us down another Europe Studio
they're taking the You Don't Know Jack
sort of idea of like you know rather
than uh uh you know using control you're
connecting your phone to the TV um and
the one way want to go check out this
game called HED agenda which uses the
same sort of like motion capture like uh
technology of until dawn but it's this
uh it's about a like a thriller like a
seven serial killer and it's uh four
people are up to four people um and uh
you you use a mobile phone and you're
making the decisions together and so
like if you split two two you have to
get in the room and decide like this has
to be a majority this doesn't move
forward without all US piig currency
thing to like
demand I'm going to make the decision
[__] really good and so what's
great about is it's not just that you
get to play the car and then like Austin
gets to make the decision Austin gets to
play a card I'm making the decision yes
and then I get to say [__] you I'm
playing a card on top of that I'm making
the decision and you have that's [__]
why the [__] didn't they show that I say
I'm glad you actually got to play it cuz
so this booth is like there's a big
glass window with a living room inside
of it you can see people having a great
time yeah so it's like oh man I got to
check this out I walk over I go hey uh
one for that thing and they go are you
from Europe and I go what go are you
from Europe and I was like No And
they're like well this is for Europe and
I was like I you're here I don't know to
knew I was like is there another one of
these over there and they're like brexit
really [__] us you just have to lie
like no I am I am Europe I am Europe I
thought I needed to show like a inside
you just see David cage
yo this game is still really cool so
when outside I'm just saying like no one
saw this [__] game and it's amazing
so on top of that uh you're you're
making the decisions but then in the
middle it'll say like all right like
someone is going to have this is the
hidden agenda part so then to hide your
phone and so when you hide your phone
one person of the four gets a secret
objective and it is essentially usually
contrary to like what you would want to
do in the situation so like I ended up
getting the hidden uh agenda like
there's a guy who is who is maybe
wrongfully accused and he wants to
present his case to a judge and Patrick
S Jen was like don't let that
[__] present his case to the
judge shut him down that is and he's
that is my
favorite days and I'm like zap that guy
I mean it's that [__] Final Fantasy
Crystal Chronicle [__] of like you got
something you want to that game was so
good it was so ahead of its time but you
have [__] you want to do but you're
working cooperatively
are yeah well and this that winds up
happening we're like well you end up
splitting and then I know that I have
this subobjective and so we ended up
pinning it on this like PlayStation
employee like we managed to gang up on
this guy and be like yeah that's the
dude that's kep hit objective and uh
three fours through sort of the sequence
you can you can guess who's the person
that has that objective and then we all
pinned it on him because I managed to
switch it over to him and we got to the
end there's like one decision left and I
there are these like uh I guess quick
time quences they're bad they're bad cuz
you're controlling the cursor through
the phone and it's a little deled that
doesn't sound good but it's yeah it
doesn't work great but if you if you uh
manage to complete it first you get an
extra takedown card so you are
incentivized to like try and like
participate in I managed to get one of
them so I had two cards every everyone
else had one and I just let everyone go
go go and I was able to play the last
card pick the decision I wanted everyone
is very upet I ruined that innocent
man's life he is going to the chair I
lost 100 points so [__] y'all they also
they also had they also have a the guy's
name was David jaffy
right look forward they've got a jackbox
they've got a jackbox ass looking game
also they should there four of
them Europe only let us
in all of Europe I love the jackbox I
love the jackbox games like I've played
all of them I I adore them uh this look
really cool cuz you could also use the
camera uh which the jackbox games don't
do they have like the ones where you
input answers draw for like drawful and
TKO uh but you could actually like use
the camera for different things so like
during the the video presentation they
took a picture of shui yida and said
draw riot gear on him it's the [__]
that's so good I was just like yeah it
was so good and also you're like why are
we trying Riot it's like draw shu heita
is a riot cop like and actually he
doesn't need to be around you that's
actually the mission every time you play
the game like find a picture of
sh find a picture take a picture of it
with your phone take a picture of the
picture and then draw a little riot gear
it turns out the shortcut is to just
Google search shuita riot gear and then
when that comes up from his cosplay days
they've uploaded 100 Imes like looking
up your name with Sonic you know you can
just find much yeah that's my
original she r that whole section would
have would have broken up that press
conference in like a really like
refreshing way I feel like yeah I I so
that that's what I said about uh their
showing last year is that it was just
they just showed a bunch of videos and
said nothing about it and it was just
like okay these games look interesting
you you could have like told some fun
stories about these or broken it up and
and all this and they chose not to and
then apparently I was the [__] this
year same exact style like to a fault to
the point where they like they had other
more interesting games around the edges
of the broadcast and this was the year
that everyone realized like y I don't
think this is a good way to do this um
and yeah I just we just don't commit to
it full like the idea that like he comes
out you know Shan L comes out says we
got games to show you and they commit to
just showing like these guided demos and
trailers like and just like committing
to the games get it but sometimes like
like hit agenda like come out like show
do the gimmicky thing especially at this
point in the cycle I mean you think
about they gave a bunch of interviews
prior to E3 like somebody was out there
talking about how much they hate old
games and uh and how they're selling a
ton of PS4s uh so you know they're like
at this point in the cycle sing star is
really important we want to make go
Broad and all this stuff and then you
look at that press conference and you're
like that doesn't line up with
everything you just said yet you have
those games you just chose not to like
showcase like hey there's a lot of
different stuff coming to the
PlayStation we sold a lot of them you
should check this [__] out is it wrong
for me to say that having seen sea Laden
in person he looks like he's funding
some sort of misadventure led by
Bane I mean I'm not going to tell you
what's right or wrong honestly I don't
know that I've ever seen him in person
now he looks really like do you think
you're in
control that's you might you might you
might be honest something I you might
have figured this out who pH Spencer in
this fanf the show
now
yeah yeah I just it's that that
conference uh is a bummer and because I
think they've got good games Underneath
It All you look at and go like all of
the stuff looks interesting regardless
of when's coming out like there were
very few things that I was just like
what the [__] they also have like a lot
of really good first party Dives and a
lot of really good relationships with
other devs and
like like Ubisoft sticks out in my mind
as like the press conference where they
actually like brought those [__]
people up on the
stage that are excited about the media
the dude who is the creative director on
the Mario was GNA cry it's like oh I'm
gonna play that two cries saw
us as well yeah and he's crying cuz that
game's never coming out it's gone and
well yeah I that rabbit's game I is
probably one of the
coolest played I was like this it is so
much fun like the moves they put into it
to like make this XCOM Thing feel like
fun and refreshing I was just like yep
I'll
1000% that's what stuck out to me like
playing it you're running on this little
map and the maps are just like the
battle maps are just like right there
and they're tiny and anybody can go
pretty much anywhere in one move and so
it's completely different from XCOM in
that way and that like if you leave
anybody exposed they get [__]
Massacre like you leave your cute rabbit
Luigi out exposed once he will get
[__] destroyed what what I like about
it is they actually started with the
initial idea of we bring out Shira
mamoto on stage with a gun and then they
work their way backwards how we make a
game around that now what like how do we
get there like imagine that this hadn't
leased for the weeks you
had mamoto came out with a [__] G
yeah okay I'm here for this yes but I'm
sure he loves that gun I'm sure you love
it yeah God and I reminds me of a trip
through a cave once right yeah as a boy
we I used to garden and smoke
[__] uh yeah just imagine like
walks out it's just a Glock like yeah no
I got that that's that's next year yeah
let's hope the sequel is where it's like
greedy they fell into Shadow crossover
they fell into the real world and AK-47s
and you know the Vision C cheese wheel
Trump's America come cleans these
rabbits We Go Far Cry plus uh Mario next
year yeah great Mario the pastor the
father father Mario Father Mario uh you
a very sad version of Losing My
Religion yeah we got some we got some
pretty good uh Jesus pretty good Awful
covers of Rand Duran song how many years
have to pass before they can do mad
world again I feel like that's I feel
like we are on high alert for Mad
World be fun again it's just like days
since mad world uh just like oh well
reset that why didn't Cliff do that with
law Breakers what a power play that
would have been oh [__] like how do you
like that epic I mean 10
cent now it's it's a good
Cession wow wow I know it's very close
to your rabbit he sounds a lot like a
rabbit wait I mean yeah it's it's it's
fun to goof but like seriously I do feel
like there was some good stuff here like
what's like we got talk
about th me and Justin and Austin all
played sea of Thieves together with a
fourth person whose name we did not did
you get the name Michael Michael you
made that up that could have been m
Michelle rest in peace yeah he's gone it
was the most it's it's I've played that
I played that game last year too and it
was a lot of fun but back then it was
just the ship sailing and I got in like
a fight with somebody and uh played an
accordion for a while and you're like I
don't know there was like nothing to do
except sale and now this demo is like
you can get off and there's treasure
hunting and all this other stuff and
it's just the funniest we were talking
about it before we got on about how it's
like it's like stage it's like an improv
it's like improv where like um I don't
think it's uh I don't think it's going
to be the type of game that a lot of
people expect it to be and those people
will probably be disappointed in it like
it's not going to be this deep pirate
RPG or whatever it's a game about just
doing like really funny [__] there's
there so you have a map you have a map
and you you actually have to like
there's no way points or whatever so you
have to look at the map and then look at
where you are and see where like the
treasure is and you press a button right
trigger to like raise it up to your own
face to like read it and then you let it
go and you can see where you are or or
you can press left trigger to turn it
around and hold it up proudly in front
of people and Justin wouldn't stop doing
that nonstop so three of us would be
pushing this big heavy wheel to raise an
anchor while Justin walks around slowly
rotating around the wheel making sure
all of us saw this his his good map we
had the same Maps we saw the map also
Justin's character model was just this
huge gnarly dude holding up his macaroni
art for everybody to see it was the
funny he drawn it himself at a certain
point I got I went downstairs and got a
bunch of Grog and got absolutely pounded
and then started holding at my map as
I'm projectile vomiting
over started playing sea of th and then
I the demoly there after and and I know
I it's going I know about my brand and
everything but [__] is point watch a
banana just go into the face it's great
it's very like I in the center of the
screen like that you have one banana
hole just just feed it yeah everyone a s
this world good I've watched it a
thousand times and it's [__] good you
watched it you live
it uh how was that oh
bad it was like you don't think about
but it's a lot like eating a
basketball you know now that you mention
that in what way in the rubberiness of
this experience [__] I'm crying thinking
about that [__] banana
anime be okay I feel like that game
might end up being a little bit like
player unknowns Battlegrounds which is
like maybe not as to play but like very
fun to watch like groups of people the
best stream ever like the right kind of
people playing it stream it like it you
I there was a moment I played it with
strangers it no like it took like 20
well it took like 20 30 like most the
demo to like sort of like find our
Rhythm one person didn't speak English
that met rough they kept dying um and
I'm not saying that couldn't work but
like watching them I was watching their
demo and I was like oh my gosh like I
would watch this stream of them playing
I'm I'm not even that interested in
playing this game watch them there was a
moment where we were trying to get to an
island because you look at a big Ma
there's a big map on the second like
floor the lower the middle deck and you
have to match that with what the shape
of one of the islands is on the on the
your personal little maps and we figured
that out and we didn't figure out is
that the the middle deck map does not
actually reflect the actual esape of the
sea where there were big [__] rocks
and stuff and there sailes in front of
my eyes I think I was piloting it so I
couldn't see anything so I was counting
on everybody else to tell me what was
all around and Griffin climbed like the
Mast of the ship to be my Lookout oh
yeah and then you [__] fell into the
ocean well the three of us were out
there cuz we knew we couldn't turn the
ship fast enough to get away from the
rocks and so we just went out there and
Justin was like jamming on his accordion
and showing us his [__] map and we
just you can do Under
Water [__] shark under water that was
dope the the like the Justin made a
point uh when we were talking about it
for for a video about like the what the
sticking point is going to be like it's
all about like find and buried treasure
bring it back to the ship what do you do
with the treasure at that point because
if it's like if it's like you think
about it like Destiny where like you get
work with a team to beat a really hard
boss and if you're doing that and
somebody just starts [__] goofing
around you get pissed off about it cuz
you want those rewards cuz they're
desirable and switch from goofball
time this this like griefing simulator
that they've created J sunk our ship
Justin sunk our ship dropped their ship
I did they they all jumped off to swim
to the island and adults I was watching
them and Griffin started getting chased
by a shark and I thought well [__] that
and I raised the anchor by myself and I
ped the boat over and I was like look
guys this is way easier and I jumped out
of the boat and I didn't drop an he
ghost rode the whip right up onto the
right and then we [__] finished that
thing we went out there we hit the pace
button there's a button to do exactly
like one step at a time and it counts it
you dug up the treasure we G brought it
back all proud and [__] he was like
shooting skeletons while caring the
treasure running and then we we turn and
there's a when your ship crashes a
mermaid holds a signal flare up like you
[__]
up yeah that was on me keep the but like
that's funny that that time but like I
don't know after that we do that that
one time and it's like after that like
like how many more mechanics are there
that that would like be like showing
someone the map how drift I was in an
interview with them and they were like
and say you're in a public matchmaking
session with three people and I'm
like no won't be no give me another
options cuz that's not that's in no way
and they said the adver session lasts
like an hour so like the idea of having
a crew of three strangers for an hour
like I don't know if we're really trying
to like get [__] done I don't know I
don't know if that's the ideal SC but
the I think the thing that really is
going to make it the thing I keep coming
back to that I think would be really fun
is the PVP stuff because the last time I
played uh this time we uh respawned our
ship after the mermaid incident and got
on it and then we saw another team ship
just sitting next to us with nobody on
it so we stopped and we lit their ship
the [__] up for no reason except to make
them not have a ship anymore they should
experience what you had to go through
helping their demo but the last the last
time I played I got in a for real ship
fight where we were being chased and
they were you know head on and we
dropped our anchor which lets you
literally drift and destroyed them and
that [__] rules so like that tension of
like oh we've got treasure and we have
to get it back to this island and oh
there's other people trying to stop us
we got to take them down like that
that's good that's like good gameplay
not the like hitting a skeleton with a
sword with a hand shitty
like yeah the shooting and like it feels
like a game Jam game in Search of like a
larger
context they're running a beta right now
they Haven been doing it for a while
right and talking to developers they
actually struggled whether they should
call it a beta or not because the game
industry is ruined what the term beta
means which is largely like a
pre-ordered demo and what they're doing
right now is actually a beta it's like
we have this thing like we like we we
see what happen with them we watch
people streaming it like it's like we
have something but like what do we have
and I just don't that's why like this
like spring 2018 sounds more like fall
2018 or preview program right maybe the
smar way or they somehow find it and
they're like oh okay we know what this
is now boom build it go it reminds me of
spy party kind of like when when spy
party first came out and you played that
you're like that was I was going to say
it reminds me spy party that's no I
think I think it came out not he that
whole game SP part's out right now no
it's not at the bottom of the screen you
see a link spy me and the team Checker
we've been working on it for ages and
we're checker check her out
every come on he's
gone part to present spy party yeah uh
and then there's Skull and Bones the the
Ubisoft Pirate game seemed decidedly
less like fun you know but also like it
looked like hey this might be a good
time if you just like if you're into the
murder part of this thing I bet that was
a bracing bracing time on the sea of
Thieves I bet I have weird like oh I
have a weird thought about that though
because they're basically just
repackaging something something that
they already had made saying like hey
great now it's multiplayer now pay 60
bucks or whatever the hell it's going to
be for this thing that we already had
that we could already like Implement
that we could have for all you you know
that could have been a mode in in Black
Flag and black
flag's Black
Flag fantastic game and
um like I just don't I feel very
uncomfortable with this notion of
companies that are taking something that
they had already had and
I don't know if that's bad though
because like Just Dance is just a raving
rabbits mini game that made them M
gajillion dollars but people eventually
forget that like that was a raving
rabbits mini game people ever
know that's that's real uh that's as
real as Mich Phil Che he could have made
that I like that I like about this uh
this like weird Ubisoft uh pirate battle
game right is that everybody else is
like you know what competitive games
there's only one way to make it well two
sports and shooting people in the face
and Ubisoft was like what if we just
never do that they're like we made
Ubisoft sieg or what Ubisoft
seub got godamn it they're like like
let's get we like we'll get ourselves
away and they made they're like what if
we made a I don't know like you're like
a Samurai and like I don't know like a
night they're like yeah like let's do
that and they're like how do we top that
well you're a boat and then there's
another boat like what are we going what
are we going to get next year it's just
like I don't know you're just two cute
horses and you're like friends I don't
know you're two Eagles and you play it
in virtual reality I don't know their
multiplayer stuff is like I admire you
go back to Assassin's Creed multiplayer
like it's such a different crazy
stuffy right but like I I I think that's
great and I I agree like on one hand
it's like crud because like well I would
like another Black Flag game sure on the
other hand like I don't know that I do
man like I looked that was like you know
like enough time is passed you have to
figure like yeah like they're they're
using that as a core because they're
that team and you know there's that
stuff but I feel like if they're
building a full game around it I don't
know the stuff that they talked about
was like and it's season based
multiplayer I'm like I'm out not the
minute you're like pitching your game on
announce is like yo sports like I just
it's some point you to you have to do
that like and he's
up
not a lot of fake uh not a lot of fake
chatter uh like I feel kind of bad for
the one dude that yeah that one dude the
one guy you guys are going to have more
of this in the show right it's not going
to be I'm not going to be the only human
being in all of A3 doing this oh no no
lot lots of people no no je R to you've
got it you're going to have other people
with yellow shirts on stage right yeah
yeah for sure several people all yellow
shirts are very excited to present this
year there was a distressing lack of
people telling each other to stay frosty
yeah
really bothering oh I don't know that's
that's that was uh like a refreshing
change for video games is like I feel
like we came out of and maybe that's
maybe why people felt like the press
conferences were not all that exciting
because generally speaking they were
fine and it wasn't just like all this
stuff that was just like super like
you're not seeing a lot of Loops of just
like can you believe this [__] happened
look at this [__] like it just did
that just wasn't there I think there's a
log in saying stay frosty while you're
on the beaches of Normandy too it's just
like a general back then stay frosty
yeah no [__] it sucks here that dude
just got his leg blown off yeah but stay
frosty wouldn't have gotten his leg
blown off if he stayed Frosty he wasm
did you notice in the Assassin's Creed
Origins presentation that the dude said
um the team and I have been hard at work
since uh we released Assassin's Creed
Black Flag at 3 years ago and I'm like
um are we just going to all sort of
pretend that was the last one okay fine
yeah yeah the the last one you guys
released assassin's CRA without
assassin's
CL assassin's CRA excuse me you
get if you climb to the Top This is
actually it's a piece of Eden it all
comes together sounds good you get the
Apple up there you get watch videos some
blue [__] doing whatever
explain when Micha would hand the Agro
crab to the kids they would touch it and
see the future the sun expl yeah I know
kill Chris Bell and I guess with that
we'll toss it back to you Mo that was
crazy they would get the the trophy each
time and then they would kill chrisel
every episode you're the best contestant
on the show we've ever had you're really
nailing it you got all this AGG crack
but now we have to kill
you three games in
they well well does anybody remember
that first person that was supposed to
be 3D part of uh Assassin's Creed did
did anybody play this I feel like this
is a hallucination I have there's like a
a first person puzzle game suck at it
and then like Desmond narrated on top of
it like a John upik novel he's like I've
moved to New York and I'm horny like
what is this game real I'm telling you
I'm this is a dream you no and he's like
he's like they won't let me go back to
the farm the pharmaceutical company is
here someone fix Chris what happened to
Chris have you have you been storting
naids again just Lin
L of sweet Nets we got to wrap this up
now after that I'm going to go see if
this game exists we're going to get
proof thanks everyone for coming yeah
busy show tomorrow or you kind of like
wrapped up at this point
anyone oh crack yeah yeah I have to
interview interview Koji eashi cool
which is super cool but I again first
time for everything yeah no that that's
awesome uh he's he's usually a pretty
good interview except for now that all
the stuff about like yoi is the worst
company I don't want to hit me with a
whip yeah uh he did not have the whip
the last time I saw him that makes me
feel a little bit at least not during
the presentation we we saw the
presentation and I presentation I going
to put that on blast real quick cuz I've
had a couple beers all right they did
like a 30 minute presentation on blood
stain that included like a 10-minute
segment on what Castlevania was I it
full PowerPoint wait what are you
talking about [__] blood blood
stain Jud judges it took them 10 minutes
to do that and they couldn't have just
pointed out their game and been like
this one this it's that they did that
they did like a point by PlayStation one
it's this one they did a point by Point
what's different like 3D this time yeah
that was bad and that game seems fine
but fine and then they made us play the
demo after watching them play yeah they
played the demo then you got to play the
demo which is also one of my least
favorite things well thanks everyone for
coming by and closing out with us I know
it's super late uh but but seriously no
thanks for coming and and uh good luck
at the show tomorrow good luck with that
coconut does that tomorrow you going to
eat that hairy fruit it's hard to it's
hard to pick the day when your face dies
from trying to put a big you got to pick
one though feel like you made it this
far what could possibly go wrong yeah a
lot it's a big nut you got to lose your
teeth that's his ho only mouth for his
whole life yeah they have there's
science for that don't worry about it
see Detroit become human it's yeah they
got this whole thing we'll be back
tomorrow with just hours and hours of
guests again
and it's probably going to end how you
think it's going to
we'll be back tomorrow everybody have a
good night thanks for
watching